I want to be here.
>> Good evening. We are back. Uh, in
compliance with chapter 551 open
meetings of the Texas Government Code, I
call to order a regular voting meeting
of the board of trustees of the Austin
Independent School District for
Thursday, November 20th, 2025 at 7:58
p.m. A quorum of the board is physically
present at Austin ISD central office to
conduct this meeting. This meeting is
being broadcast on cable channel 22
through Spectrum Estound Broadband and
on channel 99 through AT&T Universe.
Closed captioning English is available
on those platforms for individuals who
are deaf or heart of hearing. Welcome
and thank you for joining us. Thank you
for sticking with us. Um we will now
move to our first item which is public
testimony items uh for our items on the
voting agenda. Members of the public
wishing to participate in the public
testimony portion of our meeting called
a dedicated Austin ISD phone line in
advance of the meeting to sign up to
speak in person or to audio record their
remarks. Tonight we have 33 people who
signed up to speak in person. We have
119 people who left a recorded message
and we will now move to in-person
testimony first in order to provide as
many opportunities for input as possible
within a limited time period. Each
speaker will be allotted one minute with
no substitutions or yielding of time.
Callers who signed up to speak in person
will be invited to come to the
microphone when their name is called. As
you come to the microphone, please press
a button to turn it on. A device will
light up as you move through your one
minute. When the buzzer sounds, please
make a final thought in a single
sentence. We ask that whether you come
to give a complaint or praise that you
please reference any staff member by
position or abbreviated last name. We
ask that all audience members, whether
speaking or not, please show respect for
others.
Uh our in-person speakers tonight will
be Erica Hoffman, Joseph Ariyaga. Um we
have Lauren Ariyaga who's not coming. So
Erica Hoffman, Joseph Ariyaga, Addison
Culture, and Brennan Griffin. We'll
start with those four. Thank you.
>> Good evening. My name is Erica Hoffman.
I'm a proud member with Education
Austin, a proud teacher at International
High School, and I'm here to talk about
our campus closure. IHS serves newcomer
students ages 14 to 17 who need
specialized scaffolded English language
support in all content areas. Initially,
the plan was for IHS to close and
transition as a program to Navaro High
School. On Friday, we received an
updated plan which removed all language
about a program transition and that
newcomer students will instead be
reporting to their home campus with
newcomer reports. With this update, IHS
staff need to receive priority placement
in openings at secondary high school
campuses where newcomer supports are
offered. We also expect our collective
expertise to be respected with a seat at
the table to further strengthen and
build out the newcomer programming
offered at this level. We expect that
all newcomer students and families will
receive specialized support with quality
programming for all content areas just
as they would at international high
school. Finally, we demand that AISD
step out with courage to defend the
immigrant populations of students,
staff, and community members. You have a
duty to serve. AISD silence and inaction
in the face of this racist deportation
policies and attacks on our community is
a disgrace.
What a journey. But as I tell my son,
anything worth doing is rarely easy. My
comment tonight is simple. Why? Why are
we closing schools in item 14? Why are
schools in item 143 being closed? This
shouldn't be a trick question. According
to the district's own documents, it's
not TAP, it's not teachers, it's not
budget.
If that res isn't crystal clear,
trustees, you should vote no to 14.3. A
no vote is a yes to growing DL, not
shrinking it. A no vote is a yes to the
idea that strong communities can solve
big problems.
A no is a yes to harnessing the power of
this amazing community behind me. Vote
no and let's go get started on the hard
work of turning this district around.
Thank you.
>> Oh, sorry. One sec. Oh, there we go. My
name is Addison Coulter. here to
represent Texas Apples Seed, a
nonprofit, nonpartisan organization that
works at the intersection of policy,
advocacy, and the law to improve the
lives of all Texans. Thank you to the
board and superintendent for this
opportunity to speak. I am here to
discuss how Austin ISD has an
opportunity to decrease economic and
racial segregation as it goes through
the painful process of school
consolidation and redrawing of
attendance zones. Districts across the
state are facing school consolidations
and boundary changes. My research shows
that in the last three academic years,
131 schools have closed in 36 districts
across the state with as many as 60 more
schools slated for closures in 13
additional districts. Even as the city
of Austin has grown, the number of
school age children in the city has not.
Combined with expanding charter schools
and the potential for losing more
students to recently enacted education
savings accounts, it is clear that AISD
faced challenges in student enrollment
that are beyond its control. However,
the segregation of AISD schools is
within its control. Closing schools
without addressing persistent
segregation by race and economic status
will just set schools up for failure. We
measured the index of dissimilarity for
AISD, which quantifies how evenly groups
are distributed across schools. And this
AISD consistently scores at 60% or
higher for black to white segregation,
Hispanic to white segregation, and
economic disadvantage. And I'll let my
colleague speak on this further.
Thank you. Uh
my name is Brennan Griff. My name is
Brennan Griffin, senior deputy director
at Texas Apples Seed. Thanks again for
to the trustees for this opportunity
opportunity to speak. Uh benefits of
school integration are widespread and
well studied. We can provide many
citations around that. Um and it's not a
panacea. nothing is for improving
schools, but uh and I know we've had the
school district has decided to delay
sort of a widespread redrawing of
attendance zones, but we really believe
that this is an important uh thing to
address in the in the coming months. Um
through Texas Apple Seed, I'm an
advocate for safe, effective, and
accountable schools for all students. Uh
as an Austin native who attended AISD
schools, I benefited from from a prior
generation of integration efforts. uh
attending magnet magnet schools before
student populations were separated as
they are now in campuses uh like Lassa.
And as a parent of two AISD students and
a third who will go to AISD schools
soon, I believe that school integration
is really an incredibly important
element uh in any plan to deliver the
kind of education that all students
deserve. Um the the district is uh going
through the second set of school
closures in in the last few years.
uh demographics have changed uh and the
attendance zones have not really been
revised in uh many years in in a
widescale way and many of them don't
make any sense. Many schools have uh
just not even enough students in their
catchment area to fill half the
building. Um I live next to LBJ High
School which is in that situation. Um, I
applaud your willingness to start to
address some of these issues and I think
that this is one of the ways that you
can really go forward in in terms of uh
trying to improve the education we can
offer to all students. Thank you.
>> Thank you. Um, next up we have Tanner
Van Essen, Elizabeth Slama Signs, and
Delicia Mlean and Drew Martinez.
>> It was right. Okay.
Good evening, trustees. Uh, it feels
like we're in a strange place right now.
The board is supposed to work for the
public and the district for the board,
but along the way in this consolidation
process, that seems to have flipped. I
don't know what happened, but it seems
like that's not how this is supposed to
work. Right now, it seems like we're
disregarding our AISD values while
dictating what a plan should be and what
our schools should be on what one
person's view of AISD should look like.
Whether community agrees or doesn't
agree, that doesn't seem to matter.
It seems like this process was already
done the day the draft came out. The
process has been opaque, contradictory,
unidirectional, and actually punitive.
It's an attack on dual language
programming.
This is not leadership. This is not how
we build strong schools. I'm asking you
tonight to do right by these communities
and vote no on 14.3. Give the
communities a chance to make a plan that
strengthens AISD instead of ripping it
apart.
>> My name is Elizabeth Salama Signs. I'm
currently the Riley PTA president, uh,
home of the mighty Mustangs. Um, I begin
with gratitude, clarity, and an
unshakable commitment to public
education. Thank you for considering
keeping u our Mandarin and Spanish
program together. We have weathered
pandemic, broken 504 sped systems,
leadership turnover, all while losing
title one funds. In that chaos,
Principal Alano stepped in and did what
leaders do stabilized the ground under
us and rebuilt systems, culture, expect
and expectations, not perfectly but with
courage and heart. This pro process
taught us that there is opportunity
within every adversity.
We are not afraid. We are ready to show
our equity muscles in the spirit of true
partnership. We will do the work, but
you got to do the walk
with all communities. We trust the
district will show up with support,
communication, and follow through with
every family and all staff members. Uh I
will Oh my goodness. Matias.
Thank you all.
THIS IS A CLASSIC CASE of escalation of
commitment. You see it everywhere. You
see it when someone sits at a slot
machine pulling a lever again and again
because they're convinced the next pull
will be the one. You see it in people
who stay in bad relationships not
because it's working, but because
they've already invested so much that
walking away feels impossible. For those
unfamiliar, escalation of commitment or
sunk cost is when we keep doing
something even after it's clear that
it's a bad idea simply because we poured
so much time, money, or energy into it.
And that's exactly what's happening
here. You agreed to consider school
consolidations this summer, but
superintendent had been preparing these
consolidation for months. You asked for
equity and instead he targeted the
middle class and went after our four
wallto-w walls. His story keeps
shifting. And the data, it's not just
flawed, it's manipulated.
We saw proportions presented with
mismatched sample sizes, building scores
tank because of outdated toilets while
major strengths were ignored. Critical
information like how many EBs are
already in dual language and at which
schools and how many aren't at which
schools. You were pushed towards dual
way dual two uh you were pushed to
toward two-way dual language as a as the
key. Even though research shows no
significant difference in outcomes
compared to one way trustees just
because you were initially open to
closures does not mean that you must
follow through when the foundation of
this plan is based on a manipulation and
deception. Even this week staff continue
to alter public records within 72-hour
window when it's that was explicitly
prohibited. You are not trapped at a
slot machine. You are not bound by your
word. You can still walk away and you
should by voting no to 14.3 as well as 4
14.1 and 14.2.
>> There we go. My name is Drew Martinez
and I'm a parent of a student at Becker
Elementary. When we enrolled in Becker,
we signed a commitment to complete the
dual language program through elementary
school and I believe in honoring
commitments, but I question whether
those who drafted item 14.3 hold the
same value. This plan breaks up
communities and leaves families with
nowhere to go. It eliminates hundreds of
dual language seats in South and Central
Austrian with no available placements
for displaced students. We're told to
just trust us, but that trust has been
broken. The plan was built on rushed,
incomplete data and a process that
actively discouraged community input at
every step in the process. As reflected
now by the district executives that are
on leave, this plan fails to meet its
own academic and financial goals, and it
does not meet TEA requirements.
Closing down a school like Becker does
not serve any purpose than to drive away
families. If the board wants to salvage
long-term trust with the community, then
I urge them to vote no on 14.3.
>> Thank you. Uh, next up we have Carla
Landry, who will be reading for Adam
Sparks, who had to leave early. We have
Stacy Woodburn, Henry, Steve Swanson,
Selena Martinez, and Alfonso Moreno.
Hi, my name is Carla Landry. I am a
parent of two children at Maplewood and
I am presenting this on behalf of Adam
Sparks, also a Maplewood parent. At the
beginning of this process, one of the
trustees said that they would be unable
to vote for this round of school
closures until the financial savings and
enrollment loss from the last round of
school closures was released. We now
have been told that these numbers will
never be forthcoming. And yet, we expect
a yes vote tonight. It is imperative
that this board direct the district to
produce a report next September that
lists campus by campus financial savings
and enrollment loss for each closed
campus. Trustee Boswell has said in a
statement that for every 72 students
that leave the district, AISD loses $1
million. When presented with those
numbers, the superintendent claimed it
wasn't true. The district has no numbers
from 2019 and if left to their own
devices they will not have clear
transparent numbers for 2025 either. I
once again urge the trustees to direct
the administration to provide a school
by school report on the financial
savings and enrollment loss for each
campus that is closed to be presented by
next fall. Thank you.
Trustees, thank you for the tireless
work you're doing in this challenging
moment for AISD. Only a deep devotion to
public education could keep you at this
table, and we stand with you in wanting
a strong future for public schools.
Change is necessary, but this plan is
not.
Every problem the district faces cannot
be solved at once, not successfully.
Please focus on delivering strong
turnaround plans. Let these schools
concentrate on meeting targets without
simultaneously upending everything else
in this district. AISD has incredible
dual language programs that took a
decade to build. Children whose parents
were told to never speak their native
language are bringing it back to their
families. Kids attending a DL program
are learning to be inclusive global
citizens and solve problems in a second
language. These programs are attracting
families to a shrinking district. And
yet, Becker is now the only dual
language program being moved into a
zoned school that cannot fit us. Our
third and fourth graders were not given
the same option to stay together as
other campuses. Even families who live
one block from Becker are now divided
because the new boundary line was
inexplicably drawn through the middle of
our neighborhood. We are the only zip
code where two adjacent neighborhood
schools are slated for closure. Please
support students in need without
destabilizing existing, thriving, and
dedicated communities. Please vote no on
14.3.
Steve Swanson.
>> Good evening. I am Steve Swanson and
again I am grateful for and we must
recognize the importance of our AISD
lawyers, their rules of professional
conduct and their vital role in the
planning of schools. Their rules include
providing our board and superintendent
with an informed understanding of their
legal rights and obligations in chapter
11 of the education code, rights to
training under the TEA and their
obligations and strategies that align
with community-based planning and
actions serving the needs of students,
preventing harm and loss in our schools,
and making effective use of community
resources, stopping our alignment with a
harmful A throughF accountability
system. The condition of our planning
process revealed in the news at board
meetings through public information
requests and by our superintendent
acknowledging the need for integrity
demonstrates the need and opportunity to
start learning and fulfilling rights and
obligations in chapter 11. Please know
acting to prevent harm and loss in our
schools is our lawful responsibility
today and in the future. Instead of
voting on plans tonight, including
school turnaround plans, with the
professional leadership of our lawyers,
let's start learning and fulfilling our
rights and obligations that align with
preventing harm and loss in our schools
and not turn our schools over to the
state. TEA has failed in serving us and
TEA needs to turn around. Thank you.
Yeah.
>> Let's take a moment to think about the
communities and students that will be
impacted by the recommended closures.
This plan lacks vision
and is based in fear which limits your
ability to think creatively.
Unlike the majority of schools on this
closure list, this plan deserves an
unacceptable rating.
President Boswell,
Trustees Kintana,
Trusty Kaufman, Trustee the Urisote,
Trusty Whitley Chu,
Trusty Singh, Trustee Hunter, Trusty
Foster, and Trusty Gonzalez.
You have a choice. You have the power.
Vote no. Thank you.
Hello, my name is Alonso Moreno. I'm a
parent of a pre-K student at Richtop
Elementary. I'm originally from Mexico.
We're a bilingual household and we
transferred to Richup specifically
because of its high quality Spanish
education. I'm grateful to AISD that my
daughter is now on her way to fluently
talking to her grandparents and family
who don't speak English. For many
families in rich like enriched up like
mine, that dual language program pathway
is everything. Closing rich is a
mistake. 14.3 is not a program move.
It's a program closure. If this is about
equity, it seems short-sighted. Closing
a thriving, multi-racial, high achieving
school like Richtop destroys exactly the
kind of integrated community that so
many have fought to build. If this is
about finances, this is not a
responsible plan. You have no attrition
data. Even though attrition is a big
biggest financial threat, the the
options reached up are given are
disingenuous. They do not guarantee dual
language access to our own schools, even
for bilingual families like mine. Our
community went from 60% supportive of
the plan to 90% opposed after Friday's
changes. Giving Richup the same
consideration as the campuses removed
from the closure list would help rebuild
trust in this district. This is a false
trade-off. We do not need to turn
thriving schools into abandoned
buildings to support struggling
campuses. You still have the opportunity
to get this right without destroying
what's already working. Please vote no
on 14.3.
>> Thank you. Next up, we have Rosina
Castanos,
Andrea Hayen, Magdalena Riley, Jason
Rodriguez, and Nikki Schubitz.
>> Test. Okay.
Hi. Hi. My name is Rosina Castanos and
I'm a Becker parent of a second and
fourth grader. I chose a wall-to-wall
dual language program so my kids could
stay connected to my native language and
their heritage. For five years, Becker's
dual language program has shaped their
education and sense of community.
Throughout this process, our community
has made a consistent ask to keep us
together in a South Central location and
to preserve dual language access for the
kids who have invested years in the
program. Despite submitting extensive
feedback and viable solutions that help
achieve AISD's goal to better serve
emergent bilingual students, the latest
version of the plan makes our asks
impossible.
The plan removes hundreds of dual
language seats and does not show how
students will continue their bilingual
path. There is still no verified
financial benefit and the district has
not adequately modeled attrition or the
loss of dual language funding. Those are
financial risks, not savings. Please
vote no on 14.3. Let's regroup and build
a community-driven plan that preserves
dual language funding and supports
AISD's long-term stability. Thank you.
Okay. Um, good evening board members. My
name is Andrea Hayen, director of bands
at Betachch Middle School. For the past
several months, I've held on to hope
that my school, my community might be
spared from the Collins consolidation
and closure plan. I'm sorry I don't cry.
Um, I came to bet four years ago as the
assistant band director and became
headband director in 2023. When I
arrived, the program had seen a new
director every year for four years. My
first goal was simple. Give students
stability. I committed to staying. I
built trust. And together we rebuilt a
program. In 2023, we had 93 students
enrolled in band. Today we have over 220
students.
To the districts, these might just be
numbers, but to me, they are kids who
make me laugh, who challenge me, and who
remind me every day why I drive an hour
from Roundrock to South Austin to be
their teacher. The district doesn't see
the students facing homelessness, food
insecurity, abuse, anxiety, or
instability. But I do. Many of us
support our students in ways that go far
beyond our job title. In my classroom, I
have a wall covered with student
shoutouts, notes, drawings, and messages
from families. Those aren't decorations.
They're reminders of the relationships
and built dress we've built. Better
check is more than a school. It is a
family. And for many kids, it is the
only place where they feel safe,
accepted, and successful. This
consolidation plan threatens all of
that. My students are worried about not
about test scores or budgets, but about
losing their teachers, their friends,
and their sense of belonging. And while
staff have been told we'll be
reassigned, that is not what keeps me up
at night. This isn't about my job. It's
about my kids. It's about Lincoln who
found a home in the band hall and
carries an instrument heavier than he is
every single day. It's about Yaer who
bursts in every day to share the latest
cheeseme. It's about Amy, Gerald, Za,
Natalie, Ramito, Brian, Mona, Haley,
Joseph, and so many others whose lives
are rooted at Betachch. Middle school is
already one of the hardest stages of
childhood. Asking students to start over
across three different campuses to
rebuild friendships, to search for
trusted adults, to try to find where
they fit is not what's best for their
emotional or academic well-being. I
understand that Betach needs support. I
understand the need for a tap plan, but
many of our families do not have access
to tutoring, transportation, or outside
resources. Many of our students go home
to care for younger siblings while their
parents work night shifts. Many walk
bike or take the city bus to school.
Instead of closing our doors and
scattering our students to a failing
school, a charter school, and a fine
arts academy that is unprepared for a
tap plan or the needs of our students,
we should invest in the community that
already exists at Betach. Our students
>> and I'm so sorry to interrupt. We have a
lot of speakers.
>> Oh, I understand. I just respectfully
ask that you reconsider the closure of
betichek. Give us the opportunity to
implement a standard tap plan and show
that our students can accomplish help
everything. Help me keep my promise to
them that I will stay, that I will not
give up to them, and that they matter
beyond measure. Thank you for your time.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
Okay. Hi. Uh, my name is Magdalena. I
want to thank everyone for allowing us
to speak. I want to thank the district
and the board of trustees for all your
work. I know you're up against a lot.
Um, I am a Becker bomb of two. I'm going
to say something unpopular and the only
reason I'm going to say it is because
it's true, which is this final draft.
The first thing I did when I looked at
it was start looking at options outside
of the school district. I'm sorry that
I'm breaking up, but and that is not
what happened when I saw the first two
drafts. And I want to make that clear. I
have a very precocious child. I know
that's not the goal. Like he's not the
kid that dual language is designed for,
but dual language is the reason we're
keeping him in public school. He has not
been served well by public school
because he's kind of too smart. But dual
language and the Becker community are
the reason that we have stayed in public
school. And so the only thing I'm asking
is for everyone to consider all of the
needs that are being met by these
programs. I think emergent bilingual
need to be the center of the programs.
The programs need to change to serve
them. But I think we also need to
protect the other needs that are being
met by these programs by voting no on
14.3 or offering amendment that lets
Becker stay in dual language and
together as a community. Thank you.
Okay, hopefully this is working. Um,
in this season of thanks, I want to
thank the principles of our TAP schools.
The Calvary is finally coming to serve
your students, but it's trampling right
over you. AISD showed up too late and is
taking your job and your students away,
and I'm so sorry. You are not the cause
of your schools closing.
Thank you for the many more months that
you will work this year to grow your
schools. And thank you for the years you
invested in them back when it was just
you and your school community in the
area nonprofits doing the work. Your
commitment is obvious and our thanks
should be coming from every corner of
Austin ISD.
Thank you to the AISD staff and trustees
for this monumental work that you are
involved in to rightsize our schools and
our districts.
Thank you to teachers at TAP campuses.
The work that you do does not always
deserve receive the respect it deserves
and or nor the pay. The jobs are harder
than the jobs at other schools. You show
up each day to inspire, connect, and
lift up the kids in this those
communities. And thank you for the
caring way that you are navigating this
heart-wrenching season. Moving forward,
we must learn from the circumstances
that led us here. Our commitment must be
to sustain the community investments
made and to ensure every staff member
and principal transitioning from these
campuses is fully supported. We owe it
to them and to our students to get this
next chapter right.
Thank you. Is Jason Rodriguez here?
Okay, Jason shows up. He can jump in
line when he uh shows up again. Uh, next
up is Mary Alice Ruiz, Pim Mayo, Teao
Vhil,
Erica Fink, and Maria Murphy Mayberry,
little flower.
Good evening,
esteemed board members and
superintendent Matias. I I have to open
with a little flower that was given to
me, made for me special by two students.
And uh, this is why we do the work for
our children. And it's all about keeping
their dreams and hopes alive. I spoke to
that last time. And I I'm, you know, the
dyslexia interventionist, special ed
certified. I also serve on the CAC and
now recently recruited for uh being Ed
Austin representative. Um I'm busy and
so I just wanted to begin thanking you
on behalf of our community to uh
trustees Kintana Canina. I'm sorry, not
Canina Kintana. I'm so tired guys. I'm
sorry for coming to our CAC meeting and
for attending our event that we had and
also CAC meeting. You listened to our
concerns, answered our questions and
also board members because it's evident
from the plan. Providing that
opportunity for all students to come to
our school, remain at our school is
paramount for their dreams to continue.
And we wanted just to let you know that
we appreciate it and we want to also pay
uh or applaud all the community members,
parents, students,
um families for the advocacy work. We
stand together in unity. I know it's
difficult. It has been difficult for us
and I appreciate it. Sorry, I'm really
tired tonight, but thank you.
>> Thank you.
Uh, is Pim Mayo here?
>> Awesome. Thank you. And then after Pim,
it will be Teao. Thank you.
>> Okay, I pushed the button. No, it's on.
Okay. My name is Pim Mayo. I'm a parent
of two ridgetop rattlers speaking
tonight only as a parent. You must vote
no on agenda item 14.3. The proposed
dual language program changes violate
TEA rules which are adopted into ASD
policy EHBE. According to rule 89.1227,
AISD must continue dual language
programming for current DL students.
This is a mandate, not a suggestion.
Item 14.3 does not provide DL
continuity. There are simply not enough
seats. Combining Becker, Riley, Richtop,
and Sensa Valley into ODM, Pickles,
Sanchez, and Wooten leaves 750 students
without access to dual language. This
number was calculated using the data
rubric's projected enrollment for next
school year. This in and of itself shows
ASD does not intend to provide the
required continuity in violation of TA
rules in ASD policy. The district also
bears responsibility for ending dual
language for students who started just a
few weeks ago at a school that is now
slated to close. Kids like my prek son.
By closing four dual language programs,
ASD is not just breaking a promise to
our families. If ASD is found in
violation of rule 89.1227,
a TEA takeover won't be because parents
objected to this plan. It will be
because you violated or you failed to
comply with TEA rules.
>> Stand up. Stand up on it.
Hello, my name is My name is Teao and I
am in third grade at Richtop. I want to
ask you please save my school. Adults
always tell kids that our voices matter.
You tell us to be leaders and to speak
up. So I am speaking up today because
this is very important to me and to my
friends at school. I learned to listen
to my feelings. When I when I think
about this plan, it makes me feel sad,
worried, and confused. I think you
should listen to your feelings, too.
Good choices do not feel like this. They
shouldn't feel bad.
That's our body telling you to stop. We
love Richtop. We love learning Spanish.
We love learning fun stuff in fun ways.
Our teachers care about us. Our lunch
ladies care about us. Everyone at
everyone at our school feel makes us
feel safe. None of my friends want to
leave. I don't think kids should be
split from each other. We want to stay
together. All kids matter the same.
Adults should not pick and choose
between schools. All kids are good,
including us kids at RichTop. I know you
already made a plan, but grown-ups can
change their minds when something does
not feel right anymore. Please say no to
this plan. Or if you really think you
need to close Rich Top, please do it
slowly.
You can change your mind. Adults can do
that. Thanks.
WOOHOO.
TEAO, before we go to our next speaker,
I want to say thank you so much to you
and your friends for being here. We
don't hear from students nearly as often
as we would like, and I really want to
thank you for coming to talk to us.
>> Thank you so much.
All right, Erica, try to top that.
>> All right, that's impossible. That's
>> I want green. Thought that was going to
happen and it did. All right. Good
evening. I'm Erica Frink and I'm
speaking on behalf of Ridgetop families
urging you to vote no on 14.3.
My own rattler is in first grade at
Ridgetop and my second will start prek
next year. Our students who currently
have a safe under 10-minute walk to a
highly rated program were suddenly given
an impossible inequitable choice. Attend
an F-rated school under a tap to keep
dual language or move to our newly zoned
school Riley with a 40minute walk that
crosses both airport and 290.
For most families, an unearned tap with
a two-year star-heavy focus is not a
viable option. The TAP was not part of
the plan until Friday, six days ago. We
feel blindsided. We feel betrayed.
And we're not alone. Riley Dual Language
and Becker are right here with us. We
when we choose neighborhood campuses
over TAP, it will splinter friendships
across multiple schools and it will
overcrowd Riley. There is no TEA
deadline requiring these last minute
program changes. Finding reasonable
solutions for these three schools will
not break the budget. Tonight, we urge
you to vote no on item 14.3. so our
students can stay in dual language
without tap, stay safe on their commute,
and stay in their successful
neighborhood schools they love. Thank
you for being here and appreciate it.
Did I start it? Oh, hi. My name is
Maria. Um, I am a parent of two AISD
students and even though we're a
transfer family, we've been part of the
Becker community since 2017.
I appreciate the time dedicated to this
process by the board and want to ask for
your accountability on your important
duty to provide fiscal oversight of the
district and our public tax dollars.
Item 14.3 proposes to close three
financially stable campuses, but the
district has not provided an expense or
savings budget or shown projected income
loss from student attrition specific to
this plan in the backup. This is bare
minimum information that has been
requested by the board and the
community. It is needed to understand if
the true savings realized are actually
enough to benefit the district long term
and to justify the current harm being
caused to students, educators, and
communities. The public needs to trust
not just the district, but our elected
board as responsible stewards of our
students education, our educators
livelihoods, and our public tax dollars.
A vote to enact 14.3 with no financials
considered is in direct conflict with
your duties as a board and destroys any
belief that you are exercising
independent oversight on behalf of our
community. Please vote no on 14.3.
Thank you. Next up we have Christine
Allen, Cheryl Bradley, Natalie Wilson,
and Rebecca Steen.
Is it on? Okay.
My name is Christine Allen and I'm a
Becker and and and I'm a a parent of a
fifth grader at Becker Elementary and a
passionate advocate of linguistic
justice. However, I am not here tonight
to talk about those things. I am against
item uh item 14.2 which imposes the most
draconian tea punishment aka turnaround
strategy on Bington, Dawson, Oak
Springs, Wedane, Win, Betach, and
Martin.
It was the city and the district, by the
way, where the hell is the city? Um,
that opted out of writing the wrongs of
extreme segregation and inequity for
decades, thus denying a quality
education to generations of our
workingclass black and Latino families.
Don't contend them to the tea equivalent
of the death penalty for a crime they
did not commit.
They are not dead branches, nor are they
barren soil.
F furthermore, I oppose I I oppose
closing any schools including Becker,
Sunset Valley, and Ridgetop without
giving all affected non-managerial
workers a seat at the table. To start,
give them an anonymous input mechanism
to remove the fear of retaliation during
the reassignment process. The workers of
AISD, the teachers, the front desk
staff, the custodians, counselors, food
service workers, and librarians are not
consumables. They are the cornerstone of
our children's well-being and success
and and a democratic future for us all.
Please treat them as such. Thank you.
>> Good evening, trustees. Superintendent,
I do have a concern. Trustee Boswell,
you asked some very good questions and
you spoke of your concern with wind
going to Andrews and the disadvantaged
economically disadvantaged students
there. Well, I agree. But you also have
the same issue with that portion of
students going to Pan Springs. Then you
also have the same issue with Oak
Springs going to Blackshire. Blackshire
may be overall a C, but if you look how
economically disadvantaged students are
rated, it's D and F. This district has
slid into segregationism,
y'all. You just can't go backwards. And
that's what's happening. It's racist.
It's classism. You just can't do it. So,
yes, I want the board to look at 14.1
14.2 2 14.3
and not only do you have emerging
bilingual but there are African-American
students in this district as well. No
one speaks about them. They're not on
the news. If you look at you see very
well you see Nelson Linder back there.
You see the teachers right here and you
see me. You've broken the trust of our
community. We don't trust you and nor do
you do anything to regain that trust.
Our children are spreading everywhere.
They're at Blackshire that they're at
Oak Springs.
You've got to re regain that trust, but
you don't do anything. But you expect us
to trust you. Well, we don't.
>> We don't. And I was called the forever
trustee. Well, I am the forever trustee
because you have my granddaughter and as
long as you have her, you have me.
In 1935, the descendants of Herman E.
Becker sold three acres to the Austin
public free schools for $1. Herman
Becker Elementary is the first
elementary school south of the river and
has been continuously occupied since
1936.
In many ways, Becker is part and parcel
of the history of the development of the
South Austin community. There is no
current AISD policy that is being
violated by the current dual language
classroom configurations.
and if anything in Royal Austin has
hampered individual campuses ability to
prioritize emergent bilingual students.
So wall-to-wall campuses are being
uprooted based on a not yet adopted
policy. We have not received any
assurances that there will be faithful
implementation of the wall-to-wall dual
language programs moving to other
campuses. Please vote no on the closure
of the four wall-to-wall dual language
campuses. If you must take Becker's dual
language program, please at the very
least leave us with a neighborhood
school and the tools to rebuild.
Trustees, are you comfortable being the
board that votes to close the first
elementary school in South Austin?
Hi there. I think it's working. My name
is Rebecca. Um, I've been here since uh
2000. I got here as quick as I could.
Um, and I've worked in all parts of
Austin and I've made friends with people
and children in all parts of Austin. So,
I'm here for Becker, but more than
anything, I don't want you to close any
school, right? Um,
the one thing that I'm going to talk
about though is are we just trying to
close dual language schools? This plan
reduces all options in South Central
Austin. Dawson zone to Galindo, Sunset
Valley's push to ODM. And with Dawson
being taken off the table, that
eliminates the overflow that many
families were counting on. We're no
longer moving programs. We're just
closing schools, three of which are
excelling. Sunset Valley is at 65%
capacity, but Becker and Ridgetop,
they're over capacity and weight listed.
It took 14 years to build these thriving
communities, which can't easily be
replicated. Don't blow apart things at
work. Focus on the kids. This year, TE
is requiring you to vote on taps and
let's start there. People are leaving
the district. People are starting
Spanish immersion home pods and moving
to Spain. They're moving to Spain.
Read the room. Know your audience. You
will lose enrollment. Vote no on 143.
Thank you all. We have five more
in-person speakers. Next up is Ashley
Kimble, Eric Ramos, Jason Rodri
Rodriguez, Nelson Linder, and Robert
Johnson. Thank you.
>> Get my readers here.
Do we push this button?
>> You're good.
>> Oh, just kidding. Um, so we've heard a
lot of great things already, so I'm
going to make mine really short. I get
that you all are faced with some very
difficult choices and related to budgets
and consolidation here, but I do feel
like you need to have at least have an
understanding of the impact of the
children and the families and the
communities. And I know a lot of people
have already talked about that. Um, but
I think just having so much change
happening across our city at one time, I
think we have no idea of the impact and
the ripple effect that that's going to
have next year. So, just in in worrying
about that as a as a starting point. Um,
but I think just the awareness of just
Becker being specifically as obviously
I'm here for Becker, uh, that we are a
90year-old community that has taken nine
decades to build. We have the largest
presence at the annual Martin Luther
King march. We take three bus loads of
people. I'm taking a day off school. You
know, everybody already has off, but
they're the parents. Everyone is there.
So that is because we believe in love
and equality and sharing those values.
We have a green classroom that's been
there for 40 years. It is run by 140
parent volunteers, many of which are
here and volunteer that they get to have
that communicate, that connection with
the children in their schools, in that
community. We have a gala and a party
every year. Um, so these children are
learning about how to grow and cook
their own food. Every week they're in
that garden. So these are things I think
across the city, programs that need to
be replicated and not squashed. I didn't
even mention the dual language program.
My children are actually out of Becca
right now, but I've been in the
neighborhood for 18 years. It is the
cornerstone of our community. And the
good energy that we create and spread
from this bubble is palpable. And it is
going if it the school goes away, that
energy will will leave our bubble. So
just I think there's a ripple effect
that I think we're just not even aware
of that's going to happen. So hang on to
our pants, y'all. Vote no. Vote no.
>> Okay. So, my name is Eric Robos and I'm
proud to be in my 11th year teaching at
Martin Middle School. But I have two
requests for you tonight. One
is that you truly talk to the
communities of schools are closing. And
I don't mean at sometime in the future.
I mean Monday, December 1st. You get
tomorrow to recover from this meeting
and Monday we start.
Because this district has a history of
promising to everyone but delivering to
few.
My
my second request is that we have
a public open transparent communication
about what removing the three schools
and all the boundary changes did to our
budget and how that's going to look
going forward because we all know we're
in a bad budget situation and every
little bit counts. So, I think it's
clear, it needs to be clear to the
community what that did and how that's
going to look going forward because we
have much more tough conversations
going. Thank you.
Guess up next, right, we've got two
items here. This is an article in 2007
under superintendent uh for Joan. This
is your own equity assignment book about
equity in this system that most you
probably didn't like, but that's another
conversation.
My name is Nelson Linder.
I am the president of the Austin NAACP.
I'm here tonight based on a concept
called equal protection of the law for
all children. I'm also a parent. I
maintain that all of you are also
parents. These children depend on you
and your support to accomplish
their goal. In 2007, it says that you
guys frowned on the idea of school
closure. I've been watching you in
secret the past few months. I don't see
any frown. I see you've already
submitted
to a state agency that's violating
equal protection law. You're liking one
thing. Concern for your students. You're
their protectors.
like a fear of fascist organizations and
a commitment to make these communities
stay together. When you close a school,
that is a that is a catismic experience.
These kids have fear. They lose their
familiarity. The parents are under
stress. That would never create
effective schools. To even do that to me
is a violation of your oath and
profession.
As I close out, these problems are
solvable.
But when you abandon your schools, your
neighborhood, your children, my
children, our schools, that's also a
violation of democracy.
As I close out, let me share some about
democracy. The word comes from ancient
Greece. Demos means people. They are the
foundation.
Means authority. Right now, folks have
too much authority. I want to challenge
you to regain your courage and think
about these families and these children
that are entitled to equal protection of
the law even though we're in a fastest
environment. And I want to challenge you
to look at yourself in the mirror. See
how do you feel sacrificing your schools
because you say they're not they're not
failing. And one final point, our school
are not failing. We are failing as
administrators, educators. When our
schools fail, because you have failed.
Stand up.
Be counted. Embrace all of your children
because of race
ensure they get the resources they need.
And don't let fascist
organization with too much power
scare you
where you actually abandon
our children.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you. One more speaker, I think.
Yes. Thank you.
>> You guys are making it hard to follow.
Um, just hit the button.
>> You're set.
>> I'm set. Okay, here we go. Uh, my name
is Robert Johnson. I have three children
and this is my eighth year as a Sunset
Valley parent. After this year, I have
one elementary age child. We want to
continue their dual language education,
and if this plan passes, we will send
them to ODM. My argument is not down to
the level of a programming or where I
have to drive my children. Of five
elementary schools in Southwest Austin,
Sunset Valley scored the highest on the
data rubric created and scored by AISD.
The scores were not close. Sunset Valley
barely missed the middle quintile with
two schools in the fourth quintile and
two just out of the bottom quintile.
Despite these numbers, Sansa Valley was
the one selected for closure. We've been
told that there are many factors that go
into the decisions to close schools, but
I've been given no solid data.
Explanation on these factors is owed to
all the families of all the schools
closing.
Senza Valley is a soughtafter and
exemplary dual language school on a
beautiful campus with a police
department 400 yards away that is
dedicated to the safety of the children
from drop off to pickup every day. ODM,
a Southwest Austin neighborhood school,
is having the dual language programed
upon upon them and becoming non-zoned.
In the feedback I have seen and heard,
families are upset about losing their
neighborhood school. I used to think
this process was has been rushed. I
still think that, but the true failure
has been that this process has the
illusion that anyone in the
administration is listening or cares.
Week after week of platitudes has led
the com has led to the complete
resignation that there's nothing anyone
can do. The fight has fallen out of a
lot of parents. You're going to lose
students and you're going to lose parent
volunteers. Thank you.
>> Thank you to all of our in-person
speakers. Um we will now play recorded
messages for public testimony. So please
listen carefully.
Hi, this is Leah Smith calling about
turnaround plans, consolidations, and
program moves. I'm a parent at Riley
Elementary. Thank you for hearing us and
letting us keep our dual language
communities together moving to Wooten.
We understand the need to move and are
happy to join the Wooten community. Our
turnaround program and with her
experience feels that this is something
she's confident about. We trust our
leadership and staff to accomplish this.
the TI the turnaround plan is better
than a TEA takeover. I also appreciate
having the option to stay at the Riley
neighborhood school and reboot it. I
feel like there's a lot of opportunities
there. I know there may still be details
to work out, but I hope you vote yes so
that we can move forward and just plan
for next year. Thank you.
Hi, my name is Jill Carly and I am a
parent at Richtop Elementary slated for
closure despite strong accountability
scores and an overwhelmingly popular
program. I was on board with the
district's equity arguments, with the
budget arguments, with the first round
of consolidation plans, but the
refinements of the last two weeks amount
to an inequitable dissolution of our
program. If it's imp so important to get
it right for Maplewood and Bricker
Woods, why is Ridgetop not given the
same consideration now that the closure
is no longer linked to a tap? Pick an
argument and stick with it or stop
emphasizing that process matters to you.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Candace Knight. I'm
the parent of a fourth grade student at
Rididgetop Elementary.
I'm calling to urge you to vote no on
14.3 which would close ridgetop. The
reason why is because there was a last
minute change to the plan just 5 days
ago before the vote. The plan before was
to close ridgetop but to allow the
entire community to move to pickle in a
wall-to-all dual language program in a
school with no tap. That changed just 5
days ago. Now, Ridgetop will close, but
there is no access for the entire
community to move to um any particular
school with wall-to-wall dual language,
and all of the options for us uh will
have taps. This is a huge change. It is
unacceptable to the Ridgetop community.
I'm a big advocate for public education
in Austin ISD, but you are leaving me no
choice but to leave the district if this
plan goes forward. Vote no on 14.3.
Hi, my name is Rachel Bowen and I'm a
parent of two kids at Blackshire
Elementary School. I support the plan to
welcome Oakream students into
Blackshere. But to have a successful
turnaround plan, our students need
stability, not more change. With that in
mind, please do not close the historic
Blackure campus. In addition to Black's
important legacy, its specific location
has significant benefits with proximity
to Keelin Middle School, Carver Library,
and Houston Telegram. Partnering with HT
gives us a diverse uh a direct source of
diverse teachers, enabling our school to
stay fully staffed even amid challenging
teacher shortages. While Blackshire is
historic, it's wellmaintained and has
the space to accommodate our larger
attendance boundary. Building more seats
when we have two students doesn't make
sense. It would be more cost-effective
to fully modernize Black Share rather
than building a newer and smaller
school. Thank you for listening and for
your work to strengthen our public
schools.
My name is Andy Selby. I'm a 60-year
resident uh living in Terry Town and
then Balden. Um I urge the board to
tweak its plan for consolidation to
preserve either the Becker or Dawson
campuses. So we have uh one South
Central campus left uh uh besides Travis
Heights that serves people by providing
dual language. I know you've got a tweak
proposed to you signed by a number of
individuals uh uh who have kids in the
schools. Uh we sent our child uh before
there was dual language anywhere but
Sanchez through Sanchez years ago. Great
program had a she got what she needed.
Very difficult though long time ago. Now
you've got a thriving program at Becker
that you're about to explode. You're
also hollowing out South Central Austin.
schools, much like Peas, was diminished
and disappeared in central Austin.
Notice no schools nuked west uh east of
Lamar. None at all. Thank you for your
service, especially because you deserve
um every compliment for working as hard
as you do.
>> Hi, my name is Gabe Hernandez and I'm a
parent of a student at Black Share
Elementary School. I'm calling to
support the consolidation of Oak Springs
and Black Share Elementary School, but I
want to be clear that I do not wish for
the consolidated Black Share to move to
a new construction at Oak Springs. I
think multiple moves will be disruptive
while students and teachers are focusing
on the turnaround plan.
>> Hi, my name is Cindy Reed and I'm
calling as a concerned Richtop parent
asking you to vote no on 14.3.
Friday's plan is not a programmatic
move. It is a program's closure. It is
something completely different than what
has been communicated to rich parents
this whole process with less than one
week's notice and zero parental
involvement. We are urging you to vote
no on 14.3 and give this the time to
have collaboration that it needs. We
were supportive of moving as a community
to pickle and now we will be completely
fractured spread throughout the
district. We need to prioritize all
children's education and since ridgetop
is no longer connected to supporting and
keeping a cap away from the district. We
urge you to vote no especially since
this this plan relies on portables
against the AISD directive. More than
87% of Ridgeaw parents now have shifted
and do not support this plan. Whereas
almost 60% of us supported it. Vote no
on 14.3. Please listen to the families.
Please include us in this decision
making. My name is Julie Whmer and my
home is zoned to Riley Elementary School
and um I would like to ask the board to
delay changes to the dual language
programs including changes to Riley
Elementary. Um in asking this I'm
aligned with the uh ask by the Becker
Elementary PTA. Um there just hasn't
been sufficient time and community input
for the drastic changes that are being
suggested for the dual language
programs. Um and especially for my
neighborhood that is zoned to Riley, the
community has not had sufficient input
into uh what's to come for that
elementary school. So, I would advocate
for the TAP changes to be made um and
for changes to the dual language
programs to to be um held for for
further community input. Thanks.
My name is Emily Trevinho. I'm an Austin
native Becker parent and a first-time
caller, urging you to vote no on 14.3.
We have patiently participated in each
step of this consolidation process,
recognizing the immense challenges the
district faces. Yet, with each version
of the plan, we have watched Becker's
community become more fractured and
opportunities to continue with dual
language learning disappear. At this
point, our bilingual sons no longer have
a clear path to continue learning one of
their heritage languages at school. We
support Fanche continuing to be a zoned
campus serving its neighborhood, but
it's clear that there isn't sufficient
space for us there or in our
neighborhood dual language program. This
process was rushed and lacked
transparency, community voice, and data
that would have helped communities shape
a better plan. Sadly, trust has been
broken. Please vote no on 14.3.
I'm a parent of two students at Blackure
Fine Arts Elementary School. I
appreciate the engagement and
communication about consolidation and
tea accountability this year and I'm
hopeful that we can avoid a state
involvement with our school district. I
support the boundary change that
consolidates Oak Springs in Black
Elementary which I understand is set to
be voted on today. I also appreciate the
opportunity to continue to discuss the
transition of and future campus
location. The future campus location is
an important and impactful decision.
Keeping the school at the historic
Blackshire campus has clear benefits.
For example, the building is in good
condition. There is capacity for all
students. Teachers and staff have
experience running the school when when
it was over 400 students. Current
teachers have demonstrated success in
improving the school accountability
rating. The historic nature of the
school helps attract and maintain
experienced teachers. There's diversity
among students and teachers. Supportive
services are available and the building
accommodates fine arts programming. It's
all there. Why move? I request an
opportunity to meet with both school
communities and the AISD leadership
before a decision is made. Thank you.
>> My name is Jeff Hopkins. I'm a Ridgetop
parent. From the beginning of this
process, the Ridgetop community has been
mostly united in solidarity behind our
principal in supporting this plan. We
moved forward in good faith with the
district to do in our minds our part in
ensuring a successful 2526 school year.
Knowing that these changes were likely
to cause risks in our community, what
was top of mind for most of us was
solidarity and staying as together as
possible. No one wanted to see this good
thing end. It is hard today not to feel
like we have been stabbed in the back.
At every turn, it seems the district is
listening to everyone but us. A school
community that should have been
considered a crown jewel of AISD is
shattered, scattered to the wind, and
left to figure it out on their own. No
matter how you vote tonight, the rift
that we all feared is here. It is
irrevocable and you are going to hear it
because AISD has now sent a message loud
and clear to all parents. Be loud. Be
uncooperative. Be angry. It works.
My name is Mark Whmer and my children
attend Riley Elementary. Please vote
against the changes to wall-to-wall dual
language programs. Since the initial
plan came out in October, we've been
urged to just accept the plan as we were
told our programs were just moving to a
new location that everything would be
the same, including the principal and
staff. Now, at the last minute, the
district has completely changed course
and now our programs are going to an
existing school with two unacceptable
academic ratings. This is a drastic
departure from the earlier drafts and
the district never bothered to discuss
them with our community or solicit our
feedback. Now, parents at Riley,
Richtop, and Becker are being asked to
decide whether to give up on dual
language education or attend a failing
school where there are no guarantees
there'll be space for their kids or who
will even be staffing those schools.
Because of the lack of community
engagement on this issue, including with
Wooten, Pickle, and Sanchez, who might
not want their schools to be overtaken
by these programs, families have lost
faith in the district's handling of this
plan. I'm asking you to vote no on item
14.3 so Riley, Ridgetop, and Becker's
dual language programs can remain in
their current locations for next year.
Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Claire Croslin. I'm
calling from Riley. This is my third
take. So, um I want to encourage the
board to vote yes on the current plan.
Please, uh let's get started on planning
for the next school year. Um, my family
hasn't decided whether or not we're
going to Wooten or to
stay at Riley, but we really need to
understand what these options look like
as soon as possible to make our
decision. So, we love that Mandarin is
sticking around at Wooten. We hope that
um with the turnaround plan and the new
programming there and we hope that the
uh that the that the Riley Monatory
Strand and neighborhood strand will um
get a leader soon that um can really
prepare the school for um the fresh
start. So, thank you so much for voting
yes and um that's my time. Thanks. Bye.
Hello, my name is Pette Wooden and I am
the proud parent of twin girls at
Richtop Elementary. My girls have been
thriving in their wall-to-wall dual
language program. Our community has been
patient and has tried to work along the
parameters of the initial draft.
However, Friday's draft gives our
community unacceptable options for next
year and beyond. Please take the time to
not rush this vote. Please vote no on
14.3. Thank you.
Hi, my name is Ashley Mong. I'm a parent
of two students in the Riley Mandarin
Dual Language Program. I want to say
thank you for keeping the program
centrally located at Wooten Elementary
in the updated plan. This program has
proven success and with continued AIC
support, it can further increase
enrollment and better serve emergent
bilingual students. I look forward to
ongoing investment in resources for this
program. I hope that AISD will
strengthen the recruitment and marketing
efforts to ensure the Mandarin dual
language program is accessible to
Asian-American emergent bilingual
students who remain under reppresented
in the current enrollment. Thank you so
much.
>> Hi, my name is May. I'm a parent of two
children in the reside area of Richtop
Elementary. First, I just wanted to
thank the district for do taking the
time um and feedback from schools such
as Pickle and Wooten into consideration
for this most recent plan. However, now
that the pro programmatic changes are no
longer tied to taps, I asked the board
to consider delaying the programmatic
closures to analyze alongside the
boundary and consolidation closures that
are now slated for next year. The plan
released Friday not only significantly
changes the dual language schools, but
it also results in potentially potential
capacity issues at Riley Elementary,
trying to fit Riley reside, Rididgetop
reside, and the wind community into one
school with just about 300 seats. This
also allows for us not to really have
any time um to give you guys feedback on
the most recent changes. So, please
consider focusing this year on the
turnaround plans and minimize further
disruption by addressing these
programmatic and boundary consolidations
more holistically next year. Thank you.
>> Hi, this is Janet Pollock, a parent at
Woodshop Elementary. Um and I have a
question comment on 14.3.
Seeing as the district has changed the
draft for the programmatic change for
dual language so many times, why does
this need to be done this year? Rich
especially is no longer connected to the
tap as pickle is remaining a zone
school. It seems as if Maplewood and
Burgerwoods are getting another year to
quote unquote make sure that they get it
right. Why isn't Rich given the same
courtesy? With all the recent changes in
language and lack of clarity that the
1114 draft put out, many parents have
lost faith in the current plan. One more
year at Ridgetop surely won't break the
budget. If you want our community to be
behind you, you need to get it right the
first time and then we will support the
implementation. We understand and
support moving to a more emerging
bilingual population, but not at the
expense of the current richtop
community. Thank you.
>> Hello trustees. This is Deborah Bon, a
mom from Richtop. I'm asking you to vote
no on item 14.3.
Friday's sudden change from a program
move to a program closure for Richtop
without community engagement since that
new news breaks months of AISD as
assurances. It would dismantle
high-erforming diverse dual language
program and scatter students across
multiple campuses. It also makes no
sense to close a successful school and
send students to a campus under a
statemandated TAP plan. This process has
been flawed and a new proposal has had
no stakeholder feedback. 87% of surveyed
ridgetop caretakers urge you to vote no
on item 14.3.
This vote is separate from TAP
requirements.
Thank you.
>> This is Michelle at Ridgetop Mom. The
district has a goal to balance
enrollment. However, the 11th hour
changes they made on Friday exacerbate
the enrollment imbalance in central
Austin and guarantee reliance on
portables against as a AISD directive.
Rather than enticing families to move to
an underenrolled campus by relocating
thriing wall-to-wall dual language
program intact, the new plan instead
closes program and school while
providing no equivalent option for
displaced families to move to. Moreover,
the plan relocates the wind monatory
program whose current enrollment would
fill 95% of the Riley building capacity
as a strand within Riley while also
having Riley absorb the entire ridgetop
zone. If Ridgeop is closed, zone
families are having their school shut
down because we were told it is too
small and relies on portables, only to
be moved into a school that is too small
for the proposed population and will
have to rely on portables.
Friday's unexpected changes dramatically
reshape the reality for Ridgetop
families and undermine the district's
own objectives to balance enrollment.
Please vote no on 14.3 and give the
district time to do the proper due
diligence and solicit community.
>> My name is Rochelle Olivarez. I'm a
parent of a third grader at Weedane
Elementary.
Each school deserves to be heard. Every
school individually deserves a vote on
their tap. I urge you to separate out
the vote or agenda item 14.3.
Separate the vote for each of the taps.
We deserve your votes on record for each
school. I urge you to vote no for a weed
closure and approve the amended weeding
restart
proposal.
Thank you.
Hello, I am a mom to a third gradetop
student. I'm asking you to vote no on
item 14.3. This last minute change
breaks Austin ISD's original commitment
and every draft released. We were told
would move together to pickle, an
unzoned wall-to-wall dual language
campus where our students were
guaranteed a spot. As of Friday, that
plan suddenly changed, scattering our
community across five campuses. Richtop
families trusted Austin ISD and worked
in good fa faith to strengthen the
proposal. We supported serving more
emerging bilingual students. Yet a
drastically different plan appeared
without any feedback from our community.
This process has been flawed and changes
with no community input should be
delayed. Most importantly, this shift
does not prioritize children because it
fractures the ridgetop community for
transparency, stability, and student
centered planning. Please vote no on
item 14.3. Let's take the time to get
this right.
>> Hello, my name is Adrienne Maness. I
have a third grader in the Spanish
program at Riley Elementary. I want to
strongly encourage the board to vote in
favor of the plan. No one thinks the
situation's ideal, but a tea takeover
would be the absolute worst possible
outcome. And Riley families understand
this. We're supportive of the plan to
move our dual language programs a short
distance away to Wooten and to merge
with their school. We're not for we're
not scared of assuming Wooten's TAP plan
and we're confident that if our awesome
teachers and principal are allowed to
come with us. The TAP plan will be
implemented successfully and the new
merged Wooten campus will be a model for
success. We'll miss our Riley campus,
but we're happy that neighborhood and
monator students will continue to enjoy
it. We're all ready to get started on
our transition and we hope that you will
vote to get us across the finish line.
Thank you. My name is Elizabeth Orur. I
am the parent of two zoned students at
Ridged Top. AISD has 24 schools
requiring a tap. Our cost per pupil is
the second highest in the state and our
metriculation rate is among the lowest.
The state is coming. It's just a matter
of time. After three months of flailing
leadership in changing plans, I doubt
any of us, including you all, are
confident in the details of the plan
before you today. That said, adoption of
item 14.1 to implement school taps is
necessary to stop the bleeding and offer
desperate aid. However, I urge you to
vote no to 14.3. Closing successful
programs to move kids from them into
failing schools puts those students at
risk and dilutes campus tap resources.
Further forcing teachers and leadership
into established schools breeds
bitterness and creates a divided school
community. You all have convinced me
AISD meets reform. But this is too
little too late. By foregoing the
initial plan, you conceded that you do
not have the political will to be the
reformers. Please do not disrupt
successful schools and programs in a
half-hearted attempt to keep the state
out. It's too late. Give us a little
more time together. Vote no on 14.3.
>> Hello, this is Carla Lopez Bray. I'm a
parent at Richtop Elementary with a
student in kindergarten and second
grade. I am calling to respectfully urge
the board of trustees to vote no on
14.3.
Um
the new proposed plan was a complete
bait and switch from what was originally
offered to us with the initial
consolidation plan. Our family is a
district transfer that was on board with
moving to pickle when we were guaranteed
a seat in dual language. That is no
longer a guarantee. Our program is being
done away with and we are no longer tied
to a cap. So, we respectfully ask the
board to please vote no on 14.3 and
continue our amazing program at Richtop
Elementary. Thank you for your time and
your consideration. Goodbye.
My name is Katherine and I am a District
1 resident testifying on agenda item
14.3. I urge the board to vote no on
agenda item 14.3. When you say you are
committed to making generational change,
it is clear that you mean it. To resume
wall-to-wall dual language in two years
will quicken the displacement of
generations of black and brown
communities that have already gone
through this once before. The
communities of ODM, Pickle, Sanchez, and
Wooten have been talked about more than
talked to in this process. This plan has
already done harm to the broader Austin
ISD community. This plan does not make
it clear how you will serve the students
at these campuses. It just makes it
clear how you plan to shuffle them.
Please do not move forward with this
plan and hurt communities already
feeling the pain of being left behind by
other public institutions.
>> I'm Natasha Rogers, a parent at Matthews
Elementary. Please keep sixth grade at
Matthews Elementary for at least one
more year. With a pause on the
consolidations and closures for non-tap
schools, there's no reason to remove the
sixth grade at Matthews at this time.
Currently, there are resources and
capacity to continue to serve this grade
and great interest by students and
parents. Matthew sixth grade has
outperformed other sixth grades in
reading math. Why remove a successful
outlier? We think it would be worthwhile
to let the class remain at Matthews next
year and study how what and why it is
successful. Perhaps there are teaching
strategies that can help with other
sixth grades. Moving these students per
permanently to middle school would
eliminate their safe, stable, and
familiar setting. Keeping them in sixth
grade, the elementary level provides an
essential year of growing maturity and
learning stability. go for truth to
middle school. Finally, the sixth grade
year in elementary school offers unique
high impact opportunities that
facilitate leadership development and
positive social integration. Thank you
for your time, board of trustees and
superintendent.
>> Yes, my name is Matthew McCra. I wanted
to call and formally implore the um
board of trustees to vote no on prop
14.3
uh which would effectively close the
school of richtop. Uh this proposition
is separate from the turnaround plan
proposition. Um and that is the main
thing that should be voted on tomorrow.
Um the way that this has been handled by
the school district is been super
inconsistent and um has wafted all over
the place from getting buy in initially
um and even like not just buyin but like
family members or people with kids that
would stop um openly
uh supporting the plan and and vouching
for it. Um
and the plan has completely changed
since then. So, it's really been treated
unfairly. Um, and I just feel as if the
best thing to do here would be to start
again and reconsider this for the school
year beginning uh 2027 and leave this as
is for 2026.
>> I am calling today to express my strong
belief that we need to replace our top
leaders, specifically the superintendent
and executive directors. We are
currently facing a staggering budget
deficit of 110 million, a situation that
has arisen from years mismanagement and
ineffective leadership. We have seen a
troubling trend of failing schools, many
of which have received consecutive
failing grades from the TEA. This is a
clear indication that the current
administration has not adequately
addressed these issues. Instead,
decisions such as school closures have
been made without sufficient community
input, uprooting families, and
disregarding their voices. Furthermore,
it is concerning that the administration
has not utilized data analysis
effectively to inform decisions or
provide the necessary resource to
struggling schools. The narrative that
school closures were innovatable yet no
proactive measures were taken reflects
the lack of self-awareness and
accountability. I must also address the
troubling decision our executive
director and superintendent to accept
substantial reasons 2023 knowing full
well the financial issues we face. This
decision has become a problem for our
community and budget. Their main
profession is to help children not take
for them. It raises serious questions
about the priorities of our leadership
when so many schools are failing and
community is in distress.
>> Um, hi, I am a Riley parent and I was
just uh calling to say um thank you for
listening to us um and keeping the
community with um the Spanish dual
language and the Mandarin dual language
and our uh general community together
when you're um moving our school. Um
we're I'm looking forward to joining
with the Wooten community as well. Um
and I think that the turnaround plan um
feels very doable um especially under
the leadership of our current principal
who um has uh um experience and
turnaround plans. Um so I guess calling
to say thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Taylor O' Connor. I am
a parent of a kindergartener at Ridgetop
Elementary.
I urge the board to delay the vote on
moving dual language campuses. Um
specifically Ridgetop. Um
the current plan was given to us on
Friday and has not been um adequately
um
adequately informed to the parents and
the uh people involved. We need more
information on what this program would
look like. Um and uh at this point it
feels like a program closure and not a
program move. We add uh asked the board
to delay the vote on this measure so
that we can listen to public comment and
get feedback so that the this can work
for all involved students,
teachers, admin and parent. Hi, my name
is Katherine Kyoto and my daughter will
be entering kindergarten next year and
I'm calling because I wanted to share
for our cohort of families who are
entering AISD for the first time how
profoundly our confidence in AISD has
been shaken by the consolidation
proposal and review process.
We see us in our cohort just what
incredible challenges AISD is facing.
And I think what shakes our confidence
is that the way we are moving forward on
those challenges, which we absolutely
need to do,
does not seem to be able to answer
really foundational questions about
whether a given move will save money
with what level of assumed attrition,
things like that. and the lack of
detailed thinking about how the
consolidations will work. I want to
thank you all so much for your service
um in this incredibly difficult time.
Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Jan O'Neal. I have a
granddaughter that attends Ridgetop
Elementary School. Please vote no on
14.3.
Don't rip these kids up and ruin the
community that they have built so
strong. I'm Detroit educated and look at
their schools. Please don't tear up
these schools. Thank you.
My name is Natalie and I'm a parent at
Richtop Elementary. I'm asking the board
to vote no on item 14.3 related to
programmatic moves. These are no longer
program moves. They're actually program
closures and they represent an
indefensible bait and switch at the 11th
hour. As of Friday's changes, the very
programs that the district said were
needed to serve more emergent bilingual
families and had to move are now being
proposed to close. A change of this
magnitude requires much, much more
consideration.
These changes were never contemplated in
any of the draft plans. They are only
appearing in the final plan. Our
community has had no opportunity to give
feedback on this massive change, which
is an even more severe process issue
than the failure to consider feedback
that led to previous changes in
timelines for other portions of this
plan. 14.3 is not ready for prime time.
Richtop wants to work with the district
to find the right path forward. Please
vote no so that we have the time to do
so. Thank you.
>> Yes, I'd like to ask to just please get
rid of the Monasuri program. It's
failing. It's going to bring a tap to
the school that um it's being
transferred to and um the students
and parents um asked for that. Uh also,
can you keep dual language at Riley? And
um yeah, anyway, I know it's a hard job
and good luck. Thanks. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Katie Moses. I'm the mom
to a um second grader and a fifth grader
at Ridgetop. Um, I'm asking you to vote
no on item 14.3 specifically. Um, I
totally understand the need to vote on
the taps. Um, but Ridgetop does not need
to be closed next year to still be in
compliance with the taps. Um, the change
that was made just five days ago, um,
you know, we had been on board before
that. Five days ago, y'all pulled the
rug out from under underneath us. Um
it's not acceptable to close ridgetop if
you're keeping Breer, Maplewood, and
Palm open. Um because they're not tied
to a tap. Um you know, we largely behind
this plan until 5 days ago when the the
rug got pulled out. Um we're not able to
stay together. This is not wallto-wall.
This is a total change. Um so please
don't vote. Please vote no on 14.3. Um
so we can have some time to plan and
make this accessible for ridgetop
students as well as pickle students.
Thank you.
My name is Michael Rodriguez. I am the
parent of two elementary age school
children at Rididgetop. We collaborated
with the district to refine the plan for
the benefit of Ridgetop students, the
teachers, the district as a whole, and
really our whole community. We
understood that dual language programs
should serve more emerging bilingual
students and we asked that our community
be allowed to stay together as we move
campuses. This was part of the plan
until Friday. We were led to believe
that this would happen and this did not
happen. In fact, we feel that we've been
hoodwinkedked that the district has
really pulled the rug out from under us
because some of those other campuses
that are not being closed made more
noise and now we feel that we should
have made more noise. We should have
been less compliant. We ask you to vote
no on the measure to close elementary
because you're not just closing a
school, you're decimating a community.
Thank you.
My name is Alex Beasley. I am the parent
of two children at Rididgetop Elementary
School and I am calling to urge the
trustees to vote no on 14.3.
This newest version of the plan released
just 6 days before today's vote
introduces radical changes that
especially impact the dual language
program across the district. The
Ridgetop community has been supportive
from the beginning and has been promised
throughout this process the chance for
our community, our our students, our
teachers, our families, and our leaders
to stay together with the new
consolidation plan. However, this new
plan, again, released just 6 days before
today's vote, completely jettison that
commitment. Please vote no on 14.3 and
take more time to get these program
changes right. Uh, I support changes
coming to the district. I support
changes to the dual language program,
but this plan has not had the time for
any engagement or to make sure that
serious errors are not being made.
Please vote no in 14.3 and take more
time.
>> Hello, my name is Elizabeth Howard. My
husband Santiago and I, we have two
children at Rididge. We're a bilingual
family. Declining enrollment and budget
pressures are driving this consolidation
plan. But I need to sound a serious
warning. Closing or relocating
successful wall-to-wall dual language
programs risk pushing families out of
ASD to the zones they came from, moving
away, or choosing private school. AISD's
wall-to-wall dual language education is
academically strong, culturally
affirming, and deeply valued in this
city and community. Families choose AISD
because of these programs. Uprooting
them breaks trust and we can't afford to
lose more students. Emergent bilingual
communities, they deserve reliable,
well-resourced schools. And as Austin's
demographics continue to shift, moving
these campuses to chase population
changes is not sustainable. Instead, AIC
should strengthen and expand
wall-to-wall dual language programs
across the city so they remain
accessible and stable for all families,
no matter where they live. I urge you,
protect these programs, protect
Ridgeopot. Vote no on 14.3.
>> Hi, I'm the parent of two children at
Rididgetop. I'm calling to strongly urge
the board to vote no on 14.3. I've been
a supporter of AISD's overall
consolidation efforts, but the revised
plan released less than a week ago
negates the reasonable feedback our
community has provided and uses
Rididgetop students as pawns in the
district's game of chess. Vote no on
14.3.
Hello, my name is Chris Nolan. I'm a
parent of two children at Becker
Elementary. I was calling in regards to
the proposed changes to the dual
language program. Um I am calling to
urge you to vote against that particular
part of this plan. Uh I don't believe
that uh relocating the program is going
to necessarily help the school district
at large. But more importantly, I
believe that the schools that are being
relocated from and closed, the students
that are attending those schools, their
futures have not been adequately or
appropriately addressed and uh dealt
with the as a zoned Becker parent. Uh we
were our our school is being closed. The
school is of course like a a a BAB
school level school and we're given the
choice between two failing schools or
one struggling school and one failing
school to go to. So essentially you're
taking our kids out of an educational
program that is loved by the city or
loved by the the area the community and
>> superintendent Agura and trust I
reviewed your school improvement and
turnaround plans. You outline new
staffing, the ACE model, MTSS support,
and added counselors and
interventionists. These points show
effort. They do not form a complete
strategy. You do not state how many
counselors each campus will receive or
how you will assess students mental
health needs during major transition.
Students in turnaround settings face
high stress. They need defined support,
not general statements. Your academic
plan also lacks measurable targets. You
describe data cycles, coaching, and
observation, but you do not present
clear benchmarks. You do not show how
many how progress will be tracked or
what actions you will take if goals are
not met. Turnaround work requires
precise expectations. There is also
concern with limited discussion from
board. You are expected to question gaps
and ensure accountability. I am asking
you to publish clear mental health
staffing plans, measurable academic
goals, and regular updates. Student
deserves structure.
>> Danielle Beatri, parent of student at
Riley zoned for Gallette. Trustees, you
must vote yes for this consolidation
plan. You have no other options. Schools
need resources. Resources are tied to
funds. CAP schools need more resources,
i.e. funds. AISD has undertaken the most
comprehensive research and data
application to date and done their job
to utilize their resources in this
horrible situation with unfair rating
systems and denial of funding public
schools by TEA in the state. How you
transition these consolidations and
future consolidations is paramount. The
transition is where you have the power
and ability to fix the broken system and
inequity amongst your represented
districts. Furthermore, if as a trustee
you have not properly performed your due
diligence by attending or hosting
community meetings and logged as many
hours as others on the dis, then you
must abstain from voting because you are
woefully unprepared, grossly
misinformed, and your opinion is biased.
Hi trustees, this is Mary Alice
Williams, a Ridgetop parent. I'm calling
to urge you to vote no on item 14.3.
Richtop families have spent months
working in good faith with the district,
building trust around the plan to move
our intact dual language program to
pickles.
We were agreeable to the plan until the
district made last minute changes on
Friday that removed that commitment and
now divide our community across five
different schools. This plan is not
equitable. Other communities were
offered time, engagement, and
adjustments based on their feedback.
Friday's release and today's vote do not
give Rididgeopot families the same
consideration. The shift to taking on a
turnaround plan written for another
campus is a drastic change and families
deserve the opportunity to engage before
decision decisions are finalized. Please
vote no on 14.3 so the district can
listen to feedback and make changes when
all communities are given the same
opportunity. Thank you.
>> 14.3
Marie parent here's public comment.
Everyone
anything
else.
Say no to school closures. Thank you.
>> Delay the votes on closures,
consolidations, and program changes.
Approved tops with restart. This
district tore apart Doby Bernett and Web
harm still echoes. Please don't repeat
it. We keep hearing we have to do hard
things, but hard things are investing in
our school communities. Hard things are
trimming administrative excess so we can
pay teachers and fund campuses. hard
things would have been implementing tax
two and a half years ago. So we weren't
one step from tea takeover. That failure
was not on the community. It was on
leadership. Leadership who was warned
and they said we have systems. We won't
be here. But if they have systems, they
don't work. We were promised cuts away
from campuses first. We got performative
cuts, increased spending, fasttrack
school closures, but largely by two
people now in leave for lack of
integrity of the process. As the
district said that issue has never been
remedied. This is a gener generational
decision pushed through in a few weeks
with flawed data, uneven criteria, an
engagement that was hollow,
performative, and in many cases harmful.
Back this up. Slow this down. Give the
community a real process, not a stage
one. You are the last safeguard for
these children. Do not rubber stamp harm
and pretend you're approving
inevitabilities. Delay the vote. Protect
Austin's future.
>> Hello, my name is Miriam Soi Chapino.
Thank you for taking my call. I am
calling to testify about agenda item
14.3
and I'm urging the board to vote no on
this agenda item. Again, 14.3.
Um,
I'd like to share my story and the
reason why I find it important. Um, I'm
my child attends one of the schools in
AISD. We're a transfer from Lake Travis
and I know that um everybody knows the
curriculum isn't necessarily what it
should be, but I'm I'm attending one of
the school districts in excuse me, one
of the schools in AISD because of the
community. I know that my child will go
to one of the schools and he'll get a
good education, but what I'm concerned
about is the teachers. Where will all of
these teachers go? Where will they find
jobs in an already extremely
unpredictable market? Thank you.
>> I'm a mother of two young children
living in the Boulden Creek neighborhood
and had hopes to send my children to
their neighborhood elementary school.
I'm asking that you vote no to the
current consolidation plan. In your
focus to move the dual language
programs, you've completely disregarded
the members in the neighborhoods where
the schools currently reside. I think we
can all agree that the primary reason to
send your child to their local
neighborhood school is so the child can
be part of their local community which
fosters social emotional safety,
relationship building, etc. This is
supported by research. However, the
current plan literally splits Golden
Creek neighborhood in half making it
impossible to have all neighborhoods in
the community in one place. You are
already taking away our neighborhood
school Becker and are not providing us
with a good second option for a
community school that all members can
attend.
Please do not completely overlook and
dismiss an entire neighborhood in your
desire to organize a dual language
programs. Let us keep Becker as our home
school or if you have to take it away,
please give us an actual viable option
for a community school such as the
initially proposed Zilker Elementary
that all of us could attend. Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Meg and I'm a parent to a
student at Ridgetop Elementary and I'm
calling to voice concerns with the
process that's led to this plan that's
being voted on tonight. I know many of
y'all have been working really hard to
try to pull this off in such an
impossible time crunch. But this process
that we know is going to make
generational changes to our schools and
communities has been incredibly rushed
and filled with lastminute reversals and
changes without enough time to
meaningfully engage communities along
the way. It's been marked by confusing
and conflicting messaging. And even in
this new draft release only a few days
before the vote, we've been told that
there's oversightes in the language
included. So for schools not connected
to attack, we need to pause and ensure
that the decision-making process around
school closures gets it right for all of
our beloved kids to have the best
outcome and least disruption possible.
Our family, like many others, is down to
one of the three schools that's now
tenatively planned to close in 27. And
by proposing to close schools two years
in a row, passing this plan will set us
up to send our kids to three different
schools by the time E7. That doesn't
make sense. Please pause on what you can
and let's make sure we're getting this
right.
12.2 Two, please codify all of these
promises regarding transfers into policy
12.3 on admissions. That is a change to
the policy to clarify that enrollment
documents live online. I am urging the
board and the administration to allow
onampus
um registration and to have onampus
registration events, multiple of them
with the support of the PSS um and other
staff. When you have communities who
don't drive or have to take an entire
day off to take the bus to get to
headquarters, you have communities who
aren't tech-savvy, who don't own
computers, and we are making it very,
very difficult for our families to
register and enroll for school. Whereas
the charter up the block will give you
all the tours that you want. They will
um register you. They're on campus. We
are competing with um many other school
opportunities and options. And if we
want to keep families in Austin ISD, we
need to ensure that we're offering tours
and registering them on their campus.
>> My name is Steve Steel, a parent of a
third grader and kindergarten at Richtop
Elementary. Our community supported the
original plan because we believed in
serving emergent bilingual students, and
we trusted AISD's commitment to keep our
kids together. But now, just 6 days
before the vote, our plan has changed.
This is no longer a move. It is a
closure. And it leaves our families with
only two unacceptable choices. Send our
children to Pickle, a campus and a
two-year turnaround plan, or abandon
dual language and move to Riley, whose
future is unclear. Transfers aren't
guaranteed anymore. They're only a
priority. This will tear our community
apart. Other schools like Breerwoods and
Maplewood were given more time because
their plans weren't tied to a receding
tap. Bridgeop is no longer tied to a tap
either. So why aren't we given the same
consideration? We're not fighting
change. We're fighting for a responsible
plan that protects children. Please
listen to Ridgetop families and vote no
on item 14.3. Thank you.
>> Anita Sigler, Pickle Elementary.
I am Anita Sigler, the librarian at
Pickle Elementary. I want to thank the
board for listening to Pickle and their
community about being a neighborhood
school. I appreciate the pause and I
hope to be able to be part of the
solution when it is reconsidered. I have
met many people from other schools
during this difficult time and I hope
the board will include staff, family
members and community when they begin to
work on this again. We are ready to work
together. Thank you very much. Bye.
Hi, I am a parent of a student in a dual
language program and I would like to ask
you all to vote no on item 14.3. We made
a commitment to dual language education.
You asked us to do that and now you are
taking it away from us and not leaving
any options where we can actually go.
The numbers are not adding up. Please
vote no on item 14.3. Thank you.
My name is Gabby. As a community member,
I'm calling to speak directly against
agenda item 14.3.
This entanglement with the state taps is
a profound failure of vision and a true
betrayal to the communities you are
sworn to protect. Our dual language
schools are the crown jewels of this
district. Look beyond short-term budget
fixes and recognize the immense
irreversible cultural and educational
harm this vote will inflict across the
district. We are united in our
opposition. Show true leadership and
integrity by rejecting this destructive
measure. I urge you to listen to your
constituents, listen to your educators,
and make the right choice for every
student by voting no against item 14.3.
Do not dismantle the programs that make
our district exceptional. For the sake
of Austin's vibrant future, the
community insists that you vote no
against item 14.3.
Hello, this is Julia Remington, mother
of three AISD students, two of who are
at Matthews Elementary. I'm calling to
oppose 14.3, specifically the
programmatic programmatic moves of
wanting to remove sixth grade from
Matthews Elementary. You may have
recently heard that the sixth grade at
Matthews Elementary scored the highest
on math and reading scores in the
district and that is a pro shows that
it's a proven program that should stay
there. Additionally, not having parents
have more than a year uh heads up about
a program moving drastically impacts
their ability to make good choices for
their students. Sixth grade was at
Matthews for a lot of different reasons,
including student retention. Um, now
that Brier Woods is no longer is pausing
on closure, we have the space at
Matthews to keep the sixth grade program
there. Please, please implore the
district to keep the sixth grade program
at Matthews Elementary. Um it is a
proven record of success at retaining
students and improving uh scores for
sixth grade students. Thank you.
Delay the votes on closures,
consolidations, and program changes.
Approved taps with research. This
district tore part Doy Bernett and web
harm still echoes. Please don't repeat
it. We keep hearing we have to do hard
things, but hard things are investing in
our school communities. Hard things are
trimming administrative excess so we can
pay teachers and fund campuses. Hard
things would have been implementing tax
two and a half years ago. So we weren't
one step from TDA takeover. That failure
was not on the community. It was on
leadership. Leadership was warned and
they said we have systems. We won't be
here. But if they have systems, they
don't work. We were promised cuts away
from campuses first. We got performative
cuts, increased spending, fasttrack
school closures built largely by two
people now in leave for lack of
integrity of the processes. the district
that said that issue has
>> Hi, my name is James Wilson. I'm a
parent of two Becker students and now a
lively student that's in the sixth
grade, a Balden resident for the past 15
16 years. And I ask you to please vote
no on the agenda on item 14.3 and do not
take away our neighborhood school that
is so special to all of us in Balden and
our community. Please vote no on 14.3.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Rashmi Kosa and I reside
in Boulder Balden neighborhood uh where
Becker Elementary has existed in the
last 90 years when since it was built.
Uh as a parent uh taxpayer community
member and a supporter of public
education, I find it totally unnecessary
for AISD to consider closing Becker
Elementary. um a fully enrolled
performing school with a stellar
wall-to-wall dual language program with
a 10-year success record and a waiting
list to enroll. I urge you not to close
better. And I also want uh to ensure
that um uh that uh I stand by vote no
for agenda 14.3. Again, this is Rashmi
Kosa and I have two kids who went to
Becker Elementary since 2011 and they
have had a stellar record. They have
gone to great schools and I still expect
and hope that other kids get the same
that my children get. Thank you so much
and I I beg and urge AISD not to close
the school. Thank you.
>> Hello. I'm calling regarding discussion
point 14.2.
I'm a parent of a student at Blackshere
Elementary School and I'm calling to
support the consolidation of Oakspring
and Blackshere Elementary. Uh but I want
to be clear that I don't wish for the
consolidation of that to move to the new
construction in of Oak Springs. I think
it is a waste of resources and that
could be better put towards supporting
the children. I think multiple moves
will also disrupt the students while the
teachers are focusing on the TAP plan
and improving um the progress of those
students. Thank you.
Hi trustees, I'm Adriana Viscarondo Big
Bford, a Venezuelan immigrant mother. I
know we're in a difficult position and
there is no easy solution, but one thing
I know for certain is the power of a
community and the Becker community has
shown over and over again that we're
willing to do the hard work and elevate
AISD if we're given the chance. Please
don't tear that apart. Becker has been
essential in honoring and celebrating my
kids Latino heritage and language. And
under this latest plan, our community is
completely fractured. We are left with
zero realistic options to stay in dual
language. Trust is going to be lost and
that will have real implications for
enrollment in AIC. We've showed up.
We've offered solutions that benefit the
entire district and still we're being
isolated. I urge you to vote no on 14.3
or separate taps from the wall-to-wall
decision so this can be done
thoughtfully and with integrity. We can
do hard things together, but not if our
community is torn apart. Thank you for
listening.
>> Good morning, trustees. My name is Kathy
Clinton and I am a Becker parent. I have
two children that are emergent
bilingual, one child that is in special
education. My ask is to please vote no
to 14.3.
Becker students were told, "Hey, we will
at least stay together." And our
community has been decimated and there
are not enough seats for all of the kids
to go. There has been such a lack of
transparency, such a lack of planning on
the leadership's part. We were told last
week that all kids would get a seat,
just not the seat that they necessarily
want. That is not good leadership. Um
the dual language programs if they are
not wallto-wall they are generally
one-way programs and they do not have
enough teachers to have students finish
out the program for fourth and fifth
grade. My ask is that you vote no. This
is poorly organized and has been very
poor transparency. Becker is not
attached to a TAP program and there's no
reason for anyone to dismantle a
productive school. Thank you.
Hi, my name is Anna Vuchi. I'm calling
from Wedane Elementary School. I'm a
second grade teacher here and I am
asking the trustees to vote yes to re
for a restart for Wedane. The community
here is amazing. The kids are amazing.
They deserve stability. They deserve
teachers that they know, a place they're
familiar with. And I think it would just
be a huge mistake to send our students
to another school that's struggling with
the same thing. So, please vote yes to a
restart for Wedane. Thank you. Bye.
>> Hi, my name is Vicki Deusk. I'm calling
in regards to agenda item 14.3. I urge
the board to vote no against this agenda
item. I am a longtime resident of the
Balden Creek neighborhood. All three of
my children have attended Becker. I am
thinking about the future. I am thinking
about all the apartments that are being
built on South Bur and Lamar. Where are
these kids going to go to school if you
close our school? A school that is full
of community. A school that has the
largest elementary attendance in MLK
march. A school that has the largest
attendance for children running in the
Cap 10K. A school that has a garden
program that's been around since 1989.
Getting children outside. Closing our
neighborhood school means saying no to
community.
Please vote no on agenda item 14.3.
Don't be remembered as a board who
closed
a community school.
Vote no. Thank you.
>> Hi, I just wanted to comment on the
consolidation between Black Shear and
Oak Springs. Um, you know, it would be
very sad if we had to let go of the
Black Shear building and all of its
history. Um, but for me, two of the most
important things uh and priorities
should be to welcome the Oak Springs
community and help integrate them into
the Black Share community, but also to
maintain the culture and ethos of
Blackshere and its priority on the arts.
Um especially if the Oak Springs
community is uh coming to Black Seir for
the first year uh and then we go into
Oak Springs new building. I can think of
no better person to help guide that
transition than she is amazing and she's
going to be there uh welcoming the Oak
Springs community in. So she'd be the
perfect person um to move into the new
space. Thank you.
Hi, my name is David Cordova and I'm a
former teacher with Austin ISD and I am
calling to urge the trustees to vote no
on action item 14.3
um regarding the closure of Beck
Elementary School. I believe the
planning has been terrible. There has
been no transparency at all with the
parents and the stakeholders and yeah I
think this is a horrible solution for
students. I was a teacher there um in
the in 2014 I think it was and uh the
school was vibrant and the dual language
program was great. So I think this is a
very bad decision. Um so that is why I
urge all the trustees to vote no on
action item 14.3. Thank you.
For the last 13 years, I have lived next
door to Ridgetop Elementary with my art
studio abuing the playground. Even
before I had a family of my own, I drew
creative energy from kids at play. The
school is a coherent enriching part of
our community. Last year, I took the
parent tour and was moved. All she
shared the library with the outdoor
area, collective art projects and the
that after seven years kids leave fluent
in both English and Spanish. If
Bridgetop has a problem, it's
overenrollment.
Austinites want dual language for their
children. Emerging English speakers,
heritage Spanish speakers, and the whole
generation of children growing up in a
place where Spanish is essential to our
community. I want to urge the board to
slow down this process and keep
Rididgetop and other dual language
programs open while we look for more
money from philanthropists in our
community and from having an accountant
look at how the resources come into the
into the school and how we can get more
money back from our um our
>> Hi AISD. I want to thank you guys for
all the hard work you're doing on the
consolidation. I know you have many
difficult decisions to make. I'm a
parent of a student at Blackshere
Elementary and I just want to call in to
support the consolidation of Oak Springs
and Blackshere School. Uh but I do want
to be clear that I do not wish for the
consolidated Blackshere to move to a new
construction at Oak Springs. I think
these multiple moves would be
disruptive. Uh while students and
teachers are trying to really focus on
the tap, the turnaround, which is the
most important part and Black Shear is
in a really special location nestled in
between uh Houston Tullson and the
Carver Museum and Keeling Middle School.
You cannot beat the location and once
you lose that, you do not get it back.
So that campus needs to stay open for
the long term. Thank you.
Hi, this is Janney Transersonen, a proud
parent of a Becker student. I'm asking
you to please keep our students together
and designate a school in South Central
that the majority of our children can
actually attend. Becker is the only
school not being prioritized for staying
together. And our community deserves the
same consideration as every other
campus. Many of our teachers that I've
spoken to live in Butuda or Kyle because
the rent in Austin is too high and
they're not paid a livable wage. If the
district is committed to equity like
they say, then please show it by
treating our students and teachers
fairly. Please do not place dis please
do not displace our kids. Thank you.
>> Agenda item 14.3 raises one major
concern. There are not enough seats for
all current dual language students to
remain in dual language. Even if the
program continues somewhere else, many
children will lose access simply because
there isn't space. When a program exists
on paper but becomes out of reach in
reality, it creates a divide between the
students who can stay in it and the
students who cannot. This is an equity
issue. Research shows that students who
face economic hardship gain
significantly from strong dual language
programs, especially in literacy and
long-term academic growth. Removing
access takes away a proven proven
academic support from the students who
need it most. Families are also
concerned about long-term impact. Once a
school is closed and a dual language
program is broken apart, it cannot
simply be rebuilt later. These campuses
took years to build strong academic
cultures and once dismantled the loss
for students is permanent. We know hard
decisions have to be made, but they must
also be good decisions that protect
every child. That's what the majority of
our community is asking for.
>> My name is Fred Becker, a grandson of
Herman E. Becker. 90 years ago, my
grandfather and PA WY donated three
acres so South Austin could have its
first school. In 1936, to formally
recognize that donation, the Austin
school board approved naming the new
school after Herman Becker, my
grandfather's father and the
father-in-law of PA WY. Becker
Elementary is a true historic gym. But
even more than that, over the last
century, it has grown into an
educational gym. My grandfather and Mr.
Wy's intention was simple, that the
children of South Austin was always have
access to public education. Although the
neighborhood has changed many times,
families have continued to fight for
that same goal. Today, Becker's fully
enrolled, has nationally recognized
programs, turns out globally minded,
bilingual citizens. I ask you, please do
not dismantle a thriving community
school. Honor the spirit of my family's
generosity and the hard work of everyone
who has carried Beckard forward for
nearly a century. Please vote no on
14.3.
>> Uh, greetings. I would like to submit a
request that the school campus Becker be
kept open and that more broadly access
to dual language education uh remain
available to the kiddos in the city.
Thank you.
Uh greetings. I would like to submit a
request that the school campus Becker be
kept open and that more broadly access
to dual language education uh remain
available to the kiddos in the city.
Thank you.
>> Yeah. Hi, this is Tony Penz and I'm a
member of the Dove Springs community and
I'm asking trustees to vote yes to
restart uh for within elementary.
Thank you.
>> My name is Simone Salum and I am a
ridgetop parent of a prek4 child and I'm
asking the trustees to vote no on item
14.3. The revised plan released last
Friday eliminates the plan schoolwide
dual language program plan for pickle
elementary. The Richaw community was
given no opportunity for input on what
is now a program closure and not a
program move. Our community was told by
the district repeatedly that we would
move to pickle as a community and now we
are being dispersed throughout the
district with no guarantee that students
can attend the same school. My child is
now only guaranteed admittance to our
zone school Maplewood which is slated
for potential closure next year. The
decisions made by this district today
may force my child to attend three
different schools in his first three
years of elementary. Since Friday,
Richtop has received mixed messages
about the possibility of a schoolwide
dual language program at pickle. This
highlights the disorganized and
confusing messaging has received from
the district. Superintendent Sigura
stated that he valued integrity. This
last week, the district has shown a lack
of integrity in the process and a lack
of engaging the impacted communities.
Please vote no on 14.3.
>> This is Patrick Rosenthal, and I wanted
to urge the board to vote no on 143. I
want to flag something important about
the consolidation plan. The district
savings diagram and subsequent savings
data is way too simple and it leaves out
major real world costs. First, staffing
reductions don't work the way the chart
implies. Class- caps still apply, so
combining campuses rarely reduces
teachers, and larger schools need more
support staff, sped, bilingual,
behavior, intervention, not less.
Second, facility costs usually go up.
Putting 700 plus kids into a building
designed for far fewer means higher
utilities and more maintenance. Third,
transportation costs almost always rise.
Fourth, the cost of maintaining empty
buildings and selling empty buildings is
always underestimated. And the biggest
issue of all is the enrollment loss.
AISD must make a complete 180 degree
turn and focus on enrollment loss in the
spring. If we do not do this, this is
going to continue to happen again and
again. Consider community feedback.
Consider 1882s. And if you do any more
cost cutting in the spring, make sure
that you include community.
>> Please vote no to action item 14.3.
>> I urge the trustees to vote no on action
item 14.3
as this impacts children of our close
family friends. Dual language
instruction isn't just about learning
two languages. It's a powerful
educational strategy that supports
long-term success for diverse learners.
It's especially impactful in communities
with large populations of emergent
bilingual such as Hispanic children in
this state. Dual language programs help
English language learners maintain and
develop their native language while
acquiring English and native speakers
gain proficiency in a second language.
Thank you.
My name is Kelly Rich. I'm the proud
parent of Rich Top Radler. I'm here to
share some of the most compelling quotes
in opposition to this plan. Trusty Shu,
you referred to the parent survey used
to develop the plan as quote so bad you
could cry and that you didn't understand
some of the questions causing you to
feel quote extremely mistrustful of the
process. Trusty Boswell, on July 15th,
you warned the district that the guiding
rubric would quote penalize our oldest
Austin schools. You rightfully called
out the district's short-sightedness and
not calculating targeted improvement
measures to the rubric. Recently, a
parent did request the data used for the
building cost score for Richtop and they
were told, quote, "We are working with
senior leadership to determine whether
any additional documents exist." Trustee
Foster, you told us that if schools were
removed from the initial list for
consolidation, you would not support the
plan. Your statement just three days ago
directly contradicts your previous
assertions and interestingly enough was
released the evening before a planned
community feedback session. Lastly,
Superintendent Sigura, you said that
there were quote significant concerns
about the integrity of specific
individuals involved with the plan. We
are still waiting for anyone to tell us
what that was about. How can you vote
yes for a plan where the person in
charge admits that there were integrity
issues and where members of the board
also admit to the flawed data used to
inform it? Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Beth Bond. I'm a Ridgetop
parent. I'm asking you to vote no on
item 14.3. That's a separate vote from
the statemandated tap does not relate to
the TEA deadline. Beyond that, I'm
asking for a commitment for more clarity
on the transfer process, including
timelines, details on how the transfer
process plays out, and accessible
information on scheduling for school
tours, which has been left in the past
of just word of mouth among parents. Uh,
our family took the major step of moving
next door to Richtop because our main
priority was for our daughter to
continue her bilingual education in a
wall-to-wall program. But we understand
we are only one of many families
affected by the consolidation. So with
concern for not only Ridgetop but also
Pickle, Becker, Sunset Valley, Riley,
and others, we're asking for more time
and consideration for these changes with
monumental generational impacts. The
latest plan diminishes hope for what
Ridgeoptop parents have wanted most,
moving as a community to pickle, which
we supported as a plan to uplift two
school communities at once. Now pickle
parents are left with a local school
that will be forced to teach only to
test. Plus, teachers are even more of
alert than before. It's hard to imagine
anyone is happier with this revised
plan.
Hi, we're fourth graders at Becker
Elementary. We're asking you to vote no
on agenda item 14.3 so that we can keep
our community together.
>> Hi, my name is Elizabeth Michael and I'm
a kindergarten parent at Richtop. I'm
asking you to vote no on item 14.3.
Friday's update is not a program move.
It is a program closure announced with
less than a week's notice and no chance
for parent input. Bridgeop would close
and our popular diverse program would be
dissolved, scattering students across
multiple campuses with no guarantee they
can stay together or remain in the
program they started. This is a major
last minute change and it deserves more
time, transparency, and community
engagement. Please vote no on 14.3.
Thank you.
Hi, this is Lauren Muse and I'm a
parent. The narrative from the district
headquarters consolidations committee
staff and the superintendent have said
the opposite from what is true about
dual language immersion programs over
and over to parents, teachers, school
staff and our board of trustees. You the
consolidating schools Sanchez ODM Wooten
Pickle are mostly fully staffed with
certified dual language teachers. Most
emergent bilingual EB students, 85% are
already in dual language programs across
the district. We receive extra state
funding under HB3 for each student in
dual language immersion programs, and it
requires continuity for every student
participant. Consolidating these schools
will eliminate a thousand seats for
students in these programs, and there
will not be enough seats for students
currently enrolled. If data, facts, and
truth are not being used to make these
decisions, then it is wrong. Vote no on
14.3 for closing our dual language wall
to wall schools with corrupt
information. Keep our schools open.
>> Hi, my name is Liz Rush Smite and I'm a
proud Lively Middle School and Becker
parent. I'm also a resident of the
Balden neighborhood. I urge the board to
vote no on agenda item 14.3.
Please consider an amendment that would
allow for a fifth wall-to-wall dual
language school in South Central Austin.
The plan, as it stands, serves to close
both of Balden's neighborhood schools,
leaving this dense and vibrant area of
the city without any neighborhood
elementary school. We are ready and
eager to build community where we live,
and we're committed to attending and
growing our neighborhood schools. This
closure removes that option for all of
South Central Austin where I live. Thank
you for your time and wishing you all
well tonight.
>> Hello, my name is Caesar Bellinger. Uh I
reside in the Austin ISD school
district. Um I am calling in regards to
action item 14.3.
Um I think that the board of trustees
should vote no. Um I believe that this
is uh reducing these programs is
detrimental to um to our society. Um and
uh I will uh I am urging that uh that
this be considered um in the voting um
which I understand is taking place
tonight. Um
Austin School District.
Action item.
Hello, my name is Crystal Peterski. I am
a ridgetop parent of a kindergarter. I
am calling to please urge the trustees
to vote no on 14.3.
Major changes have come in since Friday
and we have had little interaction and
community hearout from the district. We
need to talk these things through. We
need to understand them. One week is not
enough. Today, our messages are flying
because we're seeing changes being done
live in the document. We don't have time
to grasp these, understand these and
share potential feedback. We've been
very complicit up until last Friday. And
we want, we're not saying it's a no
forever. We're saying we need time.
Please vote no.
>> Hello. Good evening. Uh, my name is Matt
Armstrong. I'm a bilingual resource
teacher and an ASD parent of a student
at Rodriguez Elementary. Um I wanted to
talk about the plan to absorb all of
100% of Wedain students enter Rodriguez.
Um working here it is a great place to
work and a great place to to learn but
um to add more over 350 students to this
campus is not tenable. um the original
plan in which a portion of the kids
would come was already at the upper
limit but we wanted to be you know a
part of this solution for AISD at large
so we're willing to make that sacrifice
this plan seems like it's moved very
quickly and has not like uh taking into
account the the reality on the ground
here just from special ed alone there
won't be enough rooms to take care of
our most vulnerable kids um Rodriguez
and serve already the most vulnerable
kids in Austin or some of Um, and the
kids in in our special programs uh
require that much more care. Um, and the
number of people that will be on this
campus is not going to be conducive to
success. Just want to
>> Hello trustees. I am Alicia Cooper, a
former Maplewood parent and public
school advocate. In a time of political
uncertainty with communities unable to
be heard for fear of deportation, it is
irresponsible as a community to take
away safe spaces. Schools are safe
spaces. With so much turmoil in
immigrant lives, it is hard to
understand why AISD has chosen this year
to completely upend the foundation of
our communities. Many families are under
threat and cannot speak out or don't
even have the bandwidth to address
school closures in their neighborhoods.
Closing schools and relocating programs
is not only going to add undue stress,
but potentially puts their families at
risk. I ask you to vote no on all school
closures. Let's not make a generational
decision for a short-term solution.
Please, as a community member, stop and
think about this beyond a budgetary
issue and consider delaying the whole
plan until everyone can have a voice.
My name is Franchesca Forna Armstrong
and I'm both a parent and an educator in
the Rodriguez Elementary community.
Under the revised consolidation plan,
Rodriguez is now expected to absorb 100%
of Wedain's students. Wedane is
currently under a TAP plan and Rodriguez
is under a tip plan. Bringing together
two campuses that are already
struggling, two schools serving some of
the most vulnerable students in our city
into now one overcrowded building and
then expecting immediate academic
success is not realistic and it's not
equitable. Bettis Elementary, Houston
Elementary, and Palm Elementary are
three other neighborhood schools that
are each less than three miles away from
Wedane, and they are not expected to
welcome any of students. This plan asks
our students, families, and educators to
navigate hundreds of changes at once
while already working under significant
pressure. Our children deserve a
thoughtful approach that supports them
rather than a plan that sets them up for
greater instability.
My name is Alison McKenna. I am a former
AISD student. Um, there is a current ASD
board member who tried to convince my
mom not to transfer me to Sunset Valley
when I was that age because being around
those kids, according to research, shows
that being around lower performance
kids would bring my scores down. Despite
being select mute, I not only found my
voice and became comfortable speaking,
but in two languages because of the
amazing wall to-all dual language
program and the support of nurturing
staff. Not only did my scores not
decline as the trustee indicated it
would, I reached mastery and achieved
perfect scores on my star exams, I
firmly believe this set the foundation
for my academic successes, including
currently where I'm at the honors
program at the University of Texas at
Austin. Closing successful schools is
not a good idea. Using these models to
help bring out lower performing schools
is a better way to serve students.
Closing schools isn't innovative,
doesn't solve problems, contributes to
overcrowding and overwhelming staff, and
doesn't create learning environments
that are positive. SSV and other schools
need to be models, not money. A truly
competent leader would know that and
invest in the students and teachers he
serves. Hi, my name is Cam Deore. I am
um calling to asking the trustees to
vote yes to restart Widane Elementary
rather than close it. again. Please vote
yes to restart elementary. Thank you.
>> Hi, good afternoon. My name is Emily and
I'm a parent of two Black Shear
students. My daughter Kadia is in kinder
and Caleb um is in third grade. This is
our second year at Blackshere. Um we're
actually zoned to Del Valley ISD, but we
choose to enroll in AISD um and send our
kiddos to Blackshere. Um, and I'm just
calling to support the consolidation of
Oak Springs and Black Shear. Um, but I
wanted to be clear that I I don't wish
for the consolidated Black Shear to then
move to a new construction at Oak
Springs. Um, I think multiple moves will
be disruptive while students and
teachers are focusing on improving
academic performance and building um,
you know, a strong cohesive culture for
two recently merged schools. Um, and so
appreciate the opportunity to share my
thoughts and thank you for all you're
doing to hear the perspective of the
community. Um, I know that it it's a
lot. So, thank you. Um, wishing you all
well. Bye.
>> Dwayne Reader, Richtope,
let's drop the mat. When did trust
become just a word on your letter head?
In barely a week, you poised to rip the
heart out of ridgetop. The school so
valuable so valued it had a waiting list
handing hundreds of families less
warning that you'd want for a vacation.
You told us to play nice to be silent.
We complied. You changed the agenda,
moved the finish line and now you rushed
to close rich talk before we can even
process what's happening. Kevin, you
declared your vote before hearing new
evidence. That's not leadership. That's
failing the very people you serve. You
aren't elected to rubber stamp
devastation or demand gratitude for
unraveling our community. If you respect
the word trustee, act like it. Live up
to your title. Earn our trust back. Vote
no on 14.3.
>> My name is Cologne Ler. I am a parent of
a first grader and a third grader in
AISD. We are currently enrolled at
Blackshere Elementary. I'm calling to
make a comment about the proposed
consolidation. Uh the first plan was to
consolidate Oak Springs into Black
Shear, which we were excited and happy
about. Um we know it's a big challenge.
The turnaround plan, everything about it
will be um difficult, but you know, I
think we can do it. Our staff and admin
are wonderful. However, they changed the
plan on afternoon of Halloween while
we're all getting ready with our kids
and they said that they might close our
school after a year. The disruption of
moving a campus and consolidating and
the turnaround plan in the black shear
and then moving our campus again would
lead to so much disruption and we would
also lose the lovely and important
location of this school. Please, please
do not do this. We are right next to
Houston Tabson. We're right next to
Qing. That's big for working families.
And also right next to Carver. Those are
third spaces. These are important
places. Um, and the position and the
location of the school. We are already
being asked to do.
>> My name is Judith Garcia and I'm one of
the parents for a couple of students
here at Widen Elementary. I'm calling in
regards to agenda item 5.1 and I'm
asking trustees to vote yes to a restart
for Widen Elementary School. Several
years back when my daughter needed to
come into school, I specifically chose
this school because I felt like it was
in a very safe location. It's next to a
firefighter station. It's next to a
library. It's next to a wreck. Uh now my
daughter is in fifth grade. She will be
graduating, but I have two more students
uh that will be coming here. The school
has been nothing but great to us and we
just did several upgrades to the school.
I just feel like it makes no sense to
come back and close it. Um, I ask I beg
you guys to please leave this school
open. Um, it has great teachers, great
students, and parents that really want
to go ahead and um, keep bringing their
students here.
Thank you.
>> Hello, I'm a Becker parent calling on
behalf of my two children. Over the last
three months, we have endured brazen
disrespect from the superintendent and
the consolidation committee for
advocating for our children. Two members
of the committee are currently suspended
pending investigation from its conduct.
The district turned our principal
against parents. The district attempted
to turn other schools and communities
against us. Our public information act
requests to the district were never
fulfilled in direct violation of state
law. Despite all of this, we have
attempted to partner with the district,
providing them with copious data and
strategy that improves efficiency and
causes minimal disruption to students
districtwide, only provide to be
provided with a plan with even that's
even worse that gives our students no
pathway to stay together. Despite
numerous provinces from the district, we
would be kept whole. The only way to
regain even a fraction of my trust is if
the trustees vote no on 14.3 and work to
strengthen dual language across the
district. My children are not pawns in a
game. They are my children. Thank you.
>> Hello, my name is Norlando and I have
two children currently at Wid Dayne
Elementary School and hopefully a third
one starting kindergarten next year,
which have always been our plans for the
last nine years since my oldest started
at at Widen Elementary School. I'm
calling to ask for the trustees to vote
yes on a restart for Widen Elementary
School because I feel like
the school is a great place. Widane is a
great place. My family has gone to
Widane for the last 20 years. One
generation has gone and another one. Um,
and it's
heartbreaking to see the school closed
down. Um, my children go there. My
youngest child hopefully can have a
chance to go there to meet all the great
teachers of all the grades in that
school. They have really made a case of
making everything feel like a community
with the recreation center and the
library. It just feels like a perfect
fit for my family, for the community
itself, and I feel like there's a better
option for our children in our
community. So, please reconsider.
>> Samantha Manley. I am a caregiver to a
child at Rididge Elementary. We are a
zonedtop family who purchased our home
specifically to send our child to
Ridgtop for the wall-to-wall dual
language. One year into our time at
Ridgetop, we are devastated that the
school is closing and the wall-to-wall
language program is being pretty much
dissolved as Pickle will now remain a
zoned campus and be subject to a
turnaround program. The wall-to-wall
dual language is not guaranteed and our
child is not guaranteed a spot in a dual
language program. Our alternative is to
go to Riley who also at the 11th hour
has now the Monttoauri program moving
there. Uh most likely looking at over
capacity issues with the wind gridtop
and Riley families all attending that
school. So we are urging the board to
vote no to 14.3 for programmatic changes
and closures of schools until this can
be more thought out and have more
community input. Please vote no to 14.3.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Deia Trevinho and I am a
parent of a Becker student who is also
an outofd district transfer. I ask you
to vote no on agenda item 14.3. This
plan closes 10% of elementary schools
across the district, but closes 33% of
elementary schools in the 78704
zip code alone. I ask that you please
have the district focus on the
statemandated taps and tackle dual
language programs at another time. Um, I
also sent an email to all the trustees
um, asking for you to vote no and giving
a little bit more background as how my
family who is out of the district chose
Becker and AISD. I ask you to please
read that email if you have a chance.
Thank you so much.
>> Wooten is excited to be able to keep all
of our own students, including ESL and
special education students. With Wooten
being designated a TAP campus and the
number of students in classrooms to
remain low with that designation,
how is the Wooten campus supposed to
absorb both the Spanish dual language
and Mandarin dual language programs from
Riley while serving all of our own
special education, emergent bilingual,
and ESL students.
The new Wooten campus is designated to
have three classrooms per grade. By
allowing three programs at Wooten
simultaneously, this would put limits of
one classroom per program. This would
then limit our own Hispanic population
that has been historically marginalized.
My proposal would be to allow the
Mandarin program to stay at Riley for
the next year while capacity of the
Wooten campus is evaluated in school
year 2026.
Thank you.
>> Hi. Yes, I'm calling in regards to the
closing on with voting against it. um
breeding um for a restart on the campus.
Also, I did um also voting no again um
any closure um as far as the the stats
go also to um
just the um just voting against it. um
due to my daughter being so happy of
being in this school and also to um the
staff and
are are so welcoming and they're like
family like and also to um due to the
next uh school that um the
I'm against it also too because this
school is also on a on a cap um they
have also failed
testing
and um again I'm just pleading uh to say
what and to vote against.
>> My name is Rachel Sala and I'm a proud
Education Austin Union member as well as
a title one educator who is currently
teaching at one of your campuses
designated as an on an LI program. I
would like to know why AIC decided to
defund the UT start program which would
directly support title one educators in
their first three years of experience at
my campus. 90% of our students are
economically disadvantaged and we serve
a large refugee population. I want to
say AIC's point is to nurture the whole
child. My students are more than a data
point and they go home to battles that
you can't possibly imagine. And there
will always be schools that are deemed
as failures from the broken TEA system.
So I ask, are we not supposed to call it
like it is? Are we not supposed to say
that our economically disadvantaged
students, our marginalized populations
are the ones that are suffering under
this? They don't have the money for
tutors. Sometimes they don't even have
food on their plate. Yet you want them
to test like the rest. They're not like
the rest. So you need to support them in
a different way by funding programs that
directly impact their achievement and
support the teachers who serve them.
>> Hi, my name is Brad Strawer. I'm a
parent of a student at Wooten Elementary
in the special ed life skills program.
And first I want to thank the board for
clearing community feedback and updating
consolidation plan to ensure priority
enrollment for students that are
currently at school and that are in the
area. Um, I wanted to clarify though if
that priority enrollment will continue
in the future. It looks like from the
the plan documents that it will move
from a dual language wall-to-wall
program to a nonzone school in the
future. So, I'd like to confirm and sure
that the priority enrollment plan will
continue uh in the future. And then also
if if you could please clarify um the
the
improvement plans if the school is
supposed to be under a restart or an
improvement plan as it looks like um
we've heard both and in the documents
right now it looks like it's just an
improvement plan. Um which I would
support not being under a restart since
as a parent I think staff um and new
principal Mr. uh made improvements
despite uh uh being restricted in the
portables.
>> Good evening. My name is Rachel Zasta
and I'm a proud member of Education
Austin and a title one educator. Public
schools are the heart of communities and
foundation of democracy and they're what
saved me and made me the first person in
my immediate family to graduate college.
Yet today, our schools are under attack
from years of underfunding by the Texas
legislature and the threat of a tea
takeover. This district has been forced
into an impossible situation. However,
Austin ISD still has an obligation to
its workers and community. Education
often has three clear demands. First, no
lost jobs beyond natural attribuation.
These closures must not result in
layoffs, salary cuts, or
reclassifications. Every employee
deserves a guaranteed path to continue
employment within AISD. Second, we
demand clear answers and transparency.
The community deserves to understand how
decisions are made and how feedback is
incorporated. Third, workers must have a
real seat at the table when implementing
the final plan. The people who serve our
students every day must have a voice in
shaping our school's future. AISD, we
are watching. The community is watching.
We will hold you accountable to protect
our schools. My name is Amy Rnanod and
I'm the librarian at Wedane Elementary.
We keep hearing the district say that
equity is guiding these decisions. The
district admits that it has failed to
give east side schools what they've
needed to succeed for years and that
they want to center historically
underserved communities. But the
district's actions don't match their
words. Instead of investing in the east
side, you're closing our schools,
doubling down on the same inequities you
claim to be fixing. Wedane was treated
as an afterthought, a box to check, not
a community to protect. We keep hearing
we're making hard decisions together,
yet those closest to the work were never
actually invited in. Our some of our
names are even listed on the tap as if
we helped write it. But closure was
predetermined and the tap was handed to
us already written. And the tap itself
isn't even accurate. It misrepresents
stakeholder involvement, inflates
Rodriguez's building capacity, and sends
a 100% of our students to a D-rated
school, which TEA could still reject.
The facts don't match the narrative. If
equity truly guides your decisions,
please repair the harm. Protect Wedane.
Give us a restart. We need investment,
not eviction.
>> Hello, my name is Mark Caparo and I am
the parent of two students at Blackshere
Fine Arts Elementary. My family and I
are excited to welcome the Oakspring
students and parents and look forward to
the opportunity to have a dialogue with
them on the best way to move forward
with our new combined school. I think
that any discussion of closing the
Blackshere campus and moving to a new
building before the schools merge is
premature and I believe misguided. I
also wanted everyone listening to this
message to know that they are welcome to
join us at the 135 year anniversary
celebration of our campus on February
13th. We are really excited about it.
Thank you very much for your time.
My name is Darlene and I'm a parent of
Win at Win Monastery and I feel
completely betrayed by the district. Our
community has worked incredibly hard to
preserve our program with dignity and
equity as our top priorities. We made
very clear that we did not want to
displace Go Valley's community for our
program. So, we advocated for a home in
our neighborhood that would also keep
much of our community together as
possible. We wanted to collaborate with
our neighboring schools to find a
solution together. Instead, we are
succumbing to a lastminute rush plan
where a mere strand of monastery will be
moved to Riley on the other side of I35.
Enrollment priority policies for a mere
strand of our program that we built
would effectively send all of our
children to the back of the line while
zoned kids for Riley get first priority
to the program that we have fought tooth
and nail to keep. Matias, you said in
your tap update on the 13th that this
would be a K through 5th program. Are
you saying that prek will no longer have
access to monastery? The largest
population of our school and on the
weight list are prek3 and prek4
students. What about special ed? Will
the strength support our kids with
disabilities? Thank you.
>> Hello trustees. My name is Ashley and
I'm a teacher at Wedane Elementary
School. I'm asking you to support a
restart for Wedane. Our school is not
broken. It's a community that has been
asked to survive constant change, loss
of support, and decisions made far above
us. And still our students are growing.
Our star scores have climbed every year
49 to a 56 to a 57 because our staff and
families show up for them. A restart
lets our students stay with the teachers
and support staff they trust. It
protects the only community school in
South Austin, preserves our new mental
health center and honors the $6.6
million investment already poured into
our campus. We all know that Rodriguez
cannot physically hold both schools,
especially with high special educ
special education needs and tap class-
size caps. A restart keeps our children
safe, stable, and together. Our students
deserve this chance. Thank you.
>> Hello. It's my understanding that uh
this evening the AI board of trustees is
voting on uh
item 14.3
which is a closure of Becker Elementary
and another couple of schools Sunset
Valley I think uh having had children in
both of those schools and especially
with a longer time at Becker I'd really
like to encourage the trustees to vote
no on that 14.3. I really think that
that school is an integral part of our
community and a high functioning school.
Besides, it really just seems like a
waste of time uh and money. And I urge
you to vote no on 14.3. Thank you very
much. Bye.
>> Hi, I'm Bob Liel, a ridgetop parent. Uh,
I'm asking for a delay on 14.3 tonight.
At the beginning of this process,
Ridgtop parents were devastated that our
beloved school would close, but we
rolled up our sleeves to make the plan
the best for every student in AISD. We
were told that none of this plan would
work without all of its pieces pieces,
that schools wouldn't be carved out
because they were loud, and that we had
to address vertical patterns and
boundaries now. But none of that ended
up being true. Instead, the new plan
released Friday seems so half-hazard
that the district appears to be updating
it in real time over the course of this
week or even this afternoon. We were
emailed information on Friday about
priority transfers that contradicts the
actual plan. There are many of us
committed advocates for strong,
equitable public schools who are left
disappointed and disillusioned by this
process. I hope that you vote for a
delay to get this right. And if you
don't, I hope that you have a better
plan for how to win back trust from
heartbroken AISD parents. Thank you.
>> Hello, AISD. My name is Dan Beard. I'm a
20-year Austin ISD father and family. We
have kiddos who have attended Becker
Small Middle School and Richard and
Macallum. So, we love AISD. I'm calling
specifically to urge the board to vote
no on agendum item 14.3.
that item which consolidates Becker and
disperses our kiddos amongst multiple
campuses losing the ability to keep our
community together. This isn't about
saving a school at all. It's about
conserving a community. I also presume
you know there is a proposed amendment
that we have over 500 signatures where
we consolidate Becker Dawson and other
school in South Austin to create a
community opportunity for our kids to
stick together. So my request is to vote
no on agenda item 14.3 and do strongly
consider the proposal by Becker families
to keep our kids together. Again, the
ability to change your mind is a sign of
wisdom and we believe you guys are wise.
Thank you for all that you do. We
appreciate your support.
>> Hello, my name is Lindsay Powers,
Becker, parent and Balden resident. Vote
no on 14.3.
Hi, my name is Santia Baraki, a parent
for Rich Elementary School. I'm calling
to urge the board to vote no on 14.3.
Uh, as it has been cons consolidating
the wall to-wall program and removing
it. This is an issue for us and is
putting a zone to a school which is over
capacity. There has not been enough time
for parents and community to comment and
has been changes up to as soon as Friday
and it is unfair to pass this now. I
encourage the board to vote no and to
delay this and to give enough comment
for the community as it is very
impactful to my family and others uh in
many schools across uh the city of
Austin. Thank you.
>> My name is Jasmine. I'm connected to
AISD through working with students and
educators at my job and I'm concerned
about the consolidation plans for Wedane
Elementary and Betachch Middle School. I
wish that these schools wouldn't close
and I hope that the capacity building
plans at at Rodriguez and at Pedes and
Mendes will be more than sufficient to
support the students who will be
transferring over because overall I'm
concerned that these transitions will
negatively affect the students
self-esteem and it may discourage them
to come to school and learn and be in
community because schools serve as a
place for community, a place for
resources and I don't want anybody to
slip through the cracks and I want the
public schools to support the students
in the best way possible and prioritize
them first above anything above any
policy or above any regulation or even
above money. I hope I want the best for
these students to develop healthy and
thrive. Hi, my name is Ilana Samila. I'm
a current staff member and parent at
Wedane Elementary. I'm um in response to
AISD's commitment to wellresourced
campuses. I wanted to say that Widane is
already one of the most wellresourced
campuses east of 35. Our students
benefit from the public library that
hosts story times and visits for
presentations. The rec center where our
staff knows our students by name. The
pool our first graders learn to swim for
free every year. The park where our
families gather for events and
celebrations. Right across the street,
we have a brand new public health
facility that offers essential services
along with fire and EMS stations that
support our career days. All of the
resources that surround our school are
part of what makes Widane such a strong
connected community. All AISD needs to
do to strengthen Widane is invest in the
quality education part of their
commitment. Instead, closing our campus
would uproot our students from the
resources that their families rely on
and dismantle the heart of this
community. I urge the board to consider
a campus restart with a tap at Wedane
rather than closing our school. Our
students deserve the chance to thrive in
their own community surrounded by the
people and resources that already
>> My name is Sergio Dravinho. come a
parent of a current Austin ISD student
and a future Austin ISD student starting
next year. Uh I urge the board of
trustees to vote no on agenda item 14.3.
This is a dramatic change that will have
a longlasting impact and will affect my
sons throughout their Austin ISD
experience.
I am a former bilingual educator in
Austin ISD. I was a fourth grade teacher
uh for three years. I believe deeply in
public education.
I believe this process should have been
an open book with Austin ISTD showing
all of its work and giving an
opportunity for the community to
understand the justifications for the
decisions that were made and to propose
alternatives. Instead, we're being asked
to accept on faith that the plan will
solve the school district's problems,
but there are very credible criticisms
that indicate that will not happen.
I urge the board of trustees to vote no
on item 14.3. Thank you.
>> Hi, my name is Lindsay. I'm an a AIC
parent to former Dawson Dolphin and
former Becker Bobcat. I live in the
Dawson neighborhood. I'm calling in to
ask that non-managerial staff at dual
language program campuses that are
moving be given more opportunity to give
their feedback and to actually be heard
in this process by the district. While I
recognize the need for simplicity and
language, I felt that the use of the
word resources to describe teachers and
staff is problematic and harmful. Please
develop anonymous reporting
opportunities for these employees and
bring them into the decision-making
process. If teachers are happy and
supported, campuses will attract more
families. Schools are only as strong as
the well-being of our teachers and
staff. Secondly, there is a current
proposal to merge Dawson and Silker
emergent bilingual at Becker to keep a
fifth wall-to-wall campus. assuming the
best of intentions here, but I'm
concerned that real engagement was
absent in this process between the group
proposing this merger and the Dawson
community. Any proposal put forward
should be considered only after ensuring
that collaboration between neighborhoods
occurred and as many voices as possible
were brought to the table. And moving
forward, please focus more energy on the
voices of the educators and staff. Hi,
I'm a parent of two students at
Blackshare Elementary, which is the
school that we chose once our
neighborhood school Sims closed down um
in the last round of consolidations. And
I am calling to say that we are honored
and excited um at Blackshar to welcome
the Oak Springs students and their TAP
plan. um talking to our school
administration, they've done nothing but
give us confidence that those kids will
be welcomed and that given enough time,
we will be able to lift all the kids
scores. Um so the thing that is most
important is that we give the time for
those kids to get acclimated to
Blackshere Elementary and not move them
immediately to outside of Blackshar. um
and thinking about how we want to bring
those two communities together and bring
those two communities together in
proximity to Keeling since that is the
direct feeder to the middle school
there. There's a big relationship
between all the students and the
siblings between Keeling and Blackshere
and that's something that
Bingo.
Fore!
Foreign! Foreign!
This is an interpretation from Spanish
into English from Marcela Garcia. Good
afternoon, board of trustees. My name is
Marcela Garcia and I only have one
comment. I do not understand the game
you have on the table. Is it a game of
chess, Loia, bingo? It's more of a
puzzle because that's how we see this
happening every day. With all the
changes that are going on, you're only
confusing us more each day. And if you
can't figure out how to put the pieces
together for a school, I have to ask
myself, how are you going to explain
where my student from heart will be
going to Dobby? And from Dobby, where is
he going? I do not understand. But what
worries me the most are the surprises
you have in store for us come August. I
ask you from the bottom of my heart,
please be clear about this. Thank you.
>> Hi, I'm Diana Wang, a current Riley
parent. I'm asking that you please vote
no on 14.3. This will one, give
additional time for true community
engagement and buyin, and two, align the
timing of these moves with the delayed
district-wide boundary changes and
closures. This will prevent a fragmented
staff reassignment effort and provide
more opportunities for the right
teachers and principles to go to the
right schools. I was thankful to see
thoughtful engagement in the earlier
stages of the plan, but the final weeks
and even final hours of this process
have been deeply disappointing. Major
decisions on where entire school
populations would be moved, transfer
policies for the existing wall to walls,
and the last minute placement of wind
Montasauri were made with essentially no
community feedback. Community members
who don't have the privilege or capacity
to even be aware of how the plan changed
deserve a chance to provide input on
what could be meaningful and achievable
plan refinements that will ultimately
result in better student outcomes. Thank
you.
We can reconsider it.
foreign.
This is an interpretation into English
of Mariela's message. Hello, good
afternoon. My name is Mariela. I am a
parent of Uten Elementary. The reason
for this message is only to ask the
Austin school district to reconsider
what I'm mentioning that once the new
school year begins that the teachers as
well as administrative and operational
staff will no longer be part of the
school.
I only ask them to keep the promise they
made that these personnel are fabulous,
they are wonderful and that they have
worked hard to have new facilities. I
understand the needs of the school
district, but I don't see why we
couldn't couldn't keep this wonderful
team that has given 200% for the school
and for all students. Really, I am more
than grateful to the school to the
district for allowing me to meet them
and for my children to attend that
educational institution. It is the only
thing I ask. Thanks a lot.
Thank you to all of our speakers, all of
our callers. This ends our public
testimony. Trustees, are there any
questions seeking clarification?
>> Trusty Foster.
Yeah, I'd really like some clarity with
regards to uh
Ridgetop families and the dual language
program
uh moving to pickle and in particular
there's a lot of folks whose sense of
the matter is that they're going to be
split to five different schools. Um the
language
there's just so many things out there
and there's so many iterations and so
many versions. folks can literally and
quite quickly
become disillusioned, confused, etc. My
understanding,
well, I I have an understanding that is
much more optimistic about
how many ridgetop families that want to
go to pickle dual language will be able
to. Um, there's also the reality that at
Ridgetop,
if that school were to close, you have
the dual language option at Pickle, you
have the neighborhood option at Riley.
So, I guess what I'd really like is
concretely um a better sense of the
numbers um the great concern that we
heard over and over again of the
quoteunquote breaking up of the Ridgetop
dual language community. Can you speak
to that, please?
Uh, sure. Um, Trusty Foster. Um, what
I'll do is kind of break down um kind of
the sequence of kind of um inputs that
led to the adjustment in the plan. I
want to be really clear like we
recognize that this is a a shift uh and
is is felt as a disruption for all of
our school communities um that currently
have wall-to-wall deluage programs. So,
I just want to acknowledge that. Um we
are going to give a a presentation in
the superintendent's update. So I I I
will cover much of this there, but I
think because you asked the question, I
want to probably just respond to to
addressing
>> and if you want to keep like sort of the
explanation, the full explanation for
later. Uh but just the clarity on the
numbers question that we heard over and
over again.
>> Yeah. So um for Riley, um the capacity
at the new Wooten will be 532.
Uh the current enrollment at Wooten is
234.
Uh so that leaves you um 298 kind of
seats available. When you look at the
number of students at Riley, uh you have
to consider that fifth grade are not
going into the new Wooten, right?
They're graduating this rising sixth
graders and they're leaving. So you take
Riley's enrollment at 354 and you less
the 46 fifth graders and that brings
your new number to 298 as far as
students that will potentially go to uh
Wooten. Uh once you net out or
take the 532 and reduce the number of
students at Wooten, you're left with 308
seats. So 298
students who are there now or all the
students if all of them are 308 and
there's 298 seats. So 96.7%
of the students there will have a seat.
So effectively 100%. That again is
assuming that no student selects any
other option. So um so in this way you
know with like I can confidently say
that the vast majority if not I can
almost get really close to saying can
can confirm that all students I just
never would say that um have a seat at
Wooten if they choose to go. Uh and
we've worked through this multiple
times. This is you know one of the
things that we wanted to confirm before
we made the modification. And the
modification in the plan was such that
we kept um Wooten families and Wooten
students at Wooten. Uh we heard that
from the community and whenever you do
that which was our commitment um and you
assign them there they now have to take
the tap right. So so that was the the
kind of the feedback from the community
and feedback from trustees that kind of
set the the expectation that tap would
now have to remain at that campus. But
given the available seats, we're still
able to receive 96.7%
pretty much 100% of this the students.
Again, that's assuming everybody goes
and and also netting out the fifth
graders who again are moving on to
middle school. So, so that's how we
worked out. Richtop, I can do the same
thing with them too.
>> So, Richtop enrollment um 376,
you have 57 fifth 57 uh fifth grade
students. Uh and so that um nets out to
200 um sorry uh 319.
Uh when you look at Pickle Elementary
School of capacity of 652, you reduce
the number of students enrolled and
projected to enroll 354.
So um of the available seats, uh it's
you know you have um 298 over 318. So
this one's a little bit lower. It's
about 93 and a half percent. So again,
if every student did not select to go to
Riley, meaning everybody went, we would
we would be able to fit um 94% or 93 and
a half% of the total student population
at Richtop into Pickle. Again, that's if
no one in the assigned boundary went to
Riley. Um so those are really high
numbers. We it's not going to be that
number, but when families say we want to
all go together, I want to explain what
all go going all together looks like.
Um, so 93% of the 100% would be
effectively guaranteed a spot, but when
you get to numbers that small, um, with
what we see in the system, it's
effectively everybody. I mean, we I
mean, you're looking at 10 12 students
at this point, like we would make it
work. But I I hesitate to say guarantee
just because you know it's with all the
moving pieces. But that's how we were
able to get to a solution that allowed
all the students to go feel confident
that the vast majority of students would
go um for those two um specific schools.
>> Overwhelming majority of students at
Ridgetop
>> and Riley
>> who are enjoying dual language now and
would like to continue would be able to
continue at Pickle.
>> Correct.
And that is not yet taking into account
the number of Ridgetop families who are
going to choose the walkability benefit
and go to Riley. Although has its
challenges
>> that are just assigned. Yeah.
>> Got it. Okay. That's that was my
clarifying question. Thank you.
>> Yeah. And and I think the other thing I
would also say um just because you you
brought up a point regarding the
hierarchy of um uh transfers, right? Um,
so because it's now a a zone school,
right, until we break the tap because we
the document says transitioning into a
wall to wall because I have to break the
tap before I can implement a full wall
to wall. Um, but in this instance, the
zone students are guaranteed a seat,
right? Which is why I accounted for all
students at the receiving school, which
is Pickle and and Wooten. And then the
first priority are all the students that
are transferring in. And then the second
priority are all the students from the
other three wall-to-wall dual language
programs. Meaning that if you were at
Richtop and didn't want to go to pickle
but preferred to go to Wooten, then you
would now be the priority right under
the Riley students who had kind of first
option. Uh and that's the that's true
for every other option in amongst these
four existing wall-to-wall programs. So
we kind of used that logic all the way
across um uh just to ensure that the
number of seats were protected across
the district but then also the offerings
were there schoolto school if they were
close by. So, the Ridgetop, and I
apologize for this. I just I just want
to be clear. The Ridgetop uh community
member who transfers into Ridgetop
benefits from dual language wants to
continue at Pickle.
>> Yep.
>> Dual language. They are among that 93%.
They there is effectively room for them
at Pickle.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. Thank you.
And I I think that's of immense
importance obviously and there's
questions that we can talk more when
it's appropriate.
>> Thank you. And while we're talking about
that since their families from Becker
with very similar questions. Yeah.
>> Can you please share that same rundown
>> logic? Yeah.
>> Thank you. I appreciate that.
>> So Becker is different. Um so Becker uh
we have 69 fifth graders um which brings
a total net students that would be kind
of rising into fifth grade or kind of at
any new school 438. Um so given the
capacity at Sanchez um only about 200
seats are available at Sanchez right so
roughly 40% it's about 39% but right
roughly 40% of the seats um of the
Becker full population that could move
have seats at um at Sanchez and again
that's the same logic where because the
students were not being reassigned to um
Zavala or to Allison which was a a a
concern from our trustees around having
um students from one tap school go to
another tap school as well as retaining
the students that meant we had to retain
the tap at Sanchez. Um and so the way
that the and this is all going to be
detailed in the slides just so that our
community members are following along
like I know I'm saying it but it's going
to be in the document so you can see it
there clearly. Uh what we did was we
protect 200 seats at Sanchez. Um the
students that are now old Becker but are
now in the new Zilker reside they will
they have first option obviously at
Zilker Galindo first option that at
Galindo if they're previously Becker and
then the next priority is any transfer
student into Becker has the ability to
go to either one of those assigned
schools um or the student who's at
Galindo Becker going to Galindo now has
that same um kind of transfer priority
to go to Zilker
So really what we were trying to do was
to ensure that any student in the Becker
community that was being disrupted had
um options between those two schools as
well as Sanchez. Um because what we
heard in in the community were were lots
of different um obviously thoughts and
and ideas and we were running through
them and trying to figure out a way to
kind of protect priority um ensure there
were as many options as possible because
this we can't fit all the students into
one location and then conversely when it
comes to um Sanchez obviously that's
priority one but ODM it's it's priority
two behind Sunset Valley students right
so protecting the seats that are
available at ODM which is a true
wallto-wall because they don't have a
tap. They can immediately convert all
the way um and then Sensit Valley would
have priority one and then the other um
committee members I mean the other
schools would have priority two and then
all others behind it. So um we'll talk
about that more in the slides like we
break it all down. Um but that's that's
how it breaks out from a numbers
perspective.
>> Okay. And do you have numbers for ODM?
How the capacity at ODM and Sunet
Valley? Uh yeah, I do. It's
>> we can talk about it in the slide if
that's where it is.
>> I Yeah, I can. It just it just gets to
be um
>> Yeah. I think where you run into is um
you're you're now assuming 100% of 100%
at 100% and you know all these schools
for instance like Sensit Valley going to
Boone and Cunningham.
You know there to assume that 100% go we
can we model that and we can do it and
it they fit. But the reality is is we
know because we have other families that
are emailing us about going to those
schools that that's not the case and
that's so we're trying to project as
conservatively as possible. Um ODM's
capacity
um 532
um total number the enrollment is 273.
So you have 259 open seats currently.
You will have that and again that's
assuming that every student stays but
they've been reassigned to Pleasant
Hill. So they'll actually it'll be the
number will be greater than that.
But we can walk through that in the
presentation.
>> Thank you. Okay, trustees, any
additional questions? Were you ready to
talk? Yeah, trustee Hunter.
>> Um, there was a caller that was very
concerned about registration. Um, the
process is very brutal. If you're not
familiar with the computer, whatever,
and they requested in-person
registration. I know we've done clinics
before, like mobile units. What is that
going to look like? especially with
everything that's going on so people can
know like what are my choices.
>> Yeah. So, um one of the things that
we're doing and you'll see this in the
slides is uh we're committing to um we
actually already have dates um and we're
going to start with the schools that
have um kind of the unique movement
around uh the dual language programming.
Um and so I think we're going to be at
Becker on the 9th. I think we're going
to be at Sunset Valley on the 10th. like
we've kind of laid out um the meetings
and and they're not going to be like you
know big community meetings. The goal is
to come in and then meet with each
family and say these are all the
available options um given where you
live like let's work with let's work so
you clearly understand you know what
options are available to you and then
help them get there and arrive there uh
and so that when we're going through the
the enrollment process registration
process it's all understood and we have
it on our end as well. Um so that's one
thing that we're doing. starting with
the wallto-wall do language because
there's kind of there's more nuance and
the hierarchy of priority makes it a
little more complicated and then going
to the other schools that are going
through that disruption as well. Um and
so that's how we're doing it. And then
just to be really clear on the back end
um Victoria O'Neal who is over
enrollment is kind of doing all of this
in the back end to make sure that the
system if it can't pick it up because of
where we are in the process we protect
it on the back end and go through the
placements. So that's how we're talking.
But it to me like going right after
break showing up at the schools with the
team, the dual language team and the
enrollment team and saying this is what
it is. This is how we can help you
identify the the location in the home
and then help them um kind of go through
that process.
>> In the instances where we know say a a
school is going to close and we the
parents already know that I'm going to
go to this school or that school, right?
Um I just there are community groups
asking like how can I help? And I always
feel like I don't know there's so many
things to do but I feel like if you are
amanable like registration like if
you're a Spanish speaker like come and
sit with somebody and help them. I did
it last year because a lady was just
sitting there. I was like you can do
this on your phone and we just did it on
her phone and we registered our kid for
the school.
>> Um but just having people there to
support that. So, uh, if if you can let
me know, then I can let those or I can
connect those groups with the
administration, uh, and you can kind of
plug those people in who are like, how
can we help?
>> Yeah. No, I I appreciate that. And I
will share with you, um, we we've
gotten, I think, better. There's still a
long way to go regarding kind of the
resources we can deploy across the
system. You know, some families don't
have access to the devices or the
technology required and it can be
cumbersome. Um, and I don't know that
we've done the best job of making sure
that we're present. um kind of on the
campus to help families with
registration. Uh but we've made some
adjustments. There's more to come. Uh
once we have a plan as far as the
deployment of those resources, we can
certainly partner with anybody. I mean,
we've even gotten to the point where
we're making phone calls, phone banks.
Um so, yeah, I'm happy to connect. Um
and and that is really why whatever we
decide to do, the earlier we do it helps
us. Um the later you go, the the less
time you have to actually get that part
right.
>> Thank you. Any other clarification
questions?
>> Um, there was a a caller or two talking
about the last minute updates
potentially past the Friday posting. Can
you speak to that at all?
>> Um, I I don't I'd have to see what
they're referring to. So, so just to be
clear, there are things that the board
is voting on that are governance and
then there are things that are
administrative like just kind of you
know working documents like all the
transfer priorities like all of that
that those aren't those are transition
standard operating procedures that we're
um deploying at the administration's
level. They're not policy changes.
They're not boundary changes. And so
those things like as I've committed to
our community like I am refining
refining refining those decisions that
are board level decisions those haven't
changed. Um so I don't know what
specifically that member was was
referring to but if they're asking like
if there was a document that was
changing I'd want to know kind of what
it was. But I will tell you even as of I
mean this morning you know about like
you know making sure it was really
really clear that the priority between a
transfer into a school that's closing
and a school that's being split you know
that it's clear that they're on the same
level and not one beneath the other
meaning that the transfer into the
community would have a higher priority
over someone who lives in the community.
Like we made that clear and so that was
a like a refinement but it's not any
that that's the kind of thing that that
we're refining right now. It's nothing
that impacts the board vote.
>> Gotcha. Okay. That that was my
assumption, but I guess without more
specificity.
>> I I'm guessing that's what it is. That's
what we've been working through like
those little pieces just as clarity.
>> Sorry.
>> Trusty Boswell, can we move these um to
the agenda item?
>> Anyone have I think we'll have some more
questions.
>> Yeah. Anyone have
>> Mr. Walker? Would that be more
appropriate?
Yes, I think that would be up to the
board for those questions if they're
related to the superintendent's
presentation. I think that would be
fine.
>> Okay. Anyone okay with that? Trusty
Kaufman, did you have a question you
want to ask?
>> I suggest we hold the questions till the
>> Let's do that. Perfect. All right. Um,
thank you to all of our callers and uh,
anyone who has comments or questions to
share between meetings can email the
board at trusteesaustinisd.org.
Thank you. Our next item is under the
president's report. And just as we
approach the Thanksgiving holiday, I
want to stop to share the board's
profound gratitude for every member of
our school community, our teachers and
staff, families, and students who are in
our schools every day. uh your
unwavering commitment to our excellent
and learning is the foundation of our
success and it's visible in every
classroom across our district and we
wish everyone a safe, restful and joyful
break and we look forward to continuing
our vital work together when we return.
Thank you. Um next is the announcement
of the board continuing education
credits. Texas law requires that school
boards publicly share the completion and
total number of credits for trustees. Uh
in 2025,
Lyn Boswell, Kevin Foster, Andrew
Gonzalez, Candace Hunter, David Kaufman,
Lady Sikintana, Fernando de Uoste, Arthy
Singh, and Katherine Wichu met or
exceeded the required minimum number of
topic one, topic two, and topic three
continuing education hours. These
included local district orientation,
orientation to the Texas Education Code,
post- legislative update to the Texas
Education Code, team building,
evaluating student academic performance,
and setting goals, identifying and
reporting abuse, trafficking, and other
maltreatment of children, safety
training, and other types of continuing
education. Experienced trustees are
required to complete five hours. New
trustees are required to complete 10
every year of continuing education. And
for this last year, trustees earn the
following additional hours. Uh Lyn
Boswell 20, Andrew Gonzalez 12.5,
Katherine 5, Candace um Hunter 11, Lady
Canana 25, Kevin Foster 5, David Kaufman
14.5,
um trustee date rodeoste 24, trustee
Singh five, and um thank you to my
colleagues for their commitment to
continuous learning. Uh our next item is
committee reports. We posted the written
committee reports as an attachment to
this item on board docs agenda and it
includes a committee report for the
board policy committee and we'll see
some policies uh that we're voting on
later during this meeting. And next up
is our superintendent report.
>> Uh thank you President Boswell. I'd like
to invite up Christine Steampport, our
operations officer, Brandy Jose, talent
strategy officer who will be kind of in
the background but available. Uh Iet
Kardanas, executive director of academic
programs and Dr. Dr. Lashonda Lewis,
executive director of student support
services. We also have Victoria O'Neal,
uh our director of um engagement and uh
enrollment. And so I'm going to to
deliver um kind of probably the hardest
superintendent report that I've had to
deliver uh regarding the recommendations
um for consolidations.
And um I want to acknowledge this has
been a a very disruptive um painful
process um for our community. Uh doing
this work is is not hard and not
something I ever wanted to do as the
superintendent.
Um I do know however that uh if we do
not evolve as a school system there
there are lots of challenges ahead that
I'm not sure we'll be able to to manage
appropriately or or mitigate. Um and
ultimately our are we have to be focused
on ensuring that our students get what
they need uh to be successful and and
also that we maintain local control so
that it's set in a way that aligns with
their values. And so we've been talking
about uh you know the this this goal of
ensuring that you know all of our
students have access to a um strong
vibrant well-resourced neighborhood
school and and we certainly know that we
have them in Austin ISD. um but they are
not everywhere
and the work required to to do this um
is coming at a time when there are so
many pressures within the education
system. Uh we've we've heard our
community um share with us kind of their
um understanding of these pressures and
they're real whether it's budget
shortfalls, the ever changing
accountability system, you know, the
TARE order that we've been managing now
and supporting for two years and and the
reality is that we just don't have the
resources to to do what we need to do.
the funding in public education has not
kept up with the rising cost and we are
simply um we just don't have the
resources and if we continue on down
this path without a significant change
um the risk again that'll be introduced
will be ones that'll be very difficult
for us to to recover from. And so as we
took this work on we wanted to be really
clear that there were things that we had
to accomplish. Um, one, we knew that and
I still very strongly believe that
boundary changes must absolutely must be
uh changed as part of this process
overall. Um, feeder pattern alignment in
Austin ISD uh has to be a focus of our
work. Uh, I certainly am disappointed
that it's not in this deliverable, but I
am committed to moving forward with that
work and and bringing that forward. Uh,
ensuring that our programs are sustained
long term. Uh we have incredible
programs all over the city. Uh these
programs however have shifted over time
and given the changes ahead of us
regarding the requirements in staffing
or just the the realization that the
focus of the student population has been
has shifted over time uh movement of
these programs is necessary to ensure
sustainability
closures and and merging of schools uh
to reduce the number of open seats in
our school system. you know, right now
at over 20,000 seats, uh, which is a
significant number. Um, you know, I I
think about that just the Moody Center
is, you know, 17,000 seats. You think
about, um, this Yeah. So, three, you
know, 3,000 seats more than the Moody
Center. um the a high school, you know,
having, you know, 3,000 seats, you know,
we're talking about, you know, dozen,
you know, many buoys, many many high
schools of just excess capacity. And and
um you know, it's not uh lost on me that
it's not easy to um reduce the number of
seats without creating an extreme
disruption in our community. Um I want
to apologize for that, but there isn't a
simple way to do this work. And so we
were committed uh to do this and and to
do it in a way that engage with
community. Um we started this work back
in February and March. Uh we created a
timeline. Uh the timeline for us was set
before the uh TEA timeline was provided
regarding turnaround plans. We knew that
they would converge, but I I do want to
acknowledge that the the the milestone
set by the agency created pressure um in
the fall semester because of of when the
ratings came out and when the turnaround
plans would would be required to be
submitted. Uh we've had 170 um
engagement uh sessions throughout uh
this period of time, lots of feedback
from our community. And when I look at
the
current uh recommendation, you know, I
can see uh in each item, whether it's in
the implementation or in the
recommendation itself, um distinct um
elements of community feedback. And I
know it may not always seem that way
because many cases that our community
wants what we're not able to do. But the
adjustments and refinements I I I want
our community to know have um very much
considered the input and and the great
understanding that our community has of
their schools.
So, as part of this um plan um which I'm
kind of identifying as part one, we do
include school closures um program
changes and transfer policy updates. Uh
we are recommending that these go into
effect in the 2627 school year. Uh and
and I want to also be really clear that
um I'm not wanting to bring this this
aspect of the work or anything done in
2627 in the spring semester. you know,
we cannot take away the only thing um
that we need to ensure our families have
in this process, which is time to plan.
If we wait into the spring semester to
make any changes, our system will not be
able to respond appropriately. Our
students will not be supported in the
way that they should be. We have
examples of that um in the last many
years. So, that's not something I'm
going to do. um we're gonna if we're
going to make a hard decision, I want to
make it with enough time for our
families to plan, for our system to
respond, and for um us to be prepared to
welcome our students um at the start of
the next school year. So, uh these are
for 2627.
Uh and I I do want to be really clear. I
do view this as part one of a
comprehensive plan. as a school board
and uh with this administration, we've
talked about academic plan envisioning
consolidations regarding balance
enrollment and boundary p you know uh
feeder pattern alignment that work um
you know after conversations with the
board over the next coming weeks you
know needs to to progress in some way.
Um this can't continue on like the
disruption is just it's just too
significant. Uh as we move on to slide
six, um many of these were discussed
already as part of the previous
presentation, but I think it's important
we list them all. Uh these are all the
closures or student reassignments um
associated with this part of the plan.
Um you can see Bington uh in the uh
closure and movement to grow at Thompson
Waldridge Becker uh with the dual the
dual language program and the
assignments to Galindo and Zilker Dawson
to Galindo Oak Springs to Blackshere. Uh
and as we get into the specifics, we'll
have kind of more details around just
things that we are considering as part
of this uh in the upcoming slides. uh
Ridgetop uh closure with um the program
uh moving and being introduced at
Pickle. We just talked about that.
Sensit Valley with the assigned students
going to Cunningham and Boone and then
um the program moving to um uh Odum
Woodain to Rodriguez which we've talked
about um as part of the previous
presentation when Monasuri this is one
that we spent a lot of time and it's
it's shifted certainly um initially on
October 3rd and October 31st it was
proposed to to move to go valley um we
heard from our community and from our
board that displacement of students um
who those schools are built for was was
going to be something that um w was
needed to be reconsidered uh and and we
made adjustments and we also met with
the wind community and we knew that
being closer to where wind monastery was
was preferable. What we ran into was
that the same disruption would occur if
if the if the move was at pean springs
which was a three UA tap or elsewhere.
So we really try to find a solution that
didn't create other challenges or just
replicate the disruption that we were
avoiding at Go Valley Zavalo Ortega.
Um Betachch Middle School um the uh
distribution of students between
Covington Prett Mendes uh where Coington
receives the tap. um want to be really
clear. Um our my expectation is that we
begin the planning process um
immediately in the spring semester uh to
reinvision uh Betachch Middle School uh
so that um we are prepared to support a
school um at that um location um down in
South Austin and we we there is a
significant need um and and we want to
do that planning with community uh and
the same is true for Martin where the
Martin students are being reszoned to
Keeling um but We want to activate
Martin Middle School, Martin site, and
and really work with community to
determine uh what the future program
will be. And and I also want to be um
clear with the community that over the
last many weeks, you know, as ideas came
up, I know there's been confusion
around, you know, uh why this school was
talked about or or you know, Matias, are
you looking at at this solution or these
program moves? I've always been honest.
if something is being talked about, I'm
going to tell our community that we're
evaluating it and and that's uh what
we've done. And I know that sometimes
creates stress in our system, but I want
to be very transparent that if there's
an idea, I'm committed to exploring it.
And just by exploring it, I think it's
important that we communicate with that
community. As we look at the next slide,
um uh this is a uh an estimate of the
reduction in cost um regarding these
consolidations. There's been lots of
conversations around, you know, with the
three schools being pulled off, what did
that change? And if you remember, that
was closer to 25 million. So, it's come
down a little bit to 21.5.
I also want to be really clear that um
there there are lots of details that I I
think that um are are desired um and and
it really comes down to like budget
level items that we as a district manage
kind of at a campus level. And so at
this time, you know, with the work that
we've done, we've taken other direct
costs, we've taken SA um staff
allocations, we've looked at the
combination of schools, the movement of
students, and then built up this
estimated cost savings. Um it is it is
as granular as can be given where we are
in the process. Um I heard from our
community uh a desire to kind of track
and show kind of what this looks like. I
want to be really clear, you know, we
are this is a reduction in a reoccurring
cost. Um, you know, year 1, year two,
year three will all look slightly
different. Um, but this is a a
reoccurring cost uh that will help um
offset some of the costs that we have
right now and certainly move us in the
right direction regarding our budget.
And so I'm going to hand it over now to
Christine to take and the team because
it gonna kind of be a triad between
Avet, Victoria, and Christine to kind of
take us through expeditiously the next
set of slides and then we'll I'll take
it back.
>> Thank you, Superintendent Sigura. Um I
just want to draw your attention to this
slide. We're going to go through each of
the schools and um kind of talk through
um you will see a map on uh the slide as
well. This is really talking about the
zone. Um, since we are no longer doing
boundaries, our terminology, and I just
want to make sure it's very clear, will
be zoned or reassigned. And so, if you
see here for Bington, this is a TAP
campus. Um, the blue, 83 Bington
resident students would be reassigned to
Waldridge. And in the green, 247 Bington
students would be reassigned to Guerrero
Thompson. And I want to um make sure
that our Bington families and students
know um that they have the following
choices. So, I'm going to pass it over
to my colleague, uh, Miss O'Neal.
>> Thank you. Um, so, uh, any student who
is zoned to Bington has the following
choices. Um, they can attend Guedto
Thompson or Waldridge as they're
assigned by their address. Um, if they
are assigned, if they are reassigned to
Waldridge, they can apply to transfer to
Guedto Thompson um, with priority and
vice versa. So if they're assigned to by
address to Guido Thompson um they are um
they have a priority um transfer
application to Waldridge. Uh similar to
all students in AISD um they are also
able to apply to transfer to any other
AISD campus with the preferred
programming um via general transfer and
and the typical policies. Any students
who have um transferred into um Bington
um uh would also be given priority
consideration at Gordeta Thompson and
Waldridge.
>> Thank you, Victoria. um next to Becker
Elementary School which is a program
shift um all um you'll see here in um
orange and that is a 138 Becker reside
students would be reassigned to um
Zilker excuse me and then in Galindo
um we have in purple excuse me 36 Becker
reside students would be reassigned to
um Galindo oh I'm sorry I've crossed
I've crossed those um and So, we want to
talk about also our Spanish dual
language program in which I'll pass to
Evette and then Victoria can go over the
options for the students.
>> Yes. I think Superintendent uh Sigura
said it well um earlier, but again to
reiterate um this the intent is to
become a schoolwide um at Sanchez, but
for now it is going to be introduced at
uh Sanchez is a two-way program. It is a
robust uh program and so families from
Becker will be able to choose um Sanchez
to participate and then have other
options as well as what's been stated
today.
Um and so the zone students who are
zoned to Becker um uh similar to um
Bington can attend Galindo or Zilker as
assigned by their home address or um
apply to the other um that they have not
been assigned to with a priority. uh and
Becker transfer in students. Um similar
uh and then with the dual language
options um if they apply to Sanchez that
would be uh they would be first um
priority at Sanchez. Uh and then um at
ODM Pickle and Wooten um they the Becker
students would then be um uh have
priority there as well behind the um
group that was kind of assigned to that
campus. Um and as uh with every student
um all of our families do have um open
enrollment uh open um transfer
applications to other campuses if that
uh matches what their um family's desire
is.
>> Thank you. Moving on to Dawson
Elementary. This is a tap and so um we
have here the Dawson zone and that
Dawson zone holy would go into Galindo.
And so students have the following
choices.
Um so when there is 100% of the students
being reassigned to a single campus um
that also includes any students who have
transferred into Dawson um they can uh
if they're zoned to Dawson they can
attend Galindo or um they can access the
um transfer application to any other
campus. Um and students who have
transferred into Dawson would be um also
have um a priority status if they apply
to Galindo.
Next is Oak Springs. Um as you can see
here on the map, we have uh Oak Springs
wholly going into Blackshere. I also
wanted to note that um I know
Superintendent Sigura um said this
prior, but community engagement will
still continue to determine the final
location of the school because we know
that there was conversation between
Black and Oak Springs. So that will
continue to happen. Um and talking about
the students zoned to Oak Springs have
the following choices. they can either
attend Blackshere Elementary as assigned
by their home address or how Victoria
has been um stating with the other
campuses, they can apply to transfer to
another Austin ICD campus um with their
preferred programming via general
transfer.
>> Yeah. Before we leave that one, I want
to be really clear. Um be by board
policy, we could always introduced a
introduce a um a route if there is a
hazardous intersection. we we're already
going to go ahead and just commit to
adding transportation for students um at
Oak Springs even if they're in the two-m
proximity um to support the students
that really just access Oak Springs by
crossing the street. Um so we put that
here in the note so it's it it will come
back but it's committed to we can do it
not a problem and we heard that from
community as well. Continue on.
>> Thank you.
Next up is Ridgetop Elementary School,
which is a program shift. And so, as you
can see here on the map, um Ridgetop
Elementary would no longer be zoned and
those students would be reassigned to
the neighborhood school, which would be
Riley. And there are also, um, a few
other options based off of the Spanish
dual language program that I'll let
Evette talk about. And then going on to
their options for other schools with
Victoria.
>> Yeah. So, similar to the previous plan,
right, of um inviting um and having uh
families from uh Richtop join Pickle
Elementary, that will still continue.
So, that is still an option for our
families from Richtop
Elementary.
And um with the address uh reassignment
uh to Riley, uh those students would be
um treated as as zone students and so
they would have that guaranteed
enrollment there. Um they would have
that first priority transfer um to
pickle and then um ODM Sanchez and
Wooten as well um as that second
priority and again open um transfer
applications as well.
>> Moving on to Sunset Valley. This is also
a program shift. Um, Sunset Valley um in
the pink you can see here um that was
the former the the boundary here for
Sunset Valley as a whole. It is shifting
into two to make sure that we can
accommodate the student um counts. So in
the pink 210 students for Sunset Valley
um would be reassigned to Cunningham and
in the blue 91 Sunset Valley resident
students would be reassigned to Boone.
And so I'll let Ivette talk a little bit
about the um districtwide.
>> Yes. So for this one, ODM will um start
off as a schoolwide dual language
program um just as we had previously
talked about.
>> Um so the Sunset Valley students would
have uh who are zoned there would have
the opportunity to attend um Boone or
Cunningham as assigned by their home
address. um transfer
um students who have transferred into
Sunset Valley uh would have um a
priority uh transfer to those campuses.
Um and um the uh attendance at ODM is
prioritized for Sunset Valley students
who want to continue with that dual
language program and then um Sanchez
Pickle and Wooten uh as options as well.
Um, and I haven't said it before, but
um, the dual language, uh, program,
which is at currently, uh, 59 of our
campuses, um, uh, is another option for
people who want to continue dual
language if, um, there's a program
that's closer to their home, um, or, uh,
anything like that. So, those programs
will also be application options for
everybody, not just Sunset Valley.
>> Thank you, Victoria. Moving on to
Wedane, which is a tap school. So, as
you can see on the map, this is Wedane's
boundary. And so, those students would
be reassigned wholly to Rodriguez
Elementary. And so, um, those students
zoned to Wedane have the following
choices. They can attend Rodriguez
Elementary as assigned by their home
address, or they can like, um, like all
the other schools, apply to transfer to
another Austin ISD campus with their
preferred programming via general
transfer. Um, let me see. Would I
missed? Nope, I haven't missed anything.
Um, moving on to Win Monasuri. Um, as
you can see, the boundary for WIN is a
little bit little bit funky there.
They've got some blue two blue parts.
And so, um, in blue, the 193 WIN
resident uh, students would now be
reassigned to Andrews. And in the
purple, 49 resident students would be
reassigned to PCON Springs. And so um
I'll talk a little bit about the um
their options here or Victoria can talk
about their options because it does
include the option for the monastery
strand at Riley. Um yes so um students
who are zoned to win have the option to
um attend uh Andrews or Picon Springs by
their address. Uh students who have
transferred into win would have that
priority um if they apply to those
campuses as well. And um the Riley uh
Monatory Strand uh which will be
established this upcoming year uh is
holding the priority seats for the wind
students um and again the open
applications that are available.
>> Thank you. Moving to Betachch Middle
School which is another TAP campus. So
in the green you will see that uh 134
bet resident students would be
reassigned to Mendes. Um, in the teal,
429 betichek resident students would be
reassigned to Covington and Covington
would assume the tap. Um, and in purple,
192 bet resident students would be
reassigned to Pareetes. And so, um,
again, those students zoned to Betachch
have um, the choices to attend their
school assigned by their home address or
I'll let Miss O'Neal talk through those
options as well.
>> For sure. Um so because this one is uh
the middle schools are um three-way uh
it basically is the same pattern um and
so if they are um uh assigned to
Covington they would be um considered
priority at Pedes and Mendes continuing
down the list of schools and um also uh
we will any student who has transferred
into Betachch um would be um uh also
considered um priority for those
campuses. as well.
>> Thank you. Moving on to Martin Middle
School, which also is a tab campus. If
you can see on the right in our map in
blue, 102 Martin resident students would
be reassigned to Marshall. Um that
little that little zone there. And then
in purple, 209 Martin students would be
reassigned to Lively. And then in the
teal, 485 Martin resident students would
be reassigned to Keeling. And so Keeling
would um be implementing the TAP. And so
the students zone to Martin have um the
following choices. Of course, attend
their school by um assigned home
address. And I'll let Miss O'Neal talk
about the options for sure. Um and um
it's very similar pattern to um
Betachch. Uh so um if you if the student
is assigned to Keeling um and they apply
to Marshall or Lively, uh that would be
considered with priority. um if assigned
to um Lively um then they would have
priority at Marshall or Keeling and so
on um with the list of three um similar
um for those any students who have
transferred into Martin and um open
transfer opportunities as well.
>> All right, moving on to Riley Elementary
School which is a program shift. So, um,
talking just through that, um, Riley El
Riley Elementary would receive students
from Ridgetop, which is proposed to
close at the end of school year 2526.
And so, I'll let Evette talk about a
little bit about the program moves to
Wooten and the program um that would be
moving from Win Monastery.
>> Yes. So, um, for this one, the
schoolwide Spanish dual language program
would be introduced to Wooten and it
would include the Spanish dual language
program and the Mandarin dual language
program as well.
Uh, and um adding in the strand of um,
Montasauri from Wyn as well. So Riley
students um have the ability to stay at
Riley. Um if they would like to uh
follow the two-way uh the Spanish or
Mandarin dual language programs um they
can they would have priority at Wooten.
Uh the Spanish uh dual language students
also have opportunities at ODM Sanchez
and Pickle. Um and uh open transfer
opportunities.
Okay. And moving on lastly to ODM
elementary school. This is our program
shift. Um this is the one campus that is
um proposed to be repurposed as the only
unzoneed schoolwide dual language
program at the at the time. And so um
ODM students have um have been reszoned
to Pleasant Hill Elementary School as
assigned by their home address. And so
they have a few other options as well um
to attend ODM schoolwide dual language
program via priority transfer. And so
I'll let the colleagues talk through
that.
Um, one thing that is unique to ODM is
that, um, as a transition, their current
third and fourth grade students, um, in
the English, uh, ESL classrooms, uh,
will be maintained at ODM if they choose
to stay there. Um, it is a family
choice. Uh, they have the opportunity
to, uh, transition to Pleasant Hill as
well, um, or apply, um, for a transfer
elsewhere. And um if there are uh ODM
families um who would like to take
advantage of um other dual language
programs uh that is also available.
>> Thank you. And that concludes that um
part with the maps and so I will um pass
it to Superintendent Sigura to kind of
just talk about the overview of our
program changes.
>> Yeah. Um, so just I'll run through some
of the the next changes because there
are many things that uh don't require
necessarily board vote, but I I always
want to be transparent. I want to
communicate to our families and staff
what is in the plan and what they can
expect uh as we move forward. Uh so some
other administrative changes uh we
already talked about the monastery uh
program uh ODM uh unzoned which has
already been talked about. uh sixth
grade um at those three remaining
schools, Blazier, uh Matthews, and Lee
Elementary. This has been a conversation
with those principles over the course of
the year. Uh it is something uh that we
intended to have in the larger plan. Uh
we I want to be really clear like we
don't arrive at these decisions or
recommendations without principal voice
and principal and CAC and conversations
there. So, um, this is really an effort
to align our system, uh, and be
responsive, uh, to what, um, our
community and our schools need.
International High School, this is one
of those that's been really hard for us.
You know, we've been impacted by the
changes at the federal level regarding
immigration and, uh, International High
School has certainly been impacted.
Currently, right now, there are 10 ninth
graders uh, and um, 81 tenth graders.
And so the way that this program works,
what we would expect is that next year
you would have 10 10th graders and
probably the same or fewer nth graders.
So as you can imagine, as a school with
less than 100 students projected to get
to less than 25, um it's just not
sustainable in its current form. We uh
had explored modifying and creating a
program at Novado. uh after going you
know and working with um our staff I
it's become uh clear that just the
number of students and given the
supports that are already at Navaro that
uh the the program itself um doesn't
need to exist in the way that it has um
so so international high school is going
to close down as a campus traditional
campus uh but again you know we will
serve our student population there is a
large number of students uh that are
immigrant um students at these schools
and and we're going to support them. Um
so s really want to touch on that
transportation.
Uh want to be really clear that we have
made commitments as part of this process
uh to ensure that our students have
access to to the programs especially
when there is a transition. You heard me
earlier talk about Oak Springs. Um I I
also want to be really clear that you
know the monastery program currently
already does offer transportation across
the district. Uh and we are just going
to continue that. you know, we don't
want to make a disruption uh in that
program. We want to make sure that it's
supported as it moves into the new home
at Riley. And then there are some
options regarding students who are uh at
Becker, Richtop, and Sza Valley because
they are closing.
They have
>> districtwide transportation.
>> Correct. Currently.
>> Yeah. So that's Yep. It's been been
there for a little while.
Uh and so uh for Becker, Richtop and
Sunset Valley, two specific options that
are unique here. So attend attend the
school to which they have been assigned
by address um which is always the case.
And then for one year, we're going to
provide transportation from the assigned
these students in the assigned area to
the new program. So Becker to Sancha,
Sensitive Valley to ODM, Riley to
Wooten, and Richtople. Um and uh just
wanted to make it clear that we're
providing that support during this
transition period and that certainly can
be revisited. uh next year and typically
those policies or those changes come to
the board in spring kind of April May
time frame. Uh so that always an
adjustment we can make at a later date
if we need to. Uh I will hand it over to
Victoria to take us through slide 22
just to kind of highlight some of the
additional enrollment and transfer
policy changes.
>> Yeah, thank you very much. Um so in
terms of the enrollment system and
transfer in general um one of the
biggest changes uh that's upcoming is
the introduction of a lottery for
general transfer requests which
currently have been done on a case-byase
uh uh rolling um model uh and um that
has caused um it it adds a an ongoing
task to our principles and it leads to
families getting communication in uh
varying timelines depending on the
workflow for the different campuses.
And then um it also has uh was the uh
driving factor behind the dynamic weight
lists which was particularly frustrating
I know for families. Uh and so by
introducing that lottery for general
transfer requests. Um everybody will get
notification on the same day. They will
be very clear what seat they have been
offered. It will be clear what their
position on the weight list would be and
that would never uh they would never go
down. They could only go up the weight
list. Um and um and so we believe that
that will be a transformational change
in terms of our ability to communicate
with our families and their ability to
plan. Um we are bringing in more of a
collaborative determination of transfer
capacity um balancing um uh you know um
our ability to make um calculations and
predictions and vetting those with the
principles. Uh that is also something
that we're doing to um support the
principles who have had a lot of
responsibility um in that area which is
which is a lot of pressure. And so we're
bringing in definitely more
collaboration on that um to um uh also
help um maintain um you know a healthy
transfer rate for um different campuses.
Uh and then um we have we are both
maintaining and strengthening the
commitment to sibling and staff
transfers.
Um the transition priorities uh have
been provided for affected students as
we've talked about through the um
campuses uh that we've talked about. Um
and just wanted to add that we are going
to be very very hightouch uh with those
applications um looking to see because
we know that every family has choice um
the um uh to to ensure that those are um
that we're matching students um with the
place the campuses that they have
applied to that we are respecting the
priorities that we have committed to um
and so that will all be like I said very
hight touch before they receive those
transfer seat decisions Um and the
priorities described because they are
transition priorities will be in place
for this uh spring enrollment season. Um
and just uh a reminder that you know
transfers are based on capacity as we
have talked about. And then um yes um
the next slide shares a little bit about
um it kind of ma generalizes some of the
um transfer the transition priorities
that we've talked about when we talked
about each individual school. So, um,
non-transfer students, so a zoned
student who's affected by a school
closure, regardless of program, um, will
always have a guaranteed seat at the
reassigned receiving school, um, can
apply for a general transfer to any
other campus under the regular policies
and can apply for a new program transfer
to any other campus under the regular
policies as well. And um we do respect
the community nature that um if you have
transferred into a community and you
have been uh committed um to that then
um you also have um priorities uh as
well. So what this means is that um the
affected students would be um placed
first and then if there were additional
capacity and there were um additional
applicants from students who were not
affected by any of these changes uh then
they would um uh then we would evaluate
those based on kind of the standard um
policies and procedures uh and and
priorities.
>> All right, next slide. Yes, thank you.
So, we recognize that this has been
really hard for our community, for our
students, and for our staff members. And
so, we have been intentional with making
sure that we're providing supports for
for our staff and our students on our
campuses. And so, what we have been
doing is um from our first um release of
the consolidation plan, we've had our
licensed mental health professionals on
our campuses providing support for our
staff um with our principles. Um that
continues. Um, we have also had our
directors of our counseling and um, our
coordinators of our counseling
departments meeting individually with
the administrators and the counselors on
campus to process um, their emotions and
their thoughts behind what um, the
information is that they're hearing, but
also to provide um, opportunities for
processing circles for their staff um,
and as well as um, making plans for
future um, supports on their campuses.
We are also um uh we've also provided a
a Google form for our administrators to
complete to allow them to give us
information on what supports they think
they may need. Some some principles have
reached out to us asking for processing
circles for their staff um or
restorative practices for their staff.
Some of them have also even reached out
for our employee assistant program and
so we've been able to connect them with
those resources as well. Um at a
previous meeting I talked about a bridge
team which um is a multi-ep department
um group of district staff um from
departments of course counseling but
we've also pulled in individuals from
our special education department, our
MTSS department, our creative learning
departments to really think through what
type of um activities and resources we
can provide for our community and for
our students and staff on our campuses
so that we can bridge that gap from
where we are currently to where we are
going to be in the future. And so we are
dedicated to um ensuring that we're
intentional with those supports not only
um right now as we're going through this
process but as we go into next school
year as well.
>> Thank you Dr. Lewis. As we close out the
presentation I I do want to um
communicate uh how we're going to share
all these updates with our families. So
pending tonight's vote um amongst these
agenda items uh we will send community
letters uh from myself um and there may
be one from our board of trustees. We're
also going to send individualized campus
letters. You know, each campus is going
to have a different um kind of
experience regarding the impact of the
vote. And so, we want to make sure that
we're very clear and responsive um and
sharing precisely what that community
can expect. Uh and we're also going to
send staff letters and staff preference
surveys. So, this is something that
we've talked about a couple different
times, but what this is meant to do is
to um hear from our staff uh all staff,
all campus staff, and not just staff
that are impacted um by these votes, but
all staff regarding um what they um what
preference they have, if any, regarding
the change. And and the reason that we
want to do this is because we have been
committed to throughout the entire
process to ensure that every stu every
employee um classified or nclassified
uh campus based staff or anybody that is
in our campus um has a home if they
choose to stay with Austin ISD. We've
been committed to it from day one. Uh we
we are able to do it. Um it's it's a um
a benefit of our size given just the
attrition you typically see in the
school year. and we we have a thoughtful
plan in how we're going to prioritize
those staff who have been with us. But
to do that well, we need to understand
what they want. And so this survey is
intended to do that. Uh we'll release
tomorrow morning. I have a principal
check-in tomorrow afternoon. Uh and
that'll really set us up moving into the
weekend uh into the the break because I
I want to make sure that as we go into
these long breaks, we're providing as
much information as possible. uh in
December when we come out back from
break, I've we've already committed to
having um dual language enrollment
information clinics. Uh you can see here
where they're committed, the times that
they're committed. So Becker will be
December 9th from 3:30 to 5:30, Richtop
December 10th from 3:30 to 5:30. Riley
from 3:30 to 5:30 to 16th, and then on
the 17th at Sunset Valley um same time,
3:30 to 5:30. We've also added a um an
email uh link dlransition austinisd.org.
This is really in an effort to be
responsive. We'd love to have someone be
able to answer the phones and and and
make sure every question gets answered,
but we understand the volume may get to
a point where we're not able to provide
that response with the detail that our
families um deserve. And so um what we
wanted to do instead of creating any
frustration with our families is just be
uh ensure ensure that we have one place
where we're receiving all of that. we
can track and then immediately respond
uh and and just can it keep track of
that uh so nothing gets lost. And I also
want to reinforce that the nuance of all
the different options needs to be well
understood and if we have like a phone
bank or people who aren't as familiar
responding, it could create confusion in
our community. So I wanted to make sure
we address it in that way. um next steps
on December 18th. Uh I do want to come
back and provide an update. Um after I
have time to to speak to each of our
board members regarding, you know, what
the spring semester will look like, um
the work around boundaries, uh
consolidations, anything that um and the
academic vision and plan. I I I really
want to make sure our families
understand what to expect from AISD
before we go into the winter break. And
uh as I close out, I just want to um say
once again uh this has been a difficult
process. Um but uh along the way, I've
been very encouraged with just the
commitment from our community to to show
up every day for their schools. Um you
know, I that's what you want, right? You
want communities that love their schools
and we have incredible schools. Um so I
I appreciate our staff. I appreciate our
community. Um and most importantly, our
students. Um, this is difficult. Uh, and
um, I wish we didn't have to do it, but
the pressures are gargantuan and
without, uh, a significant change, um,
we will not be the school district that
ultimately can protect who we are moving
forward. Um, and so with that, I will
open it up to any questions the trustees
have and um,
you know, be team and I will as well as
everybody else in the room will be able
to answer any questions. I just wanted
to ask if we're operating under
timelines either voluntary or enforced
with our questioning time
>> um
this time
>> I mean are we choosing to self-regulate
or to have five minute time constraints
given on our questioning so or are we is
it a free roll
>> Josh do we have space to talk as much as
we feel like we need to
>> and it's 11 pm so
>> and it's 11 p.m. So if we want to do
five minutes at a time and see how it
goes
Yeah. Oh, it's midnight. It's 11:46.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, yeah, let's we can try to be
efficient out of respect to each other
and our community
>> and the process. Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Um, who who has a question or comment
first?
>> Trusty Coffman.
>> Uh, so I just have a couple. I've had
many many questions over the last
several months and I've asked and
they've been answered. So, I will
restrict myself to a few um that came up
new tonight to me. Um one, would would
transportation be provided for Betachch
dual language students who would now be
assigned to Mendes where no dual
language program is offered?
So um that that's one of those we we can
make adjustment that do you want to
>> or would they otherwise have access to a
dual language program to provide
continuity of their programming?
>> So we currently have um transportation
for students that are opting out of
Mendes to Paredes. But you were asking
specifically about Betach. I just want
to ensure that students who are that all
students who are zoned to Mendes who are
um either legally entitled to dual
language or who are in
continuously enrolled in a dual language
program would be able to continue.
>> So we've had those conversations and we
would continue the agreement that we
have.
>> Okay. So that would apply to the new
students. Okay. Thank you.
>> Do I have a timer?
>> Okay. Can we do our little timer thing
or no?
>> Okay. Um no. So the second question, by
law, a student's participation in a
newcomer program like at international
high school is restricted to two years.
Um and as in the past at East Side, the
students were welcomed and treated as
Panthers, I believe, and were um able to
continue with transportation for their
junior and senior years after exiting
the newcomer school after sophomore
year. Um has that practice continued at
Northeast where students are now rebel I
mean are um
raiders and are allowed to continue
their junior and senior year.
>> Yes.
>> And so would that so what would happen
now in this case if we have students who
are currently freshman or sophomores at
international high school. It said in
the slide that they would be returned to
their home school, but would that be
would we not be continuing the pro the
practice of
you know enabling them once a raider to
always be a raider for those four years?
>> So uh we have also looked at the
addresses where students live and most
of them live in the northeast um area
where they're at now. So that would
actually be their home school.
>> Okay. Most
>> um others who would be
been unable to continue in that
capacity.
>> I think that we need to look into that.
>> Okay. I would like to learn more about
that. Um and then I would I I do I'm not
asking for them now, but I do believe
the um we need more public information
about what the newcomer support would
look like at high schools. I do think
there is a very elaborate plan that is
fully developed for what newcomer
support can and should look like at high
schools. Um, and I think it would be
helpful to have that be a little more
public and then also to to really focus
in on whether that will be implemented
fully.
>> Um, again, I had millions of other
questions, but most of them have been
asked already. So, thank you.
>> Thank you.
Who else has question comment? Trusty
Whitley Chu.
All right. Um, so I have a kind of
question comment. Um,
so with our our programmatic changes
that are moving,
you know, it's says that people will be
in the general transfer window and
they'll they'll find out in March
if they have a spot. So, so if Becker
closes, if Ridgetop closes, if Riley
closes,
they will find out in March if they have
a spot at a school. When will they find
out?
>> Yeah. So, we um intend to um have the uh
the new dual language programs in round
one. Um and typically um so we're on a
slightly adjusted schedule right now. We
anticipate um round one to open in um uh
early January um the second week of
January we think and then um to be open
for um uh approximately four weeks and
so there'll be a full court press to
make sure that um we get um everybody uh
reregistered uh who wants to be and then
um approximately two weeks after that
window closes uh the families would
receive notification.
>> What is that what is that date? What is
that month? So we are um still working
on finalizing the exact calendar dates
and so I don't want to misspe at
>> February March it would be the second
week in February.
>> It would be um
>> ideally is what you're or
>> before the end of February I think I can
commit to
>> okay
>> um like and I like I think the
enrollment department since I feel like
since I've been here has all been about
like enroll Austin and figuring out that
system. I I know that these families,
they can tell you in December where they
want to go, and I know that we can tell
them if they have room.
I know there's room to guarantee spots
for people to move together. Like I I I
know that is true. Um
you know, you're saying families need
certainty. They really need certainty.
Um if we're wanting to retain families,
which that is what Yeah,
>> that is that is what I that's like
they have to know like they have been
through so much. They need certainty of
where they're going to go and you know
having questions back and forth to ask
about the rules staff we don't have the
staff to do that. It would be so much
easier to just I love that you have the
meetings in person and say if we know in
December we can tell you if you have to
prioritize people. So these are really
really popular programs that pull in a
lot of people out of district. These are
so so in demand programs. People will
drive
very far to go to them. We have to
prioritize
Austin ISD residents because we are
fiduciaries of the district.
>> So I think we can let people know.
>> Yeah. So um I can work with Victoria. I
mean, we we know that there's, like you
said, there's there is space. Um, and I
want to commit as early as I can. Uh,
that is for sure. Um, and so it sounds
like what I'm hearing, trusty Willie,
true, is if prioritizing in AISD versus
out of AISD transfers helps provide
certainty, then I can maybe
provide that certain certainty earlier.
If I'm combining out of district
transfers and indistrict transfers into
the program, then that number may be get
in some is to is closer to the like what
makes it uncomfortable to say guarantee.
So it sounds like
>> yeah, if people let you know because I I
know that we do not have the staff
capacity to go back and forth with all
these questions procedurally.
I I know all these folks. They'll make
they'll make you a spreadsheet tomorrow.
>> Or let's let's give them some more time.
I mean, but they they would like our
community wants to help. Yeah,
>> they will will help us.
>> I mean, that's good feedback. I mean, I
want to get this done. I want to get I
want and that's why we're having the
conversations at each of these campuses.
So maybe what we can do is Avette and
Victoria, we kind of create a database
and if we can get commitments,
>> y'all might not even have to create I'm
I'm telling you
>> I need the data set,
>> but create the
>> the the data set that will and with the
commitment right because I need the
commitment in order to to protect the
space.
>> Yep. Um but if we get get that early um
in the amount I'm I'm certain that we
can find a solution that gets us for
more information and more certainty much
earlier than waiting for all of it to
come. Um it may just be like a
commitment from the organization and
then they'll get the commitment from the
system.
>> Uh that's just kind of how it has to
work because they have to bundle.
>> Yes, I know. I know.
>> But I we we I could I want to be
responsive to that. I understand
certainly how disruptive this is and
this is and if I can provide certainty
early I will 100%.
>> Yeah. Let's not make like what is
people's worst case scenario like for
for for our families for many of our
families on the outcome of this vote. It
doesn't have to be it it doesn't have to
be worse. Um and I think families
families are we I mean we're all tired
right now.
>> Yeah. So let me do this. Um I will work
with Victoria and Avette. Um, we will
have a structure in place before we show
up to any of those schools that I'll
send to our trustees just for awareness
purposes. Um, and I can share with you
how I can be responsive to that because
I want to do what you want to do. Um, I
I promise you
>> I know you do. I know.
>> So, let So, that that'll give you the
Thursday. Well, that'll be the 9th. So,
it'll be around the same time, but the
week we come back, I'll I'll share
something with you about how we can get
closer to that.
>> I I'd love I think our community would
love that. Um, I think we'd uh also love
a list of dual language of campuses that
offer dual language um that have room
because I think we can guarantee spots
at more, you know, I think all these
campuses are like are are wonderful
options. But yeah, just so people know
it might be closer to their house where
they work. Like I know if my kids like
my schedule is so tight like I I can
only teach at ACC Highland if they're
like, "Oh, will you teach?" No, because
and if if my school moved either more
like if I got moved south or west, like
I would not make it to my class on time
after dropping off my kids. So, um this
is for people's jobs and just for their
kids. So, thank you.
>> We can do that.
Thank you. Anything else right now?
>> I just had a quick question on staffing.
Um I know several schools have kind of
um advocated for amendments to the plans
specifically, you know, doing restarts
instead of closures and considering the
staffing requirements on the restarts
and the ACE model. Um, do we have any
reason to believe would we be able to
staff campuses if we moved them to
restarts instead of closures?
We have um
I think we would be Yeah, we'd be able
to I mean I the staffing is
teacher the educator staffing is not the
biggest um
challenge in meeting the expectation
regarding the dis the state's ACE model.
Right. just be clear like it's not that
it's a that structure ace is something
that is set at the agency and and it
means that you're going to go through
this process and create the structure um
because we have lots of educators that
meet that criteria. So I feel very
confident that if we needed to we could
find the staff um what often becomes a
challenge is the administration. Uh that
is really what we've seen um in our
experience um recently and then what we
see across the district across the state
is you know you have to have someone who
has demonstrated turning around a school
which is an F2C
um you know and so that would be part of
the requirements that there are
different things that we can do um if a
if a principal has experience as an
assistant principal that's gone through
a restart I mean there are things that
we can do but there are very very few of
those leaders that have demonstrated
that um so that it's not that we
couldn't staff, you know, for classified
educators. It really comes down to the
administration team, administrative
team, staffing wise.
>> Yeah. I think I I meant the entire
concern um to to be able to support
that. Okay.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. Trustees.
>> Trusty Hunter.
>> Yes. Um, one of the things you were
answering, you were kind of getting
there for parents. Uh, I had a parent
who was here earlier ask a question.
It's like, what does this look like in
the spring? Like what am I trying to
navigate? What am I what what am I
concerned? You know, my main concern is
for my kid, but what what am I concerned
about? So, we've kind of talked a little
bit about Enroll Austin, about the
supports that can be there. We talked
about maybe they can make that decision
if they already know, hey, I'm going to
be here that maybe that's going to come.
Y'all are going to try to work that out.
>> We could do it.
>> Pardon?
>> I think we could do we we could provide
more surgery.
>> I'm I I've done in Austin. I know. Good
luck with that, though. Um but I'm I'm
asking for parents in the spring. Um
what what can they be expecting from
their schools? I mean, we have all the
other things going on. Is there anything
with the taps
that that they need to connect with? And
I'm going to attach a question to that.
Um,
the taps are happening and from what we
hear from people, they they say my name
is on it, but I'm not in it. Right. And
so, as whatever the vote is tonight and
we proceed on the ones that we proceed
on, how can we better draw in people?
Because I mean, it'll be it'll be a done
thing, right? Yeah,
>> but it still has to be done.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. Um, so Trusty Hunter, one of the
things that we uh I've been very clear
about is um the implementation plan and
the ability for us to execute it is
critically important, right? Um so on
October 3rd when we submitted the
initial documents uh and then we've
since refined it uh on the 31st you know
we had our transition plan uh framework
we had our um bridge team and structure
kind of built out at the administration
level we identified staff here who are
going to lead and and ensure that the
transition plans are completed with
fidelity. I will tell you that over the
last six weeks, what's been hard in some
cases is when you have two two school
communities um that don't know for
certain if they're going to merge or
not.
>> Uh it's challenging because you don't
know who the new leader of that campus
is, who is really going to help
coordinate and lead the effort of
bringing the school communities
together. And then you also can't have
all communities just go because it may
not actually occur depending on what
happens with the vote. Um but all those
structures are in place. Um I've
identified staff internally to manage
it. Um the key performance indicators um
will be timeline driven. So you'll know
like we're going to have this many
meetings or this period of time. I'll
have that information. I can report to
the board. Uh so that's what it's going
to to look like. You're going to see
lots of planning early on in the fall in
the spring semester as the leaders get
set. Um there'll be um notifications and
hirings. So, so we're starting, this is
why it's so important, in December,
we're going to name the principles and
and just for kind of reminder, um, in
last year, we approved the taps June on
June 26, and so we were hiring
principles in the summer.
>> Yeah.
>> So, this is a a long a much longer um
>> kind of runway and planning period that
will only help us be successful um as we
launch. So, we have all of that in the
documents in the backup. Um, but those
will be executed with fidelity and it's
going to start with the naming of the
principles.
>> Okay. And with my final one minute 30
seconds, um, you know, I love AI and I
put my all of my 11 schools because we
have 11 in D1 going to go through this
tap process. It's like that's almost 40%
of my district, right? And it's the
heaviest. It's the the most eastern and
I I get all of the reasons why, right?
the most vulnerable populations.
there is not a lot of specificity and I
know we said we didn't want to put that
in there for the agency because it would
uh we would be locked into something and
uh just be one more but the communities
need that specificity like and I think
uh the caller that called in that was
like hey this is a great start what's
the plan right and so uh I think a great
opportunity for those that conversation
with taps and the people that are on the
tap committees and working with that
it's a great opportunity to really
>> build some bridges, do some healing, and
like everybody wants the same thing,
right? We really do all want the same
thing. We want a great education for our
kids, and we just are not getting there,
right? So, I appreciate that. Thank you.
>> Anyone else?
>> Give me an extra minute. No, they're
doing it over there.
>> Okay, first question. Um, is there going
to be an enrollment clinic at when as
well?
>> Um, so we started with the So, we're
going to put we're going to have
enrollment clinics at all the schools
that are going through disruptions and
we're starting with the ones that have
kind of the more complex
>> moves. Um, I wanted to kind of seed
these, commit to these, and then build
from that. So, yeah, we'll have more.
They'll be in December. We want to be
done with them at least the first round
before we go to winter break. Okay.
>> Um,
>> okay. I've got more questions. That's
good. That's good enough. Okay. Um, so
is there space at Riley for all of when
>> is there space at Riley for uh all of
>> in that one strand?
>> Uh, sorry.
>> Uh, not no not in this.
>> Okay.
>> Because we because it's wallto-wall now
and and we're going to a strand. Um now
one of the things that we talked about
through this process was I don't want to
talk say we'll go fast was that the
challenges with the with um when
monastery or a monastery program within
the state's accountability system and
the wallto-wall is one of the things
that kind of creates that challenge.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and so based on the feedback from the
trustees and the community we wanted to
keep the program because we understand
how
>> um uh how many how desirable it is but
also structure it to where it could be
successful.
>> Okay. That's awesome.
>> Um, so so we did a strand. So it's not
all, but we're it'll be at likely two
sections, but we'll see kind of what
comes in regarding who wants to
>> and at when we currently do Montasuroy
for prek, correct?
>> Yes.
>> Is that going to be the case at um Brley
as well having it start at prek?
>> So we when we did a strand, we assumed
it would be prek5, but I don't I mean
that's going to still go down to kind of
working and planning kind of later.
Really, I hope I I really hope that is
what happens because that's the draw.
It's the prek and getting the families
in at that early age. Um, okay. The
priority transfers,
>> um, how long will that last?
>> Yeah. So, the priority transfers for the
is is one year. It's a transition year
because once they're in, then they'll be
a a tracking transfer,
>> right? So, so if you're a let's say
you're a second grader and um you use
this the um one-year transfers to move
into another school, then after that we
would keep you in that school because
now you would have a tracking transfer.
>> Okay. Well, I'm thinking like okay, so
and then let's say like let's fast
forward like five years from now when
all the kids are like out of that
particular school.
Are there like does transferring even is
that even does that even apply? No,
because I mean it would be completely
different student population, different
Yeah, we we would kind of be fully moved
into kind of the plan as it
>> so the priority transfer situation is
only for this
>> transition period.
>> This period. Okay. Um and then I do have
a request uh well a question really. I
see a statement here that says the three
school it's on page three. the three
schoolwide dual language programs,
Becker, um, Richop, and Riley would
relocate and be introduced as, uh,
two-way dual language programs at
Sanchez Wooten. Okay. And I don't I
mean, we haven't committed to that,
though. Like, we've committed to the
part that the two-way dual language
part, but not the schoolwide part.
Well, I I think you know when we started
this process, we we had the schoolwides
um or district-wides. We they were all
zoned. So, we moved to unzoned and we
kind of renamed them districtwide
unzoned to yes kind of be responsive to
the fact that we want to have more
students access that that campus.
>> Um you know, if there's a change moving
forward, that opportunity exists for
that. um we can't go full uh unzone
districtwide because we're protecting
the students who are in that school now,
which means we have to preserve the tap.
>> Um so that's the direction we're going.
It's obviously not set because we have
to break the tap first.
>> Okay. Like I I feel a little like
hesitant about
even talking about a schoolwide dual
language program for for because it
would be for a neighborhood school then.
>> No. So it would like
would it be a neighborhood school or
would it be open?
>> Yeah. So, you'd have to get through the
transition period. We'd have to um you
know, obviously break the tap.
>> Uh and then at the future, you have the
ability, right, to transition into a
district-wide non-zone school. Um which
was kind of the original plan on the
October 3rd and October 31st plan.
>> Okay.
>> The TAP um made it and the feedback we
got from the community to keep the
students there kind of required No, I
get it. I get it. I get Okay. But I
think let me tell you what my concern
is. My concern is that this would create
a whole another set of changes a couple
years from now once the taps are over.
>> So So I I'm actually hesitant to be
talking about a possible eventual change
of the per like the program and the
>> Yeah, I think well I think that's why we
have the academic work in the spring
because I would expect that to come up
there,
>> right? because we're doing academic
vision, academic uh alignment in the
spring semester. We'll get all theories
of actions and set and then what the
board wants and what we envision long
term is what we'll do.
>> Okay,
>> that that that's why
>> you could say that about anything. So, I
mean, it's not a big deal, but I I just
want to be really careful and just say
like like I don't want to commit to
doing something for a couple years to
meet the needs of the TAB with this idea
that like, oh, maybe two, three years
from now once we get out of TAPS, we're
going to now go to these same campuses
and say, oh, we're going to change and
we're going to make it open to the whole
district and now it's going to be
schoolwide because we're going to be in
this situation again. You know what I'm
saying? So I think
>> in situation being that you have fewer
merger of bilingual
>> like we're just going to have to revisit
>> bunch of stuff
>> I I want to get our system in the habit
of revisiting things more frequently
boundary changes I mean once we make
>> not like two three years from now
>> well I mean
>> but anyway I I'll move on but I'm I'm
just saying like I I I wish that wasn't
in here but that's me personally like
because to me it's like well you could
say anything could be happening later.
Um but but part of the reason that I
noticed that even was because we're
calling in this plan um what's happening
at at Becker and Richtop a program move
um as though it's the same thing as
what's happening with Sunset Valley and
they're not. And so I think my request
would actually be before
um we vote on this I would like to just
call Richtop and I think it's Richtop
Becker and Riley.
No, I don't know. I know for sure Beck
Becker and Richtop call it a modified
program move because it's not really a
whole program move like Sunset Valley
is. And I think it just helps with the
clarity on what is actually happening
here. It is um you know Becker Becker
and and Richtop are a wallto-wall dual
language program. They're not moving
into a wall-to-all dual language
program. They're going to be
transferring into
um a two dual language program. So I
don't know how that works, but um I
don't know if anyone agrees with me, but
that's that is a concern. Um and then
and then um
did you get a chance to
Oh yeah,
the the question that I did get an email
about somebody who asked about the
transfer priority for a family that is
zoned to a school that now is
going to have a priority transferred to
another um campus. I we had talked about
it.
>> No, that's what we we think.
>> Is it already addressed?
>> We we addressed it. Yeah. So, what
you're referring to Yeah. So, if there's
a split, right? So, I'm going to use
Sunset Valley as example, right? You
have students that are zoned to
Cunningham and to Boone, right? And then
you have students that are transferred
into Sunset Valley.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, if you're a student that
resides in Cunningham and want to go to
Boone, you would be at the same priority
transfer level as the student who
transferred into the Sunset Valley and
now wants to go to Boone. So, it
protects, you know, it it gives students
options who are in the previously
existing Sunset Valley to go to either
school that is now um the new attendance
boundaries or a transfer. And so, when
Victoria was talking about it,
>> she would in the in the presentation in
the slides, it says it and then it says
vice versa because it it goes both ways.
So to whoever there was one email where
one person said that and I appreciate
that you actually listen you did what
you say you do which is you read read it
and you incorporated it. Um do I still
have time? No I don't. Okay. Thank you.
That's it.
>> And hopefully we could just do like
round one and then if there are more
questions do round.
>> Yes certainly.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Who has not spoken in round one?
Who would like to speak? Trusty Foster.
>> I have uh five things to start. So, I'd
appreciate if someone just wrote them
down cuz I'm just going to run through
them. Um, one, uh, I would really love
to see from our sort of day one after
whatever happens tonight, some clarity
and commitment on our communication
plans. So day one, which administrators
are going to be at our most impacted
campuses speaking with and working with
uh community members? And then right off
of that, what is their role in the
system? Are they a messenger? Are they a
decision maker? One of our sources of
confusion, you know, from observation
and feedback from community members is
they felt like this person was telling
them something and then they met with
somebody else or another community met
with somebody else and the message was
getting confused and it was leading to
reasonably distrust. So, who is going to
be and this this isn't really even like
a question. This is like I certainly
hope that on day one we have a plan to
visit all of our campuses with our top
level administrators and there's clarity
in what their role is so that you know
community is clear.
Secondly, I love the enrollment clinics,
but and between now and uh say spring
breakish, March, Marchish,
what is our plan for onetoone enrollment
support for our different communities?
Here's a registar, here's an attendance
person, but here are these volunteers,
etc. what is our oneto-one plan for all
of our communities who are going to be
massively confused by what's going on.
Um I would even in the context of our
budget restraints um we need some
community partners right now. Uh we have
some folks who know these sections of
town who are really good at bringing the
folks in, reaching the folks where they
are. they know where folk are eating on
Sunday afternoons, etc. So,
if that's a possibility, um everything
we have to do to communicate with sort
of integrity and clarity with our
communities for enrollment support. Um,
third, as we do whatever we do tonight,
that family voice,
uh, we
our erosion of trust is profound enough
that it ain't going to work with
decision like even taking the feedback
and then considering in the room and
then coming back
where we lost on this. I think as part
of where we lost is that I I believe
there was listening because in the past
it would be just we just do two and
that's it. Then a little bit later than
that we listened to but we didn't
respond. The administration made
refinements refinements. refinements,
but there was a bandwidth gap that once
you refined or once we refined, there
wasn't dialogue in between dropping
something on folks. And so there's no
context. It looks crazy. Even if there's
all the good thinking in the world,
folks got to be at the table walking
through it, talking through it. So going
forward, where is the insertion of
family voice at the table? Because
rich top folk, you know, all my friends,
all my neighbors, you know, it might
even be awkward. They see me on my bike,
they're like, "Oh, they're that guy."
Because I've been saying a certain thing
and I haven't even been able to keep up
with what the heck's going on. And even
as I believe in the administration. So
it's not enough for even me to be in the
room. There needs to be
if if ridgetop families are going to go
to pickle, they better be in the room
understanding what's happening even in
the context of taps and all that other
stuff. So where is family voice? Is it
the CAC? Is it this? Is it that? Is it a
new mechanism? Um
next, the next two are related really
quickly and and I would love substantive
responses to these later in my last 30
seconds or whatever it is.
um continuation of consolidation.
If we stop a plan and we just forget
that we don't drop three things off,
then we have no integrity in this. We
started something with a theory of
action that said it should look like
this. Then we pulled back and said,
"Well, we need more time. we better
deliver and we better continue and have
that be transparent and apparent to
people that this process is continuing.
So where is the plan for continuation of
consolidation and when do we hear that?
When do we hear that plan? I think I
heard December which is a start.
>> December 18th,
>> just a start. Um then right off of that
by making this pull we don't create
another problem for ourselves in that
folks are like well I'm supposed to go
to Maplewood next year and you just said
Maplewood might not uh what am I
supposed to do? So we have another layer
of confusion and uncertainty for our
parents. Um, I don't even I I don't know
how to respond to that because I think
that is a very valid concern. So, those
are my five pieces. Um, I don't know if
you want to speak to it now or later,
but I desperately need to hear something
that I can amplify to my community
because they deserve it.
>> Yeah. So, um, so day one commitment to,
uh, community to, um, engaging with
community and administrators. So uh we
have teams that are set up um you know
executive directors play a significant
role in that coupled with our licensed
mental health professionals to ensure
providing the support. Um the one thing
I'm also going to say is that uh each of
these uh transition plans um is going to
be kind of led by the um group of
leaders who are uh going to be the
administrative leads of the campus.
Right? Right. So, so one of the things
that that is is challenging is if you're
bringing two school community
communities together, someone in tied to
the school needs to be leading the work.
That's what makes it most allows us to
be most successful. Which is why naming
the leaders and the principles early is
helpful because now we'll have the
administrator, we'll have the license
health professional, and we'll have the
structure, but most importantly, we'll
have the head of the new school working
between both communities with enough
time to get it done. Um, and so that's
how it's going to be structured. As far
as um onetoone enrollment, you're going
to see me shift pretty significantly. I
mean, I I'm not not not that I have a
lot of time, but or or or really much of
anything, but I'm going to be
hyperfocused on enrollment. uh not only
in kind of the improvements we can make
with our famil family's experience um
not only in the platform but just our
support of families as they navigate uh
and and we can get to a place where we
have onetoone which may not be necessary
everywhere but the ability to get there
in in certain communities we should be
able to do where there's lean on
partners or otherwise I think on top of
that we also have to be very intentional
about finding those students who um are
not choosing Austin ISD but have really
really strong options available to them
like we need to be hidden that hard. Uh
family voice regarding the process I
kind of touched on that we have a bridge
team who's being uh the structure of
that's being led by Staca U Pascal who
um I think many of us know. Uh so she is
going to be the person who kind of you
know is is ensuring that all the voice
kind of comes together between the
school communities but as a director
report to the chief of staff so that we
have an expectation that it's getting
done. So she she's the person who's
going to help ensure that all the people
are in the room. The action of of is
going to be done primarily by the
executive director, the principal and
the support from Dr. Lewis's team. Uh so
that's how that's going to work. Um
regarding uh balance enrollment
consolidations and boundary changes that
that that's why I put it in here as as
when we're going to come back and talk
about it because I need to understand,
you know, where each trustee is. I think
I have a good understanding, but we
haven't talked about it. Um, as I said
before, I'm committed to doing the work.
Um, it's something that that has to get
done. I think boundary changes, reducing
number of seats, but most importantly,
feeder pattern alignment is something
that has to get done. It just has to get
done. Uh, I think the sooner that we're
able to do it, um, the better off we're
going to be long term. Um, but again,
I'm bringing it back on the 18th because
it'll give me the time to meet with each
trustee and and kind of bring up a plan
I think will be supported. I think I got
through the five. Um,
>> we say to
the one years
>> Oh. Um, as far as like Maplewood and
Campbell um or or Bracker Woods or Palm,
right? Is that what you're referring to?
Well, because an action isn't taking
place be right now or before December 26
27 will they're going to operate the way
that they had operated this year. Um,
and that's what I've, you know, it
depends on how today's vote goes, but
that's what I would expect to occur and
have no problem communicating that. Um,
and so as we move through the process in
the spring, um, regarding economic
vision and the work we do around
boundaries, consolidations, then it'll
kind of come back up. Uh, we'll have a
conversation at that point. But for all
intents and purposes, 26 27 is going to
be a year like we had this last year for
for 25 26.
So, and the good news will be that if we
do go in that direction, there will be
fewer schools that where we're thinking
about this and we will have had a whole
lot of learnings.
>> Yeah.
>> To to to help us through and help us
with the communication with families and
inviting them in and all that stuff.
>> I would also say the um well, the
boundary changes are are a huge lift um
themselves, right? I mean, when you
think about the number of comments, we
didn't put statistics on here, but I
want to say 80% of the comments are
around boundary changes. Uh, you know,
you had goals, trustee, laid out for us,
Trusty Foster, about having no more than
one split or two schools be receiving
any one school. We got really close. Um,
but you know, you don't have it, lots of
comments, lots of conversations have to
take place with that community to get it
right. Um, so, so a lot of energy is
going to be spent there as well. And I
think we learned through this process,
you know, ways to to maybe do that
better moving forward.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. Who's next?
Okay, I have some questions. Um Josh,
would it be possible to put up the um
projected student movement and fiscal
impact slide from the appendix
um the financial appendix? If not, I I
would just love to um get some clarity
um
on the calculation about
what we're going to see if we have
attrition. just so we have some some
clarity and and accuracy with our
community. Um on November 10th when we
met there was a projected student
movement and fiscal impact slide and
it's I it's in a link in one of the
documents um in today's presentation and
today's attachment
um modeled 470 students as a high from
as 10% of the reassigned students as the
potential loss but the multiplier was um
the baseotment 6215 it wasn't the wada
it wasn't the actual per student
funding. And uh that gave us a number of
$2.72 million lost from the district of
470 students leave. I think it's really
almost twice that um at least about you
know significantly higher than that
maybe not quite twice. And I would just
love to make sure we're looking at the
most accurate number for that. Um so
what is our water? Do we know right now
what our weighted average daily
attendance number figure is?
>> It's over 10. I'd have to go back to
>> it was yeah I mean it was over 10 when I
calculated a million
>> you want to define what that is
>> for 72 weighted average daily attendance
yes
>> how it's calculated
>> how it's calculated in a very
complicated way average daily attendance
is takes the basic a lotment has
multipliers that go with it and then uh
also factors in attendance and so it's a
a complicated number to get to but it's
really the accurate per student funding
number with a few other things and our
our total per student funding number is
more than $10,000 a student. And so
multiplying by 6125 rather than 10 plus
really underestimates the fiscal impact
of of any students we may lose as part
of this. And I just want to be sure uh
we're factoring in accurate numbers.
That's a a question our community has
had over and over and over. So um if
someone while we're here could come up
with a better calculation so we can talk
about that in a minute before we vote
that would be helpful. Um,
>> well, we're just I mean I I don't
disagree that weighted average daily
attendance is a um a better uh
multiplier to use. Um if that's what
you're saying we can I mean is that
>> Yeah. I I would just love to instead of
saying if we lose 470 it's 2.27 million.
I'd love to have a more accurate number.
>> Yeah. And and just to be clear not every
student has the same waiting. So we're
using an average. So there are students
who
>> we get compensated from the state more
because the needs are greater.
Absolutely.
>> And so we didn't break that down by each
school type or student in each of these
schools. So
>> um
>> yeah, I'm looking for a gross, you know,
number and I won't I'm not going to
quibble with the guess about how many
may or may not leave. I just want to
understand,
>> you know, for every 10 who leave it
could be this much. However, we want to
talk about it. I just want to talk about
it with the numbers that match up. Thank
you for that. Um, and uh, I'd love to
know what we get for a dual language
student on top of that as we're talking
about who we might lose. That would be
helpful as well. Um, and really
appreciate Trusty Willie to your point
about enrollment and understanding um,
getting information to families quickly.
We know that charters recruit this time
of year. We know that private schools
recruit this time of year. and that
anyone who's going to choose that has to
put a deposit down quickly has to make a
commitment to that charter school. If we
don't act, you know, for a family who
needs a school for their child, that's
what your work depends on. It's what
your child's, you know, kind of
education depends on. March is like
musical chairs and no one's going to
wait for us if we wait. We have to have
to get that done. And I really
appreciate prioritizing that um for our
program changes and anywhere else that
is going to happen. Um and I appreciate
that you're prioritizing staff and
trying to get information to staff
quickly as well because that impacts
their lives as well. So thank you for
that and and really deeply grateful to
hear that recruitment information. Um
you know we can get our budget in
balance by cutting and we can get our
budget in balance by bringing people
back. Uh and I know which one I prefer.
I think I know which one our community
prefers and we do have a lot to offer
families. Um, and we can do a much
better job and I know there are many,
many people in our community who are
ready to volunteer and ready to go out
with us and help us do that. Uh, so I
really want to be sure we're being
thoughtful about that and um, I will ask
the rest of my questions um, next round.
Thank you.
>> Okay, who else?
>> Still round one. Yeah. Are we still
round one? We good? Okay. Round two.
>> Trusty Coffman.
>> So, I just want to go back to the um
schoolwide dual language programs. Um
so, will every student currently
enrolled in dual language, whether
emergent bilingual or not, have a dual
language space available to them in
Austin ISD?
That has been our commitment from the
beginning when we started this process
was we were looking at the total number
of seats of participants at the four
schools emergent bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual.
>> So are we maintaining the commitment
that's in chapter 89 to provide a
continuous enrollment in the program?
>> The continuation. Yeah. The continuity.
Um,
has the administration examined and
considered every proposal that would
allow for a dual language program in
7874 that would hold every current
Becker student while approaching a
balance of 50% emergent bilingual
students?
>> So, we have there were several elements
to proposals that came through including
um having five schoolwide schools
looking at Sanchez and um Becker Dawson.
So, we looked at a a variety and modeled
it with program enrollment at several
schools and within a four mile radius as
well.
>> Thank you. And um $311 per student for
non-emergent angle in a dual language
program. Um and I said at the start of
this process that I would not vote for
closures without evidence of budget
savings from previous closures. I have
been convinced that there were
legitimate reasons that the budgetary
impact of 2019 closures couldn't be
calculated due to COVID and other you
know leadership changes and other and
everything else. Um I have been somewhat
persuaded that the projected savings and
reinvestments from this proposal are
likely. Um but I want to amplify the
message of the caller at the beginning
of this evening who insisted that the
administration track and report on the
budgetary impact of any closures. Um, if
we close any schools tonight, we owe
that to the next generation who faces
potential closures to have good
evidence, good data to support any
decisions that are made in the future.
Just want to amplify that voice.
>> Um, no, I think that's a great
suggestion. Um, and and we're happy to
do it. Uh, I want to I want to be really
clear that a a reduction in in cost
doesn't equal a reduction in your
budget.
So because I I think that
>> when I say budgetary impacts I I mean
investments and savings.
>> So you so I guess I can track the
reductions in cost. Um but we as a
school district, the board, you know,
could make decisions to increase your
overall budget.
>> Yes.
>> So I just want to be really clear.
They're two separate things
>> because it's complicated. But I I have
no problem tracking the reduction in
cost associated with these um these
recommendations,
>> right?
>> And invest and additional costs that it
created,
>> right? So just
>> that part, not necessarily like where
the what we did with that money that was
saved, not necessarily how all the other
factors changed, but just to the best of
our ability.
>> Yeah. to track what was the budgetary
impact of these decisions to the extent
that they were made for budgetary
reasons.
>> Would you? Okay. So, I have no problem
doing that and I'm happy to do it. I
want to be really clear like so we are
going to spend money on the taps
regardless if we close these. So, just
to you know so as I track
>> there are some closures that are tied to
to turnaround plans.
>> Right. That is that is
>> okay. Just be really clear because I
don't want to be five years from now and
I'm like Matas like you didn't write do
this right. I want to make sure I
capture the comment and I I respond and
provide the detail.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but yeah, I have no we can do that
for sure.
>> Yeah. Thank you.
>> Just a point of clarification on what
David was saying. Um I just want to I
want to be super super clear. I can only
speak for me. Ashley, see I said I is
not a suggestion. It needs to be done.
It has to be done. It has to be done.
I'm not I like again I was holding on
for 2019, but I didn't I told you I want
y'all spending any more time on that. we
got to move forward. So, whatever we're
doing and we I understand we need to
make sure that our community understands
and like David says, I'm not looking for
a line item, but that money is being
saved. It's not being saved to put in
the bank. It's being saved and coming
back into the system because it's money
we already don't have. So, but we people
need to know like I did this. This is
what I got. Right. Thank you.
>> And I would add to that um trying to get
a meaningful estimate on attrition. I
know it won't be perfect. We won't be
perfectly able to do it, but um trying
to get a meaningful estimate on on
decline any declines in enrollment um
that come next year that we think may be
higher than what we expected
>> tied to these specific changes.
Uh I mean I think certainly tied to
schools that are closing certainly. Um
but we don't know that there may not be
others in the system. I'd like to just
have an understanding of what we
expected and what we get. It's it will
be imperfect but I think we need to try
to understand.
>> I just want to interject there. One of
our retention strategies several years
ago was to expect every single school to
call every kid who doesn't reenroll in
the school to find out why. An exit
interview to figure out did you move?
Did you choose to leave our district for
a reason? where did you go?
>> So I think that would be easy data to
collect if we have a an ambitious
retention student retention not
retention student family it's not
retention like you're failing a grade
yes but if we have a aggressive strategy
for that I think that that data would be
easy to gather.
>> I appreciate that and I know that a few
years ago we did that and uh trustees
were invited to volunteer to help. I
will be happy to help make some of those
phone calls. Thank you.
um
the
modeling yes for that but that is not
the only pressure right so and again I
don't want to use administrative time I
feel like this is a thing like if we had
an office that office could do that
right so the modeling needs to include
the fact that now anybody can be an
online school. Like you can be a student
in Austin and go to school in Chicago,
right? And graduate from high school
because that's now been okayed. February
the vouchers come out. Like what's
what's our what do we estimate that that
might draw, right? Um
Arthy was talking about, you know, like
a charter is closing. I was like, "Yeah,
but they're not going to go to public
school. They just going to go to another
kid."
Um so we can't count that. And I know I
don't think we've done a good job
explaining about demographics. Yes,
there's a new 600 apartment complex
going up of studios.
That does nothing for us. And so just
because something is going up and it's
tall and it's big, that doesn't count
for us. So that modeling again, I don't
want it to be too big, but like worst
case scenario,
what could happen? Just so and what if
it never happens? But just to be able to
know and I think our experts who um have
already spoken to the district have
mentioned those things that I've just
mentioned um I didn't come up with all
that but those experts are saying like
this stuff is happening you should be
thinking about it and I know we have a
lot of other things to think about but I
think that's um that's important.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Trusty Hunter I appreciate
that and Trusty Kaufman and I I
appreciate uh your comment as well. Um,
I I always want to develop thoughtful
models, but I want to make sure our
assumptions are founded and can be kind
of backed up. Um, going through lots of
different changes in Austin ISD since
I've been here, there are things that
that you see in here and then there are
the way things play out. Um, and so when
we look at assumptions on attrition or,
you know, I I have no problem, you know,
tracking and estimating what I think may
occur. Uh, and even as trustee or
president Boswell said, you know, making
phone calls and if a family leaves,
which I hope they don't, we understand
why they left. We have a we do better at
secondary when it comes to asking those
questions. We don't do a good job in
elementary. The counter um thought is,
you know, we do know that there are
schools that are going to increase
because of some of the changes, you
know, that there are students who had
not been accessing AISD who are likely
to come back. One example I would argue
is probably Martin Tequiling. Um, and
so, you know, I'm not going to estimate
that. You know, I I know right now that
there are families like asking about it
and wanting to come back into the system
because of that connection now. But to,
you know, I'm not going to go and make
an assumption. Uh, so I I just almost
whatever we do it it is going to it's
going to feel like it's not accurate
because the assumptions are all over and
there's other pressures. But I will do
my best to model these specific changes.
model other changes in this overall plan
and then kind of track, you know, other
pressures, immigration and vouchers and
and we've done that, but again, it can
be challenging.
>> Understood.
>> Okay. Questions from anyone else.
>> So,
I guess I'm trying to think the context
for this. Um, you know, when we first
started discussing this, you know, end
of last semester going into the summer
and talking about this plan and, you
know, there was discussion about a
stable state and then an ideal state and
kind of what we would want the final
product, final product to look like. And
certainly when it was a complete
comprehensive plan, even in that plan,
there was still work to be done after
that part, right, to get us fully across
a finish line where, you know, the
district was um kind of insulated
against some of the uncertainties going
on. And you know, I understand some of
the changes that have happened that and
I understand some of the limitations in
the communication um that we're able to
provide over some of the changes. The
concern I have um that I'm gonna segue
into a question with is the confusion
was already there I think in the
community in the early conversations
about how much actually needed to get
done that even this comprehensive plan
was just the start of what we really
needed to have for like a 10 to 20 year
plan to get the district you know in a a
really good spot. And so the the
question I'm posing is with these
changes and you know you you're already
saying in January, you know, December
even we're talking about the next part
of the conversation. Um you know, kind
of two parts. One is the landscape's
going to continue to change. So one of
the things that I think was really a
strength uh that I'm warning at this
point in the original plan was that we
got a lot done at once, which was
ambitious. Um, but also the advantage
was that we got a we covered a lot of
ground in one move and now we're going
to cover less ground in this move that
we're doing and we're offsetting some
things. And so, um, surely a difficult
question. So, I'm not holding you to a
hard, you know, defined percentage, but
how much more do we still need to do?
Like, we've delayed part of the boundary
work. You know, we've delayed a lot of
moves. there's there's, you know, three
consolidations that we're pausing. Um,
you know, one of my concerns is that
with further budgetary issues um that
we'll come back with potentially more
than three consolidations that we have
to look at. Um, you know, which was part
of the I think initial conversation on
on what percentage we were really going
to look at for um um facility usage and
seats. And so I know this is a a really
difficult question, but I I think for
the community's understanding, you know,
how how far is this actually pulling us
um you know, I know it's got some budget
issues, it's really reduced on some of
the pro programmatic alignment and the,
you know, boundary changes, those
pieces. So um just so that there's not
misunderstanding on it about how much
work still has to be done after this
vote.
So, I would say that this is a um a
meaningful step for sure. I I don't want
to diminish kind of the the work that's
been done. Uh I think the board, the
community, the staff um understands the
the direess of of where we are as an
organization and that we have to evolve.
We have to change. We just do. Um the
accountability risk, the budget risk,
the you know, TA greed order and special
education risk. I mean, the list goes on
and on and on. And we've navigated them
together over the last two and a half
years by making hard decisions and
implementing with fidelity. Like
implementation is I I think more of a
strength now in the district than it has
been in the past. Um that being said, uh
you know, there will be more. it's hard
to um communicate what that is because
it comes at a price, you know, and and I
think that's we're at a point where
we're kind of at the edge of of a a
fragmentation of of the system as a
whole, right? So, a lot of what I think
about and and the work that we take on,
it's about moving us forward, but making
sure we're moving together. And you
know, if you if you push too hard, then
um you don't all get there together. And
and I understand that it feels like that
already. So even more would would make
it harder to get there together. So it's
this constant balance of um improving,
refining, reducing costs. I mean, this
year we've done a really good job
already this year of reducing our costs.
You know, we had some cash flow
challenges, but overall expenses have
gone down. And so, you know, you're
seeing us kind of make that that turn,
which we did last year, and continue to
drive down our cost. Uh, and so I would
say that it's going to come back in some
form. I think the other thing that's
going to come back are what other
things, knowing how hard this is, need
to be back on the table. That's the
question. You know, there are things
that we took off the table in 24 23 24
25. Uh, and the question to the trustees
after we have one-on- ones and we can
get back to December is should any of
those come back on the table before you
have the next conversation or not,
right? Because because we we did byp say
bypass, we elected and decided not to do
certain things. Um, so it's been a
meaningful step. Um, even when it comes
to repurposing of properties, I mean, we
talked about, you know, months ago, you
know, Rosedell and we talked about, uh,
Brook and those have been challenging.
Like, nothing is simple and everything
takes time, you know, everything takes
time and so we have to be really
thoughtful. We have to be really
intentional, but this is a meaningful
step. I I don't want to diminish that
this is a a a good step in the right
direction. Um, but there'll have to be
other steps. Um, but that's going to
require conversations with this this
body here. Um and then you know going
forward together.
>> I'm straining to think if there's a
better way for me to um ask the same
question because I I understand
>> I think you want me to ask like how many
more consolidations is that what I I'm
trying to figure out like how to respond
in a way that gives you the precision
>> suggest something. So like I mean we're
we're I think 7,000 seats are being
addressed with this plan.
>> A little less than 7,000. What's the
number of empty seats we have in the
district?
>> Yeah. So, the number of empty seats um
is a little over 20,000. Um and I want
to be like really clear before we
started this process, we adjusted our
capacities to um to align with how we
operate, right? So, where schools have
designated classrooms that are 10 to1
ratio because we have to make sure that
we have certain spaces in our schools
that can support our students who
receive specialation services. So, it
was actually higher. So, we brought it
down and then we went through a process
of creating healthy utilizations for
each of our schools between 85 and 95%.
Which allows you to kind of be in the
space where if you grow and a
development occurs, you don't have to go
get a whole bunch of portables. You can
flex bigger, but you're also not so
small that you don't get the staffing
allocations that you need to be
successful. So, 85 to 95 was kind of the
the goal of the work. Um, so we're
taking off a meaningful number uh less
than 7,000. I think there's still, you
know, more that needs that we need to
get to over time, but that's that's kind
of the gap that we have to cover. But
you don't have to get the full 20,000 or
full 22,000 because that would be 100%
versus 95,
>> right?
>> So
>> So, but we're about a third of the way
through like in terms of
>> um I would say more than a third. Yeah.
I mean, you again, it's a meaningful
I want to be really honest. It's a
meaningful step and I would say that the
the seats that we're that that we're
able to address in this round um are
some of our more expensive costs per
seat, right? And and and that's just a
function of a mature school system.
We're 144 years old. There's there's
there's a lot that's occurred. Um
uh and so I think as we continue to pull
off portables, as we continue to to do
this work, um it is a big it is a big
chunk. I want to you know it's it's it
wasn't quite where we wanted to get, but
there's reasons why that didn't occur in
this round. Um but it is a meaningful
step.
>> Okay. And trusty Boswell, I there like
parents here with four-year-olds that
they need to know if their school is
going to be open.
>> Um they're going to be there at 7:30.
There's teachers that are going to
probably be at work at 5:00 a.m. Are
>> we okay with moving?
>> Have we asked and answered what we feel
like we want to ask and answer?
>> What do you think,
>> Trusty Foster?
>> Uh, I I'll just say that I I do have
some uh granular questions
about um Wooten and distribution of
programming in Wooten in the new
building. Um and the same uh granular
questions around um the distribution of
folks to uh well, how do you say the
folks who were at at Becker and what
their opportunities are because we've
had our conversation tonight and I'm
still getting text messages from people
who simply are seeking clarity. So,
we're not there yet in a couple of
areas. I actually probably don't think
we can get there tonight. Um,
and we desperately need to figure out
how we're going to get this information
because these are really dialed in folks
who
still aren't seeing the math, you know,
the math math as they say. So, um,
yeah, I don't know. And so, maybe my
question is what's what's our strategy
to provide some additional clarity like
immediately on some of these granular
issues?
>> Yeah. So is it staffing or is it
utilization? Is it student movement?
>> Uh because I can do
>> at Becker it's student movement and at
Wooten it's distribution of um so
Mandarin Chinese comes in. We've all
we've got Spanish to English. Um and
then we've also uh have affirmatively
made accommodations which I'm I applaud
to bring all the current Wooten
community in. So some people are
referring to that as like three
programs. Um so I think we just
>> and there are schools that operate I
mean Joson operates like that right now.
Um so I I think on the Wooten
conversation, Trusty Foster, I'm not
going to be able to give you that
answer. Um because you're you're talking
about space allocation based on program
when we don't even know the number of
students that are actually going to
select the program that they want, which
is going to be what drives staffing
because we staff based on language. So
we we we have the space. It is a it is
it is a new facility. We will have the
ability to support um based on number of
students and we feel very confident
about that. What you're asking for is is
going to be really hard to derive until
we understand how many students are
going to select Mandarin. You know I
that is a question that we would need to
understand. Um and and that's really in
the weeds. I can maybe work with you or
I can work with uh the community that's
providing you those questions and and
tell you the sequence that we will take
to get there. But that's why I can't
give you that answer.
>> I and I I do think that's reasonable.
And I do also think they're the
questions coming in um are reasonable.
And isn't there some good news about
early January and Wooten that we kind of
should lift up and is a space of
opportunity?
talking about the the um groundbreaking
the the ribbon cutting the
groundbreaking ribbon
>> cutting things are moving in right
>> yeah I I think it's there's been a I
mean hair there's in the midst of all
this we've actually been constructing
and modernizing and and uh implementing
the 2022 bond program so there is a lot
that's coming online um in the near
future the first set of schools will
deliver uh here kind of mid year uh
which is really incredible Um it's
actually it's something that's kind of
gotten lost in a lot of this. Um but
yes, I that is there are great things
coming.
>> So instead of losing it, let's leverage
it and really be there for that moment,
but also see that as a moment to
communicate.
>> Yeah. And then on the on the staffing
numbers, uh it sounds like what needs to
happen is just like go and show like all
the math, um identify the enrollment,
like all the all of it. uh because we
see it, we've done it a couple different
times, but I can understand just kind of
the different options that are
available. Can it's not always clear.
For sure.
>> Cool. And I apologize for being really
prescriptive because I was like I forgot
my LSG training like all of the sudden.
Um but this is super important stuff and
and I do look forward to following up.
>> Thank you. I just have a couple of
really quick things. Um, one I think
really acknowledging that the situation
at Becker, if we do vote to close
Becker, is very different from what it
is at Richtop is very different from
what it is at Riley. Um, and and I
really support Trusty Singh's point to
name what we're doing. Um, what we're
doing is not what was originally
proposed. The genesis was trying to
bring more diversity into our
wall-to-wall programs and trying to find
that balance. um at a moment when we
heard some speakers talk about how we're
moving away from diversity as a
community in so many ways and I think
naming it accurately
um whatever we want to call it when we
vote I I welcome my colleagues to come
up with ideas to name it really just
something more truthful if that's what
we're going to do not that it was not
meant to be untruthful but something
that's more accurate um also really want
to ask if um there is a way to guarantee
Becker families a spot at either Sanchez
ODM or um a few people have proposed
adding two-way classrooms at Galindo and
and if there is a way to guarantee one
of those three um to every Becker family
who would like that
>> I think there's a way um certainly I I
need to confer with Avette um we've
looked at that uh as actually and and
and just to I know Avette said this but
you know when we got the ideas from
community we spent I mean, vet spent
like weekends like going through it and
producing the documents. So, we have a
good understanding of of what's
possible. Um, and and I think that's
something we could certainly get really
close to committee. I just want to talk
to her.
>> Well, my hope would be that maybe even
more than that you could work with just
directly with the families to find
things that work um the best if that's
where this goes.
>> Well, we're definitely committed to
doing that. I just want to the
guaranteeing of the three. I I I'd like
to be able to do that, but I just need
to be able to talk to team if I can
guarantee the three versus committing to
ensuring that our Becker families get
the most available options that meet
their needs
>> and as many people together as they can
because we can't have they don't have
the opportunity to be get together.
>> Yeah.
>> Like the other schools do. And that is
um a it's a real loss. People are
mourning for a reason. People are
unhappy for a reason. um and and closing
a thriving program and splitting a
community when that was really something
we tried very hard not to do. I think
just we need to be cognizant of that.
Thank you. Um other thing is um for
international is that um reversible? If
our policies that keep international
children out of our country become
reversible and we end up with that need
again, do we believe we could restore
that program?
>> Yeah, I mean we
>> in a meaningful way is it if we break
it, can we bring it back?
>> We we any campus that's in good
standing, any program you want to
introduce, we we can do. That's not we
we could bring it back. Uh certainly um
it may look different um but we can
definitely bring it back.
>> Okay. Thank you.
Uh, anything else? Trusty Hunter.
>> Um, you mentioned about when and uh, no,
the whole school can't go. Um, I think
that makes what, uh, Trusty Whitley Chu
asked for even more important because
not everybody will choose
>> to go across tonight, right? They'll
like, oh, no, Pan Springs right here.
We're good. We can walk to Pan Springs
or, you know, Andrews is actually closer
to my mom and the kids are going to go
there after school. So because if my
concern is that I'm going to make up a
number 200 seats right and then 300
people want to go is there I know we
moving away from portables and all this
sort of kind of thing but is there a way
we can accommodate that because the
point is we just trying to break the tap
right and win understands that their
hope well I won't say their hope because
I can't speak for everybody the people
that I have talked to their hope is to
do this break the tap build this
beautiful wonderful program that's so
big It has to have its own building.
Yeah.
>> Right. And so that eventual future move
is not something to the people that I've
spoken to a bad thing. Right. That's
what they want.
>> Yeah. And so when I was talking to the
team about this um you know we we can
handle um the
uh most extreme scenario in which
everybody goes and everybody stays.
meaning all the all the assigned stay
and all the when families go. Um that it
we would be overenrolled um but not to a
degree that is not manageable if that
makes any sense. Uh you know we have
staff right now that use spaces at at uh
Riley. You know it is it functions in a
different way. Um you know given that it
has three languages now. Uh and so there
is space. It would be tight if everybody
picked it. Um, but yes, we we can
provide that. And I think to to your
point about Trusty Willie Chu, I want to
find a way to provide certainty early.
>> If if if we and to me like if they can
commit, we can commit. You know, I would
have to do it on the back end, but maybe
it's a letter or some confirmation that
you will have a seat protected. Um, but
we'd need to know like it would need to
be a full commitment versus, you know,
we think we want to go because we're
going to begin a plan.
>> Uh, but if they if that's what we need
to do, then we can certainly do that.
and setting out that education for
parents to understand that we know your
life is different, but as soon as you
make that decision because there be a
teacher attached to a certain number of
kids and so if we think there's only
going to be this many then we're going
to hire this many teachers and then 20
more say we want to go now we've got a
class with no teacher. That's what we're
trying to avoid. So
>> it's an it's another ask. It's another
ask.
>> Yeah. So what we can do how about we do
this we let's we'll automatically commit
to the fifth the fifth meeting um be win
monastery. um just go ahead and do that
so that we we get out there. Um we'll
work with the team to get it scheduled.
Uh maybe there's an availability between
the 9th or the 10th and the following
week when we're doing the next two set
of schools, but we can commit to get
that one done in that same kind of range
of times and not move it to another
group of schools.
>> Uh and then I'll work with the team to
figure out what we can do to confirm
seats early. uh even if it means you're
not going to get a little like note from
Enroll Austin, but you will get a
confirmation from superintendent. I
mean, we will figure it out like we will
do the back end.
>> I think that that that and and Riley so
generous with their their space,
inviting people in to do that. We really
appreciate that. And then uh last bit
because we'd already worked with Pickle
and we got that and we worked with GT
and Bington, we got that. The Oak
Springs uh those conversations have to
have to continue. like that's day one
tomorrow. Like so let's start planning
and talking again being so generous and
welcoming and we really want to make
sure that we um show appreciation and
and not have situations like we already
have where people think something happen
doesn't.
>> Yeah. Yeah, Trusty Hunter. Um, what I
really appreciated, again, this is one
of those things that came out from
community, right, where we were going
through a process and after October
31st, we had a conversation at the
Greater Calvary Church and there was
information shared with us that, hey,
maybe this different option could work.
And so, we committed uh after we met
with Oak Springs Community uh to meet
with Black Shear to have different
community meetings and and that
conversation has to continue. It's not
part of this plan. Uh I I've talked to
different leaders in the community and
we want to progress it to have those
conversations and then the community
will decide together and and we'll bring
it back if we need to.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you. All right, Trusty Singh,
don't be sorry.
>> Okay. Um I'm sorry for people with small
babies. Um so quick question. you and I
had talked about um a a con um a
suggestion that someone brought and it
sounded like maybe it could happen but
maybe it could happen administratively
but that was for that neighborhood north
of when to instead of going to
>> neighborhood okay like could we made
that go to the closer school I can't
remember if it was
>> was it is that what you had just is that
what you
>> yeah so you can bring up the map it's
it's the piece by itself that's on the
northwest side of the attendance
boundary Yes.
>> And so what was the conclusion of that?
>> Yeah. So so that could be done via a
reassign an assignment a reassignment.
Um right now the way that we have it
balanced out is because um is the school
that they would go to it wouldn't be
pickle would it?
>> I'm sorry. Can you bring up the
>> You want to bring up
>> Yeah, it should zone to pickle. Yeah.
Having it zone to pickle.
>> Oh, he took the he took the computer.
And then and then Trusty Boswell, we
have this agenda item comes up again if
any or it's can be discussed at agenda
item 14. Um,
>> it can't be.
>> So,
>> all right. I I can answer it when I get
to there if you want. I got to pull it
up just because So, we can we can handle
it via reassign
>> communications. Can we pull up the map?
>> Would that would that have to be part of
this vote is basically my question.
>> It doesn't have
>> it could just be done administratively.
>> It can be done administratively because
we're using the assignment tool. Um, now
if that's what we decide to do when we
come back and do boundaries, I'd want to
codify it in the boundaries for all
those are for that entire area, right?
That's how we would do it.
>> Thank you.
>> But I think we need to probably have
multiple conversations with that
community before I actually do it
because I've only that's I've only heard
it one time.
>> Yes, makes sense. Thank you.
>> Okay. We probably need to
>> All right. Are we ready to move to our
consent agenda?
>> All right. So Oh, there's there's the
map. Are you talking about?
>> Yeah,
>> that's fine.
>> Thank you. Okay. Uh, we'll now move to
the consent agenda. Does anyone have a
consent agenda item to pull for a
separate vote?
I make a motion to approve consent
agenda items 6.1, 7.1, 7.2, 8.1, 8.2,
8.3, 9.1, 9.2, 10.1, 10.2, 10.3, 11.1,
12.1, 12.2, 2 and 12.3. Is there a
second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Um, any discussion on these
items?
>> All right. Having a motion by Vice
President Willu and a second by Trustee
Kintana to approve agenda items 6.1,
7.1, 7.2, 8.1 through 8.3, 9.1, 9.2, 2
10.1 through 10.3
and uh 11.1 12.1 through 12.3. Um all in
favor please raise your right hand
and the motion carries by all those on
the dis. Thank you very much. Um
next up is one moment. Um do we have a
motion to approve item 13.1?
>> Yes, I move to approve agenda item 13.1.
Um, okay. Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Any discussion?
>> Okay. Having a motion by Vice President
Will IU, a second by Trustee Kintana to
approve agenda item 13.1. All in favor,
please raise your hand. All in favor,
Kevin.
>> Oh, you're abstaining. Sorry.
Abstaining. All in favor? Yes. Okay. All
opposed. All abstaining, including
Kevin. Thank you. Okay. Motion is seven
in favor, none opposed into abstaining.
Um, next up 13.2.
>> I move to approve agenda item 13.2.
>> Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Thank you. Any discussion?
>> Yeah,
>> on and voted yes.
>> Yes, Andrew voted. Yes.
>> Okay. Any discussion on 13.2.
>> All right. Uh, all in favor, please
raise your right hand.
Any opposed? and abstensions. Thank you.
Uh motion carries with seven in favor,
zero opposed, and two abstaining. Um do
we have a motion to approve agenda item
14.1?
>> I move to approve agenda item 14.1,
approval of tea turnaround plans.
>> Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Any discussion?
>> President Boswell?
>> Yes. I'd like to make a motion to amend
the Widane turnaround plan from a
uh closure and reassign to a restart.
>> Okay. Um do we have a second on that?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Uh any discussion?
>> Um I'm not going to belver the point. I
think that we've had this conversation
um um throughout our six uh or seven
hour meeting so far. So um
that's it. Thank you.
>> Okay. Any further discussion? Any
questions?
>> Okay.
>> This is just on the first amendment,
right?
>> This is on the Are we amending the
turnaround plan to remove that? Correct.
>> Or to change. Um, okay. I do have a
question. Um, so Mr. Sakura, when is
this turnaround plan due to tea?
>> Um, it's due today.
>> It's due today.
>> Um, yeah, by 6 p.m. 5 p.m. 5:00 p.m. So
5:00 p.m. today.
Do you have any concerns about your
staff's yourself's ability to
create a new turnaround plan today
after this meeting that would be
approved by TEA?
>> It's
it would be very difficult. Um
I it I mean it would be difficult.
>> Okay. Any further discussion?
>> I mean I I
recognize the difficulty of it but I I
want to just acknowledge again that this
hearing was held the day before they
were due. And so the timeline that we
have agreed to put us in a situation
where we have to make a decision tonight
and then action has to be taken
tomorrow. So that's where we are. So I
don't want our decision to be impacted
by I mean I empathize with the demands
that would place on the staff. Um but
you know that's not the issue.
I think if
um
you know we could have produced a
an alternative plan
if we would have known that that was
going to be um something to that we
needed to do. Uh, and so I I know we
weren't able to have the work session
last week, but I did a presentation to
share with the community what was in the
plans. Um,
these so I I I it's tough. I mean, I I
you know, anything's possible, but it
would be very difficult. Uh, but again,
I will do what the board asks,
what the board decides.
And I have I have a question for um our
council. All right. So on um so the
motion on the floor
um wait a yes vote on the motion on the
floor
be requiring
the turnaround plan for
>> to be amended that's turned into today.
>> You'd be voting on the amendment. So the
the new motion then would be to approve
14.1
with a change to include a turnaround
plan for Wedane instead of a closure
>> or is that right? Am I saying that
right?
>> Okay. So that's so so you got to vote on
the amendment first. If it is approved,
then that's the new motion.
>> And then a no vote would then
>> if Yeah.
>> allow a new motion to be
>> Yeah. So if uh if you take a vote on the
amendment and it fails, um you have the
underlying motion is still live. So, if
that, you know, you could entertain
further motions to amend um or at
whatever point you're ready to take the
vote.
>> Thank you. Uh I have a suggestion. I'd
love to hear from council. Um could we
make a new motion to do we have to vote
on that motion and could we make a new
motion to approve all the turnaround
plans except that one and then take a
separate motion on that one?
>> So, you have a a live motion to amend.
You need to vote on that and see how
that goes.
>> But if we if we don't approve that, then
we could vote to pull that one out
>> if we chose to.
>> So what you would want to do at that
point, if that vote fails, you still
have the motion on the floor. Approve
them all. Okay. Thank you.
>> So then you'd need another amendment.
>> Okay. Any discussion? Further
discussion?
>> All right. So um we have a motion from
trustee Kintana to amend the turnaround
plans to make the win turnaround plan.
Wuane sorry the Wuane turnaround plan a
restart rather um than a reassignment.
Uh we have a second from trustee de
urost. All in favor of that plan please
raise your hand.
Any opposed?
Okay. Um, the motion fails and we have
the the second motion.
>> So, I would like to propose an amendment
as well.
>> Yes.
>> Um, I propose that we amend the
turnaround plan for Oak Springs to be a
restart.
>> Okay. Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Um having a motion by uh we have a
motion by trustee deoste and a second by
trustee hunter. Any discussion?
>> So I I just want to point out that there
has been um extensive advocacy by both
of these groups proposing a restart and
so I did want to honor that and uh I do
believe it deserves a consideration.
>> Okay.
Uh any further discussion?
Okay. So, we have a motion from Trustee
Deioce to um amend our turnaround our
turnaround plan um vote to consider to
change Oak Springs to a restart. We have
a second from Trusty Hunter. All in
favor?
Any opposed?
Okay. So, um motion carries. Three in
favor. Six. Wait, sorry, Andrew.
54. Okay. Sorry, Andrew. Thank you.
>> It does doesn't carry. Motion fails. 54.
It's very late. Very early. Thank you.
Um
All right. Um
I have a motion. I would love to vote on
everything but Winn and Wuane
separately.
>> So you want to amend the motion to
approve by removing Winn and Wane? Did
you say Winn and Wane?
Is there a second?
>> Second.
>> Second. I'd like to pull Win and Wu Jane
and just vote on them separately because
they're the ones that send F schools to
D's
and I'd like to vote on them separately.
Um, okay. We have a motion and a second.
Would any any discussion?
>> Okay.
>> I would like to understand Why?
>> I am I am
challenged by the idea of voting in
favor of something that goes against
TEA's written guidance even though we
understand that we have had verbal
guidance and I'm having trouble
voting in favor of those.
>> That would that would also include
Bington Josh with Waldridge receiving
>> plurality.
It doesn't. But she's the plurality
doesn't matter.
>> Bington is also going to
>> Waldridge.
>> Waldridge to Bington.
>> It's a minority.
>> Yeah.
>> To Marshall.
>> Marshall. Yeah. So you'd add four.
>> Which ones are receiving? I'm curious
about the ones that are receiving the
tap where a D is receiving the tap, not
just where some students are being
assigned, reassigned.
>> Just the tap.
>> That would just be
>> and those are the two.
>> Okay. I'm concerned about. Yes, I
understand students are some students
are being resigned. I'm concerned about
who's receiving that time.
>> Um, any further discussion?
>> Yeah. Um, Mr. Sakura,
yes or no question? Okay.
>> Not good.
>> Realistically, I know you're not.
Realistically,
is the staff able to submit a revised
plan
today to the Texas Education Agency that
the Texas A Education Agency would be
likely to approve? In your opinion, yes
or no?
Um,
it's
it is un it would be I I I I
want to be responsive to the
>> Okay. Would it be like it's hard for me
to say would TA be likely to approve it
or unlikely to approve a plan that was
revised and submitted
>> by the staff
in the next few hours? Maybe you can say
less likely. That might be easier to
answer.
>> I I would say that.
>> Do you think that's a good idea for us
to do you recommend doing that?
>> I I do I do not um believe a change at
this hour is going to put us in a better
position to have them be accepted.
>> Thank you. Can I just I find that
curious because we're turning them in
tomorrow anyways
then today and they haven't seen
anything official. So what would it
change to them if they see something
like it would?
>> Well, so we've been meeting with them.
We're being we've been meeting this
entire time with individuals who are
reviewing the plans and are giving
they've given us verbal feedback along
the entire way. Um and these are these
are the individuals who review the
plans,
>> right?
>> Um
>> but
>> so it would be new to
>> are they
so
>> if I have a question. So but that plan
does not exist currently. Staff would
have to create the turnaround plan.
>> Correct. We would have to create a a new
a new plan
>> 1 now am 5:00 p.m.
>> or probably before that because you need
to check it and all that sort of stuff.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Correct. So they have not received it
but those who are reviewing it have
already seen these sets of plans. So it
would it would be new as far as what
they believe we are doing
>> that if that's helpful
>> and do they have is it required that
they have a heads up or some sense of
what the plan is going to look like? Uh,
no. I I think in an effort to be um
hyper responsive and ensure that we had
the highest probability of success um
I've I've always believed in engaging
early, getting feedback and input. I
think our board has asked me to do I I
believe in that. Um and so it's not a
requirement. No.
>> Okay.
>> And I will say for the record, I I trust
that you've had those conversations. I
am uncomfortable enough with this. I am
asking to vote on these separately
because I want to vote in favor of the
other ones and I would like to be on the
record with expressing my discomfort
about what we're doing given the fact
that it's not a sure thing with tea and
we are going against and I think it's to
me I would like to just make a record of
that. So that is my hope. I don't expect
this to be upended. I've I've checked
with council if it happens to be voted
down we still have to turn something in.
We have the opportunity to vote again.
Um, but I I think it is important to
just have a record as a board that we
are aware of this and that we're paying
attention to this and that we know this.
>> So if it gets voted if it gets separated
and voted down, we can vote again.
>> Yeah. I mean, it's not ideal, but you
can set aside Robert's rules and take
another vote. So, for example, let's
just say we were only voting on 14.1
and it fails. The trustees could
consider if they wanted to to make a
motion to set aside Robert's rules for
the purpose of voting again. They could
do that.
>> And we're a body under 12.
>> What's that?
>> We're a body under 12.
>> Can we do that because of that? Because
of that. We're a body.
>> Yeah, you can do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Um,
>> and I I would very much love to vote
against every single one of these in
solidarity with the community and with
my concern about where we've come to at
this point and why these are our only
options available. But I also want to
fully support the district and the work
that we need to do next. And I I would
like to vote in favor of all the plans
that I don't even agree with fully
knowing that I need to trust the
administration
or we need to move on. But I need to
trust my administration at this time. So
that's why I would choose to to keep
them as a package and to go into this
very difficult period of time of
implementing these plans with some you
know with my support for the
administration doing it. So that's my
reason for not wanting to split them.
>> Absolutely fair. Yeah. trusty sing.
>> So, um I plan to to support all of them,
but I for the reasons I appreciate you
for um sharing your rationale for
wanting to split them, and I would pro I
would support the motion, but I would
still vote to um adopt all the taps.
>> And I very much
appreciate that we are independent
people on this board and that we each
have our own vote. And I would fully
respect and support what you do. I'm
just indicating what I would I would
choose not to, but I fully support that
>> we are stronger when we voice our own
opinions than when we build our
conscience. So, thank you.
>> Thank you. I appreciate it. Any further
discussion?
>> Okay. Having a motion by uh Trusty
Boswell to pull Wu Jane and W for a
separate vote and approve the turnaround
plans except those two. A second by
Trusty Nitana. All in favor, please
raise your hand.
Wait, this is
>> that's just just to be clear. The motion
that you're voting
>> Oh, sorry.
>> Amend the underlying motion to
>> to amend the underlying motion to remove
>> when and Wuane
>> for a separate vote.
>> Thank you.
>> For a separate vote.
>> For separate
>> for a separate vote.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. To remove Win and Wane for a
separate vote.
>> So if you want to remove Winn and Wu
Jane for a separate vote, raise your
hand.
Okay. And I'm counting. Okay. One, two,
three, four. Okay. Okay. So, the motion
is to vote on those separately. It's
five in favor. Uh, any opposed?
>> Candace was raising a finger. I thought
>> was your hand up or down, Candace? Two
opposed.
>> Any abstaining? It was up.
>> Up to pull it to remove it. Okay. So, we
have seven in favor of removing, two in
favor of keeping. Okay. So, the motion
carries. So, we will vote now on the
other turnaround plans. absent when and
Wuane
>> and yes okay
>> do we need a new motion for that
>> so your motion now is to approve item
14.1 as amended
>> okay so um do I have a motion to approve
item 14.1 as amended
>> I move to
>> I move to approve item 14.1 as amended
>> thank you
>> do we have a second
>> trusty sing any discussion
Okay. Have a motion by Vice President
Willie Chu, a second by Trusty Singh to
remove item 14.1 as amended. All in
favor, please raise your hand.
Uh, any opposed?
>> We have one.
>> Please restate.
>> We are approving item 14.1 as amended.
>> Yes. Um and we have eight in favor and
um Trustee Gonzalez opposed. Thank you.
All right. Um and now we will move to
approve the turnaround plans for Wedane
and when
>> do you want to do a separate vote for
when and a separate vote for? I
>> I'm okay approving them together. We
have a motion. Okay. Um I'd like to move
to approve Wudane and when the
turnaround plans for Wane and together.
Do we have a second?
Second
>> trusty sing any discussion?
>> Yes. Um
I have a concern about a restart for
when because a restart requires that you
do the teacher thing, right?
>> And that's a very specialized those
teachers cannot they got to stay right
where they are.
>> Yeah.
>> So I'm asking is if you do a restart,
will they have to turn over teachers?
>> Oh yeah. I I I think um
one of the things that I think we're
gonna have to contemplate is that it's
not gonna be a monastery.
>> This is what I'm saying.
>> It would be it would be it would be a
restart as a traditional.
>> Are we talking about when orane right
now? You said when
>> my question is about when
>> and my motion isn't to turn them into
restarts. My motion is just to we're
voting to approve them separately.
>> Oh, I missed
>> approve them as presented by the
administration. Just approve them
separately. Um, so we're just voting on
them separately because they are the
ones that assign students to a D
>> assign the top to a D-rated school.
>> Why don't just name one move for?
>> Well, I've moved for both together.
>> Yeah, I move for both together.
>> Wait a minute. I'm confused now. I
thought we had Wedane and Oak Springs.
>> No,
>> because that motion failed. This is not
to turn either of them into a restart.
This is to approve. So I will restate
that motion more explicitly. I move to
approve the turnaround plans for Wyn and
Wuane as as presented by the
administration.
>> Do we have a second?
>> It's already it's already on the table.
So that's what we're looking. We have a
second by trustee saying okay any
further discussion.
Okay. All in favor?
to actually
>> one two
>> we're approving the turnaround plans for
win and wuane.
>> So
yes,
>> oh as presented
>> as presented as presented we are
approving the turnaround plans for win.
>> Yes, approving the taps. Okay, one, two,
three, four, five. Okay, we have five in
favor. Any opposed?
and we have four opposed and the motion
carries to approve the turnaround plans
for Winn and Wuane as presented by the
administration. So we have now approved
all turnaround plans. Thank you. Um and
thank you to our council for walking us
through that very complicated thing.
Okay. Um next is uh item 14.2. Vice
President Willu, do we have a motion?
I I move to approve item 14.2.
>> Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Having a uh do we have any discussion?
>> Um Mr. Sigura. So my understanding is
that so 14.1
are the turnaround plans that the board
has just approved that were
>> correct.
>> Okay. And 14.2 two are the other parts
that are necessary to be implemented as
part of the turnaround plan.
>> That's correct.
>> Thank you.
Okay. Any further discussion?
>> Okay. Having a motion by Vice President
Lily Chu, a second by Trustee Singh. All
in favor, please raise your right hand.
Any opposed?
Okay, motion passes 7 to two.
Um, okay. Do we have a motion for 14.3?
>> I'll move to approve the consolidation
plan components related to programmatic
moves.
>> Okay. Do we have a second?
>> Second.
>> Okay. Any discussion? Yeah, I'd like to
propose um some amended language that I
have emailed. I emailed it to um the
president and vice president as well as
our council, but this is just to lift up
the language around the modified program
moves. Um so there's five things. Do I
need to read them all into the record?
Right.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Or I can.
>> Yes. Okay. So, um I would like to move
to amend five items. One is to um please
call Ridgetop Becker and Riley modified
program moves instead of program moves.
Um the second
one is under Riley on page seven
to please modify the sentence. The
schoolwide dual language program would
be introduced to Wooten Elementary
School as a two-way dual language
program to the schoolwide dual language
program would be converted to a two-way
dual language program at Wooten that is
not wallto-wall.
Um and then same thing for Becker on
page six. Please change the schoolwide
dual language program. Um
wait, the schoolwide dual language
program would be introduced to Sanchez
Elementary School as two-way dual
language program too. The schoolwide
dual language program would be converted
to a two-way dual language program at
Sanchez. That is not wall-to-wall. And
then four, under Rich, page six, please
change the schoolwide dual language
program. No, the schoolwide dual
language program would be introduced to
Pickle Elementary School is a two-way
dual language program to the schoolwide
dual language program would be converted
to a two-way dual language program at
Pickle that is not wallto-wall. And then
the fifth item is to please strike this
sentence on page three. the three
schoolwide dual language programs,
Becker, Richtop, and Riley, would
relocate and be introduced as two-way
dual language programs at Sanchez,
Pickle, and Wooten Elementary Schools.
Um, the rationale is that I'm not saying
like none of this might happen, but
until we've done the academic planning
work, I don't want to promise something
to our community that's going to happen,
um, which would introduce even more
disappointment and confusion down the
road. So, I'd rather just state what we
are doing right now and
that's it.
>> Okay. So, you're moving to amend
>> amend the document that we are actually
voting on to incl to make these changes
that I've emailed to Josh and others.
>> So, it's a it's a motion to amend the
motion to approve subject to the listed
>> yes
>> modifications.
>> Okay. Do we have a second?
Second.
>> Okay. Uh, is there any discussion?
>> I just like to get the administration's
opinion on whether that language is
clearly defining what
>> Yeah. I I was going to ask a vet, do you
want to come up and help us work through
this? Um, and maybe Dr. Maxwell. I'm
just trying to make sure that the
language doesn't change
how we approach the prioritization of
students moving from those schools to
the receiving schools.
Um because if we're severing
you know the program because the the
idea if you're moving a program then
that you'd focus on the students who are
impacted by the movement of the program
and so if we sever the l if the language
severs does that change our priority
transfer
strategies that we put in place. Um so I
want to make sure I hear the language
again before we respond to that. F first
could can I ask council um if this if
like a this word smithing this
>> substantively changes any
anything in the plan
>> the plan
>> that's I think that's the question for
them
>> yeah I'm asking that's part of what I'm
asking
>> yeah I think the modified is is fine so
the schoolwide the language program
would be introduced to Wen because the
idea is that it's intro introduced.
Therefore, right, once the tap is
broken, it would convert fully into a
wall to wall. What this is saying is
strike that and and don't um don't uh
assume that we're going to convert into
a wallto-wall.
>> That's right. Because because when you
do the it's not that I don't like
wall-to-wall programs. The the bigger
issue is it's going to introduce another
large change to that community in the
very near future. and we haven't even
had a conversation yet and adopted our
our our vision for dual language as a
district when it comes to that.
>> Yeah. And and I think the reason we had
the language in there is because on the
October 3rd and 31st submission, the
before we made the adjustment to ensure
that students that were zoned were at
the school, which meant that the tap had
to stay. The intent was to move towards
a a wallto-wall. Um so that's why we
wrote it that way to begin with. Um, you
know, I think I understand the
conversation around um the academic plan
and vision to figure out what we want to
do. This this is um
I think it'll work both ways in year one
and two most likely, right? The question
is, are we committing to what happens
afterwards?
>> I mean, I think if it's too complicated,
I think I would be okay with just number
one and number five um in my email.
>> Tristes, I've just emailed it to all of
you. So if you need to see it might
help.
>> And number one again is to just rename
what we're calling BridgeTop Becker and
Riley as a modified program move instead
of just a program move.
>> Um and then the last one is to strike
the sentence that the three schoolwide
dual language programs would relocate
and be introduced
as a two-way I mean you know
as a two-way dual language program at
Sanchez Pickle and Wooten
Elementaryaries.
>> Yeah. I I mean, you know, it's it's the
I would just say that it's it's
different than what we had been kind of
planning on for the really the vast
majority of this process. And I
understand, you know, the change over
the last two weeks and why we pivoted to
ensure that those schools didn't have
the disruption, the ones where that
currently reside. Um it is no longer
committing to a future wallto-wall.
Correct. Right. Which is
>> Yeah. Because cuz I think because think
about it y'all like if we if we are
committing right now to future wallto-w
wall after the tap that to me sounds a
little premature because we don't even
know like what our situation's going to
be two years from now and we haven't
done that with any of the other schools.
So it's like
>> well ODM will be a wall to wall already.
>> Yeah. And that's why I didn't include
anything about ODM in my in my
amendment. But I just I feel like we I
need to learn a lot more about the
justification for doing wall-to-all
programs and we have such a scarcity of
dual language certified teachers and
I've been bringing that up for like for
weeks and weeks and weeks and so I I
that that's why I'm raising this but
again I'm one person so I don't know how
my colleagues feel but this is the
motion. Yeah, I think I think with so
much like being uncomfortable with this
is a good reason for for an up or down
vote and if if a trustee isn't
comfortable voting it down so there is
time to make a real plan with the
community.
>> Okay. Well, the motions
>> my motion is to make the changes that
are in my email if if it is something
that doesn't conflict and create a
ripple effect. I think we're waiting to
find that out.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I think we're okay on the on the the
transfers are there or one member these
are transition transfers, right? Um so
that would hold next year regardless of
the language. My only concern I guess
regarding the language is that
the throughout the entire process
because we started with four wallto-
walls or generally four to walls Riley
you know the goal was to get back to
that um and I understand why the
language is being introduced um
and and so I just want to acknowledge
that that it would be a shift and I get
the shift recently because of the tap
but the goal was to get back to a
wallto-all now this would just pause
that until after you have the
conversation in the spring.
>> Yeah, I think we can definitely revisit
that once we've done the work that again
that's kind of where I would stand on
this is yeah, let's actually revisit
this.
Are are you confident that the Sanchez
and Pickle and Wooten communities
understand that
because even the even the Richtop
families weren't understanding many of
them weren't understanding that the plan
was for Ble and Wooten to become
schoolwide and they found some relief
when they found that was going to happen
but they didn't know that and they're
some of them had their most focused on
this. So I'm concerned that the
scientist communities might be
understanding. Oh, we our non-dual
language train can stay
>> and then they will find out tomorrow
morning that that was not accurate. So
I'm concerned that the communication is
not there. I would prefer to leave it
open as a process that we need to plan
for just like the other changes we still
need to plan for with engagement and to
ensure that
yeah that
>> you might
>> that's a process I feel we can still do
effective engagement with
>> are you saying
>> I support your motion
>> you support it okay
>> because I think it I don't I don't feel
comfortable committing right now to
something that I don't think was clearly
communicated to the community
>> that's right let's just Now, thank you.
>> Okay. Do we have a second? I think we we
have been discussing.
>> Trusty Hunter, I thought second.
>> Trusty Hunter seconded. Okay. A little
tired.
>> Okay. Uh do we have any further
discussion?
Okay. Um all in favor of the amendment
to um modify 14.3 with the language that
Trustee Singh um introduced. All in
favor, raise your hand. Any
opposed?
Okay, motion carries. Seven in favor,
two opposed. Okay, so we're back to the
motion to approve
um 14.3
>> as amended.
Any discussion?
I just want to acknowledge I just want
to acknowledge the difference in terms
of availability for the program for for
families coming from Becker compared to
Rich and Riley. And I don't know if we
need to put something in the plan or but
I just need some type of assurance that
if option one and two where they have
top priority at Sanchez and secondary
priority at ODM and Wooten that if those
options don't work for families that
there will be an effort you know at the
meetings you're discussing for
enrollment to find dual language
placements for them in you know where
programs exist. Again, not necessarily
creating new classrooms, you're creating
new programs, but we have hundreds of
dual language seats across the district
in programs where they where families
could be more thoroughly immersed in
Spanish with more students who are
emerging bilingual students. So, there
are many many opportunities out there
and I just want to ensure that the
Becker community has a place to continue
the program that we made a commitment to
to them to have.
I don't know what you all can say to
that, but I just want to have that
commitment.
>> Yes. Yes, we have that commitment as
well.
>> Thank you. So, um we're in discussion.
I just I just want to uh
lift up a note of both um gratitude but
also solace to um our communities that
are impacted by this. Uh, I think
they've showed up amazingly and um
just just represented with great
integrity. Um, the Riley community has
been amazing. The Wooten community has
been amazing. The Ridgetop community has
been uh amazing. And um
it's it's I try to
operate with enough integrity so that
I'm predictable
and I proved myself to be unpredictable
because I drew a line and said if we
pull Breer,
if we pull schools that we put on that
that would be no for me. And so I drew a
line line because that just made sense.
And the superintendent knows that my
first reaction
uh on the realization that what 14.3
would end up looking like would be
substantially different. You know, my
first note was, you know, I don't know
whether I can continue on this board.
Then I had to think and think about the
process that we've been through and the
reality that if this were, you know, 60
years ago, there would have been no
controversy at all because we just would
have done to some communities that just
would have no voice. So there would
never be a controversy because they
would just be invisible.
And then if this were just a few years
ago, we would have improved to the point
where we presented things to the public
and we introduc excuse me, introduce
some ideas of equity and we would even
listen.
But that's where it would stop and
nothing would substantively change. And
what happened this time is that we
entered into incredibly perilous and
courageous waters. Even though it
doesn't feel like that, it just feels
like chaos to some and it feels like
pain to some. But the reality is
a plan was presented by the
administration and there was intense
listening and there was refinement and
refinement and refinement. And the
courageous thing about the refinement is
that every time you refine and fix this,
you kind of break something else. And so
every refinement was jarring to a new
set of our constituents.
And yet it kept going.
Then we had a piece of failure
in that and this is my judgment of it.
And it had to do with our capacity. It
had to do with folks going on leave. It
had to do with this and that. Um, it had
to do with the imperfection of actually
trying to do something courageous where
when refinements were made,
as I said earlier tonight, I feel like a
piece ended up missing the dialogue
between we listened, we refined,
and there should have been a dialogue
moment to pull in folks to say this is
what we think it might look like. But
across 20 campuses plus impacted having
that dialogue is is was impossible.
So then the change would come out and
there was no way a community could
understand what was hitting them. It
just it's it's impossible. You got a
paragraph that is massively changing
what's happening. So at that point we
began sort of losing folks and I and I
totally get it. They're furious. They're
angry and they're also angry in the
context of a sense that wow, it wasn't
just the game. I think some folks
learned how the game really works. Some
of us know how the game works. Some of
us know that privilege protects
privilege and that that always that's
that's the norm in our nation.
And so some folks found that because
they had been willing to make the
sacrifice with the understanding that
everyone would equally sacrifice. That
ain't America.
So it is like the middle group that
actually has to be the bravest if our
world gets better because those who are
the least among us, they know what's
going to happen. Those who are the
privileged among us, they know what's
going to happen because they got the
power and the privilege to ensure that
it continues. those in the middle that
wake up to the reality and they're like,
"Hey, let's sacrifice. Let's dig in."
Then they get punched in the face. This
is what Bel Hooks would tell us that
she's like, "This is how this world
works."
And it feels like a raw injustice like
you ain't never felt before because but
we pitched in. We did what we were
supposed to do. Why is this like this?
It's cuz this is America.
So,
um I'm I'm I'm not grieving, I guess I'd
say, but I I just want to acknowledge um
just how much at least all the
communities and all the people, some of
them just really mad at us and I'm not
going to say I'm going to say us cuz I'm
in it. Cuz I'm back in the
administration and they're like, "But I
thought you were about something. I am
about something." And that had me say
there's a greater good here.
So the pickle move that was right by
pickle kids in many respects
meant this given group had to deepen
their sacrifice one more time.
And this was especially important to me
for Wooten where our kids have been on a
track for a year
and they were about to not go because we
were there. I was there, you know,
turning the shovel, having fun, taking
pictures when we broke ground for this
new Wooten. And we were telling them,
"Yeah, we were just kidding. You ain't
going to see that building." That's
that's how we had it in the plan. And we
had that in the plan until very late. It
got changed at the last minute. So, we
made a last minute change that was so
jarring. And at the end, I had to say
that was the right change to make even
though it broke hearts.
So, I just want to kind of name that and
acknowledge that um as this moves
forward and I'm only looking at, you
know, the communities that I'm dealing
with every day. I've learned so much
from so many different folks from
Breerwoods, from Becker, from Sunset
Valley, like you know, you know, our our
community reaches out. And so I've, you
know, sat and broke bread at
Rudy's, Torches, Epoch, like like all
the places. and and um they're sincere
and they're hurt and and I get it and
some are furious and I get it and some
of them are going to walk with their
feet or whatever the saying is and
they're going to make choices and I get
it. Um so as we move forward with this
consolidation components related to
programmatic moves, I find myself not
resigning as I thought I would. I find
myself not ready to vote no as I thought
I would. I find myself ready to say this
is
us moving forward and I I sure hope we
do better and keep doing better and I
see concrete ways we can do better. Um,
so I seem to always siloquise, but I
made up a new word. But, um, I feel like
I I just have to name that and just most
especially name the gratitude I feel for
our community even in their pain.
They're amazing.
>> Thank you. Any more discussion? Okay, so
we have seven trustees that said they
want to amend the plan, vote on amended
plan because there's major concerns with
it. Two trustees saying no. It it is
just very clear that this plan isn't it.
We have time unlike the state imposed
deadline. We have time to do another
plan for these schools to make a better
plan.
Voting no
allows us to do that. Otherwise, this is
the same as like draft 1, draft 2, draft
3, and this is just the draft made right
before 2 am. So, that is why I I'm going
to vote no.
speak
>> superintendent. Um how does
um postponing this process affect the
schools with turnaround plans like
Sanchez.
>> So it'll have um less of an effect now
because we've maintained the tap at
those schools, right? um which is a
change that we made as Trusty Foster
said for Woot and um Sanchez is a 3A
yeah 3UA um Wooten and uh Pickle. Uh
that being said um you know Riley,
you know, it's a little bit different
because it's a movement and a a new
school kind of at the same time. Uh and
so the one of the things that I would
say is we had been anticipating that all
of this together would allow
leaders to be in position to actually
successfully break the taps, right?
Because you you've heard about
programmatic moves. You've heard about
principles and different staff going
with the campus. So now that won't be in
play, right? So an example of this would
be educators at Riley who would like to
go to Wooten, they would no longer go,
right? Because they would choose to, I
would think, to stay at Riley perhaps
and then we would effectively um you
know kind of rethink the support system
at Wooten in a way that we hadn't
previously, right? Because because all
that movement is is connected in that
way. Uh the same would be true for
Ridgetop and um Pickle. um you know in
that instance you know as as we talked
about the goal was to have the community
largely go um if that doesn't happen
then the staff
the supports that would go with the
program wouldn't go so they would likely
stay at ridgetop and then I would have
to effectively you know do the restart
but with a different starting point like
you know because I wouldn't have staff
there so it does there would be an
impact um they wouldn't all be the
Right. I think there's different
degrees. And then you would close seven
schools opposed to 10.
Well, I guess technically four because
we're not including Sensit Valley,
right? That's included in this as well.
All right. So,
>> I move to call the question.
>> I
don't want us to lose sight.
So I mentioned ridgetop.
>> Hold on one second. Trusty Whitley Chu
asked move to call the question.
>> So now we vote on whether we want to
vote or continue.
>> Okay. Uh
if you want to call the question, raise
your hand, please. We don't need a
second, right?
>> Just go ahead. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Any opposed?
>> Calling the question
>> means Phil.
>> Okay. Thank you. Um, okay.
>> I'll be brief. Um, I don't want to lose
sight of the initial a big initial piece
of it. Bilingual certified educators
serving our kids of greatest need as
quickly as possible. Um, we have
beautiful dual language communities that
are serving 14% emergent bilingual kids.
And those bilingual certified teachers
who are wonderful are disproportionately
serving kids for whom learning Spanish
is enrichment. And we don't have enough
teachers serving kids who desperately
need to learn English. So, I I can't
support delaying
um the pro the programmatic moves that
allow that that expand our capacity to
serve our neediest kids as quickly as
possible.
>> I agree 100%. Thank you for stating
that.
>> Any additional discussion?
Um, closing these schools is not the
only way to do that.
>> Um, I have one question and then one
comment. Um I know really want to share
appreciation for the Becker community um
and other communities who have brought
we asked people to imagine advocate for
what they wanted most and that that was
my ask with you from the very beginning
the first time I met with you is
advocate for what you want the most and
help us be creative right and think
about plan B plan C. Um Trusty Hunter
was you know good, better, best, right?
Um and and I think we asked our
community to bring us ideas. Uh and I
really in a lot of ways wish we could
have started with creative ideas from
our community because there is immense
wisdom in our community. Um and I think
we would have gotten to something even
more creative, more thoughtful um than
what's in front of us. Um and and I want
to share appreciation. Um I know it's
been an immense amount of time and
emotion and thought um that you've put
into it and I I do trust um I have a a
report and I see what the administration
really I believe really considered it
and explored it and um I just have a
question. That exploration was done
before the change on Friday. Um, and I'd
really love to to be sure it's not worth
revisiting that that you still given
that the change has been significant for
the Becker community, you still feel
like that option, a a restart at Sanchez
and
putting a wall-to-wall dual language
program in 7874
is is not viable.
So we we looked at all the different
models and we're really looking again
based on the proposals looking for ways
to increase the number of emergent
bilingual students participating.
And so unfortunately within that area
when you start to look at you know who's
in certain schools so some schools
within the four mile radius or even
schools like cassiss that don't have a
dual language program and so there just
we couldn't get to a point where we were
reaching um at least 50% emergent
bilingual even when we were looking at
other looking at Galindo looking at
Zilker looking at just different Dawson
looking at different um campuses in the
area. So, we really did um take the if
you've seen the document like we've
really took each step in each proposal
and looked at different combinations.
We weren't able to reach that.
>> Thank you. Um
I will share
really echo um Trusty Kaufman's comment
that um if the vote is to close these
schools um Becker is in a an a unique
position in this where they are really
suffering you know being broken up in a
way that other communities are not. Um,
and and we talked for many many weeks
about plans that weren't going to do
that. And I think we really need to
honor that and lean really hard into as
much space as we can make at ODM into
whatever we can do to to maintain what
we can um for people who've really
chosen and invested in our our schools
um and who've chosen something for their
students that really needs to remain uh
as intact as it possibly can be. if
that's the way this goes. And and I
don't see anything in this yet that does
that. And I just really want to
challenge um the administration to do
everything they can to
bring some
get that situation closer to what the
other wall-to-wall schools have um
because it feels really unjust
um and unfair. Thank you.
Um any additional comments?
Okay.
Um, having a motion by Trustee Singh and
a second by Trustee Hunter to approve
agenda item 14.3
as amended. All in favor, please raise
your right hand.
We're approving item 14.3 with the
language but Arthy amended.
>> Yes.
>> It's late. Any opposed?
>> And the motion carries six to three.
>> Yeah.
>> Can I ask for a point of privilege?
>> Yes.
So,
I just want to point out
as succinctly as I can, no metaphors,
um,
you know, I was a teacher in this
district and I remember feeling the
weight of the world on my shoulders as
an SPS teacher, scores teacher. um that
if something happened, it was going to
be my fault, that I was the one
responsible for everything in that
classroom and that it extended basically
to the entire campus, to the entire
district. I always felt like I was the
one that was going to get in trouble.
And I want to make it clear, you know,
there were comments earlier on the
call-ins that, you know, the loudest
advocates were the ones that got what
they wanted. if we had known that we
needed to be more aggressive or that we
needed to, you know, basically yell at
the district more, we would have gotten
heard. And I want to be really clear to
the public that that's not what happened
here. And that if you have been watching
the board through this whole process,
um, you know, now I'm arguably more on
the administration, right? I'm not in
the administration, I'm governing. Um,
and a lot of the discussion has been
about what you're modeling um, down
right to the people that work for you,
the people in your teams. Um, I want to
be clear that I have never met anyone in
all my time in the district that didn't
want to be here to serve students. And I
cannot
think it's only an assumption that that
feeling that I had as a teacher is felt
by every person in this building working
to try and help students. And so when
people say
that they think something malicious is
going on or that there's some other plan
or that everything's already
preconceived, I understand how that
looks. Um, you know, I I advocate for
families outside of the district all
over Texas. You know, I understand the
confusion and and you know, the
heartache around it. Um, I do feel that
as a teacher,
very rarely did the families understand
the pressure that I had being in the
classroom. And similarly, I don't think
the community really understands the
pressure that the administration is
under. And certainly there is a scarcity
of time, a manufactured scarcity some
might argue. And so I just want to call
out and thank everyone that has worked
tirelessly throughout this process. Um
even though it was imperfect, even
though it really got messed up from how
it started. Um and it's nobody here's
fault. Um that's just the real world.
Um, so in acknowledging the families and
acknowledging the hardship that we're
going through, I just want to be clear
that everybody else is feeling it too
and that it's a little bit different
than it seems from the outside. Um, I
you know I I know that's hard to
believe. That's why I'm saying I'm I'm
not saying trust me because I know so
much of what the community is hearing is
trust us, trust us, trust us. So that's
not what I'm sharing. I'm sharing my
personal experience as someone that's
come up from being a substitute teacher,
a TA, a teacher, you know, now I'm on
the school board. Um, that's my belief.
So, you don't have to trust me. I'm just
telling you what I believe. And, uh, and
so in that, I'm thanking the community.
I'm acknowledging the hardship that
we're enduring. Um, and I'm also
thanking the administration um, for the
hardship and the weight that I know
everybody in here is feeling. Then I
move to approve agenda item 14.4.
>> Um, do we have a second?
>> To approve agenda item 14.4.
>> Propers termination of a professional
employee during a term.
>> Second.
>> Okay. Having a motion uh by Vice
President Willie Chu and a second by
Trustee Kintana to approve agenda item
14.4.
All in favor, please raise your right
hand.
And the motion passes by uh No. Any
opposed? Any abstaining?
Uh motion passes. Eight in favor, zero
opposed, one abstaining. Um I just want
to honor anyone else who wants to make a
comment before we Oh, you were
abstaining, too. Two abstaining.
>> No, I voted in favor.
>> Oh, you voted in favor. Eight in favor.
Sorry, I am really tired apparently.
Eight in favor, one abstaining. Thank
you. Um, thank you, Trusty Gonzalez. Um,
I do want to honor anyone else who wants
to make a comment before we adjourn for
um, the evening.
Okay, thank you. Um, we will now recess
our open meeting at 2:3 a.m. and move to
a very brief executive session pursuant
to Texas government code sections 551.0
074 551.072
551.073
551.087
551.076
551.0821
and 551.071.
When we finish with executive session,
we will briefly return to the open
session to formally adjourn the meeting.
The adjournment will be recorded and
included in all replays of tonight's
meeting. Thank you for joining us and
have a good evening.
Do I have a motion to adjurnn the
meeting?
>> I move to adjourn the meeting.